o
date to over E3 twenty
twenty one it is a huge day
today possibly the biggest
day of the entire E3 show
because it is a back to
back or press conferences
today and you. But you're
also going to be here the
whole day break him down
expert analysis we're gonna
have a great time so
kicking off this morning
we've got Xbox and Bethesda
and we've got Square Enix
presents a little facts the
bloods and then PC gaming
show and future games show
so here joining me to break
down everything that's
happening today. Is
jordan ramee. Go and- let's
talk about James Bay. Is a
huge they E3 said like I
already said- but it's kind
of because I is already
started the new cycle in
and is like they you go a
bunch of an I of the way le
week they released this big
video of those kind of
talking about Xbox is on
for the future a lot of
really cool tidbits and
that so let's talk about
those briefly first. Our
those with the fact that
Xbox is an explore putting
the X. straight into TV. I
don't want to invoke stadia
here because it feels like
Xbox way more of plan. To
do with all that because
gamer stuff they Google for
stay was because- worked
and we it when we're it was
but like the pricing. Was
of a mac like the wrong was
not good you X. you or has
the stable of incredible.
State first party developer.
Famous franchises. Time and
do you think this is to be
something they'll discuss
more in this press conf. Or
is it some that they just
kind of men now and they'll
talk about lights up. I
think they will discuss. X.
and kind of plan. To prop.
Their that. Within more.
Area of winds. And device.
And I am excited to hear
about that and you know you.
Arison to stadia and- one
of my favorable come. For a
is act what like I've X.
cloud bunch of such. Both
bring from bad didn't to
cut into service you know
just using screens to using
it. Connected and almost in
a city I had a playboy.
Some of it was in good to
the point where if like
there was lack everything
too far quality. Stadium
the other hand very the
opposite case I've little
to no success playing back
game and I always very much
aware of the fact I'm being
streamed a game. So the
idea of that technology
being shown in just
everyday devices like TV is
incredibly exciting because
I have firsthand experience
of it working really well
using just the phone. And
TV's are quite capable of
more- and these days than
they have been in the past
so I do hope we see and I
hope that they show off and
it definitely feels
although for most people
that come with this for
games. It definitely is a
feather in microsoft cap
and I hope that they take
it off and wavy on tickle
people's knows. Making
sneeze that. Well yeah I
mean Gaming so they meant
that things like- and- is
going to be coming to. The
it will- it's eventually
coming to sort of Xbox.
National on consoles. But I
most X. and Phil Spencer
has T. this before- why my
because of how worked with
this but- remember that the-
from. For down writers is
supposed to be super
impressive like bill to the
cloud but if like they sort
of prematurely and- all
that. But now Xbox is
doubling down and saying.
Cloud developer. .com it's
gonna be something they
read reading. On for to
join. Do you think we're
going to of see game and I
being. Hi developed in the
conduct devote in the class.
Did did tease again last
week. Easily you sell this.
Hardware physical version
find it on the Xbox store.
And there's a cloud based
version that you can. Play
reacts cloud but- I mean
there's probably a bunch of
people out there who are
not that. Additional idea
of the console PC gamer and
so the idea of the game
specifically made. For the-
that they can just stream
on to their phone onto
their laptop onto their
iPad from anywhere is
probably like super
appealing to them and so
there could just be this
entire audience out there
that. I'm just not a part
of but that Phil Spencer in
his infinite wisdom he can
see from the top of his
Xbox mountain. And so I
would not be surprised if
we get like a few cloud.
Based entire games
announced at E. three this
year. Yeah I I'm I'm very
intrigued and I think the
other thing I before we
took our games
specifically- so they talk
about last week was oversee
the impacted GamePass is
having so- a couple of
stocks at like GamePass.
Owners and uses I play 30%
more genres and 40% more
games animal like. 50% we
spend 50% more on actual
content whether that be
DLC- buying games out right
so. GamePass obviously
isn't scripture model that
is really just. Gamer world
on fire a little bit today-
we already had a leak I the
young because a like a
dragon is coming. To
GamePass. I like to I love
yeah but it took me three
months to play yakuza zero
and I bought yeah because a
like a dragon out loans and
I'm still only in chapter
four I could avoid it. You
know I'm happy I'm happy to
give. Me but I'm like I'm
it. Just a refined. But I
imagine there be overseas
huge and on GamePass today-
do you think there's any
other surprises that could
possibly comes the service.
Not even just game
specifically we know the EA
plays a part GamePass
ultimate. Could there be a
sneaky amounts of something
like. Warner brothers games
or Ubisoft's games coming
to the service time. Yeah
well there's been- I kind
of grew mac and- almost
leak that back for blood
might be coming to the
GamePass service so we'll
see if that's a thing that
would be a huge huge thing
for I'm that game I imagine
I'm so GamePass. You know
where and when having an a
kind of age right now where
everyone seems to be making
a left for dead game again.
S. and the vampire the
masquerade game and
quarantine and the others-
so and the team that
originally made left for
dead then next game dating
back for blood. Being on
Xbox service is incredibly
enticing and I imagined a
mock as such- and- like we
said before if anything
Xbox game policies impact
can be seen. In our riders
where that came you know I
would say he had massive my
presence and awareness
coming up to release but-
it certainly call a huge
boost from being on
GamePass and the community
was given a very healthy
injection. I feel like
something like facts of
blood is going to benefit
massively if is there on
day one and you don't have
to fire. I know I sure as
hell will be 5 playing on
on- game costs and if I
don't have a subscription
Dan. Correct if it's locked
the subscribing. To slacks
and I'm because that makes
perfect sense like I tell
all my friends that stay on
Xbox because- it's on Xbox
for free and. We can all
get in and no added cost.
Yeah this is the it's like
how we also playing like
project when. Right because
it was just under. And
worked on like consul and-
so I can I really hoped
michael highgam would re
are true- but I guess we
will find out later today
so let's discuss some of
the games. That I that we
know will be present at
Xbox because this showcase
today all we can kind of.
See you maybe even ones
that we just really really
hope to see so I think
it's- fairly. Many of to
say. That halo gonna have a
huge. Today it's also Xbox
is the twentieth
anniversary this year so I
imagine that kind of
definitely be. Holding on
to those sort of legacy
franchises that they have
Jordan Voght what do you
need to see from hello and-
because obviously we have
seen game played before but
maybe didn't have. The
impact that I think three
for three in Xbox wanted it
to. Yeah I guess I just
want a more definitive idea
of exactly how he'll
infinite. Plays with the
idea of this. Open an issue
world setting that it's
doing like call of duty
battlefield inhale of all
evolved over the years and
halos finally coming back
they're trying to recover
from the- not super well
received campaign of halo
five guardians but the
pretty good multiplayer
phillips' 5. Guardians and
just the idea that we're
going acted chief and we're
going to be playing on this
world that looks a lot like
the original halo but
they're going to try to
adjust the formula just a
little bit where it's like
oh there's multiple
objectives that you can
kind of like choose how to.
Tackle and like whatever
order you want like that's
a shift from regional halos
like we just do these
campaigns of huge set
pieces I'm like I'm I'm not
convinced that this change
is necessarily a good
change I mean sometimes
change is good sometimes
change is bad and I just. I
want a better idea of how
this adjustment to the
campaign what it does for
halo what it does for its
storytelling so they give
us some sort of extended
look at like a five to
eight minute look at the
campaign missions on like
this is how this campaign
mission might. Play out for
you if you chose to do this
one optional thing it might
just how the mission
changes but the story stays
the same I just want to see
that I want confirmation
that it was still those
big. Set piece style.
Campaign missions and
everything. Yeah and I mean
time. I to play a lot of
halo I know you kind of
falling off in recent years
what is halo infinite need
to do to bring you back. I
think it just needs to feel
like it has a- I think you
need to feel distinct I
think the problem that I've
had with halo and I've
played every single halo
game extensively up until
this point even handle was.
And I think that the issue
with the franchise- I
personally found is when it
called coal kind of in the
middle between. Knowing
what it is and its own
identity and the trends of
what first person shooters
were becoming at the time.
You know call of duty and
those kind of games kind
of. You sucked in a little
ways they redefined how a
first person shooter is
played and hello was the
franchise that defined how
first person shooters. Are
played on consoles you know
it it was the first game
that you played on a
console like this works and
it feels good. Then call of
duty came along did what it
did but did it ben howard
ADS and sprint and that
kind of stuff and- connect
hello in a really weird
place where it started to
feel like it wasn't rainy.
Keeping up with anything
else and then I started
doing my cost measures
into. One side and while
also trying to maintain its
own identity and it became
this thing that didn't
really know what it was and
it didn't feel confident in
what he was doing. They
started to get a bit more
of that back with more
recent games. I hope that
they they have a little
they have more of a defined
vision for how this game
should play. And that's
what I need to go into it.
To get me excited about it
I want them to know whether
this thing is a sprint or
not sprint came. And they
commit to that I want them
to know whether they're
going to have we had
abilities and that kind of
stuff. And lean into what
makes it interesting
obviously I still want some
interesting new different
kind of innovations and
mechanics but- I don't.
Necessarily expect that at
this point I'd be happy if
halo plays like halo. Just
because well I stage now
where all first person
issue is playing the same
so if they just did another
classic style halo I think
you would be unique enough
on its own to be almost
anachronistic. And call me
back in- so yeah I that's
what he needs do and also.
Some good epic about and-
you know I decent story.
I'm tired of also we
watching like she says all
doing- that's- over. So you.
Weight random team. Nine
seven. Yeah I think I
that's the day can have to
tow right you want to with
a game like halo you have
this cool D. N. A. like the
cool pillows of what a halo
game is or at least what a
halo game wise but then you
have the sensitivities of a
modern first person shooter
player because first person
shooters have evolved
significantly like you said
and so I'm gonna I'm
particularly very
interested to see if halo
is going to stick to its
guns no pun intended all if
it's going to try something
new and actually commit to
that. Or if it's just gonna
be this kind of weird thing
they kind of has a line has
a for each side of
something can lost myself
with a metaphor that we
understand what I'm saying.
Yes so I think yeah I think
halo inference probably.
Safe to say it's going to
open the show closed the
show. But I if I had to put
money in I would say would
open the show. And a big
surprise would be the
closer- but another game
but we do know is going to
be chance I'm gonna see
some battlefield game play
so if you had the- the
reveal events with. The
countdown timer to another
countdown timer- Jordan are
you excited to see some
about field. I am if for no
other reason kind of almost
going off what town was
just talking about with.
Halo it's like battlefield
comes from like this. Old
third generation of FPS
shooters that I've kind of.
Fallen a bit by the wayside
in the face of things like-
over watch valor and
tighten fall like games
that have. Changed up what
it means to be a first
person shooter. And some
looking at battlefield in
way of like. Okay how have
you. Maybe tried to change
up a bit- what you're doing
but still at the same time.
Maintaining that idea of
what. Battlefield yes this
is a big year for first
person shooters new
battlefield new halo new
call of duty. Do these big
three stick to their guns
or do they change in ways
to appeal to a newer crowd
and I think no matter which
way you go. You're going to
be a bit alienating the
other side of what you want
like you there after appeal
to the veteran Crowder that
newer crowd. And then you
have to try to convince the
other side to be like Hey I
know that we're doing ideas
that you might not just
might not agree with. But
we're having a good time
over here like give us a
chance and so I'm eager to
see what battlefield has in
store and I'm hoping that
it appeals to that. Old
grad I. Michael highgam
loves battlefield I want
them for him I want a great
battlefield game for him
but at the same time for it
to show something to me
were like okay battlefield
has never been like my kind
of FPS but of what they're
doing. As someone who
enjoys games more like apex
legends entitled to things
like that I am intrigued to
try this and I want to try
this and I'm- hopeful that
we get to see that today.
All well hope for a good
battlefield michael highgam.
And we think it we also
know we're gonna see some
far cry six I yes we saw
it- like it hadn't bongo
recently with a look at
some game play we had a
look at the post launch
plans- I. I'm not sure what
kind of game play were
gonna see today. Possibly
if they doing I seen the
kind of doing the coop
stuff again- maybe it's a
look at like just an actual
just level. In motion but
we know we're gonna be
seeing far cry. I'm in
terms of other games so
it's kind of. The Xbox.
It's a bit. Who knows right
now said Jeff Grubb-
industry insider I tweeted
out yesterday do not expect
these and Xbox tomorrow and
this list. Genuinely
surprised me because I do I
would have had some of
these games down. As
definite ones to show today
so I was out. Of a dark
fable. Hellblade to that
might be making a video I-
I- interactives project
dragon do not expect ever
wild compulsions new game.
So the reason that I
thought these some of these
games would be absent
Sheeran's is because Xbox
you know two three years
ago now they bolt or a
quiet was it like. Fifteen
the studios it was
something ridiculous and
they kind of expanded that
roster to be over twenty.
Third party studios making
games Xbox and now
obviously they have well if
it does does stuff in there
too. They also have this
brand new commitment. This
will greatly last week
which was they want to be
releasing eight one eight
new first party game every
three months. Which I mean
they they kind of also said
you know temp your
expectations I'm not going
head to the whole time but
still that is a lot of
games. So in some of these
tiles especially given they
were announced a couple
years ago like Hellblade to
was gamer wards. Twenty
nineteen I think- Mabel we
sold a bit last summer
perfect dark last summer
to. I'm very surprised the
at least according to Jeff
Grubb they won't be there.
Today time you shop for
this whole. Not entirely I
think. Hello of the a lot
of those games thank. The
studio acquisitions they-
they came I timed out. You
know microsoft will
probably want to get in
there and figure things out
for them and give them the
opportunity to kind of.
Reassess what those studios
are doing and making and
then go from there so I'm
not entirely surprised that
they want a little more
time before they show that
stuff and also I think that
microsoft once there is
kind of taking this as an
opportunity to show off
what else they've got going
on be on the stuff that we-
expect them to have- I
would have loved to see
fable a little more I would
have loved to see- a bunch
of the games that were in
that last. I'm perfect dark
especially like a lot of
those games in the next do
you feel like they're very
very early about perfect
dark and fable I don't
think it's very early given
how much we've heard about
it- and we- have a wild on.
Social you can feel like
that that they could be-
interestingly falls on not
in not last so there's a
decent chance that you will
see a force a game- no it
might show if there is. Not
a fourth set today like. Do
not remember. The last time
Xbox a breast. And the
wasn't forza. Late night
thank you game. I do not.
Know yeah would you if you
are a all I wanna horizons
so yeah. Yeah is it. What
do you think arising could
go with it because I Future
to five now. I think W. K.
in America we did that.
Zero who it's gonna be Asia
like that they're running
into the Tokyo drift vibes
except no blowout go to
different parts of Asia and
yes Randy ready like tune
up culture is big get the
get in there and you know I
think that there's a lot of
mileage in that and love
style and that that studio
can make it really pop off
the screen as well I think
what do you do something in
that region. I would love
to see that. Yeah and I
mean now that you've
invoked now that even folks
okay draft has to schooled.
By the teriyaki Boyz. In in
terms of like other Xbox
our first party games you
think we're gonna see
something like. It gives
today. 5 ended on a
cliffhanger. Hey I want to
say that I think for this
E3 coming off the end of
the last year that we've
had if yesterday's E3 event
is any indication and like
twenty twenty one is the
year of the Indies not the
triple a games not the big-
flagpole titles like IT I
would be I think we're do
more to see something like
Psychonauts two state of
decay E3- the rumors for a
new plate tale games like
that showing up at
microsoft conference more
so than something like
years now I would be love
to be proven wrong I would
love to see a new gears to
see where they go after
that as you said like cliff
hanger at the ended on with
years 5. But I'm I feel
like we have to temper
expectations for this and
that halo is like Xbox is a
big thing for their
showcase this year and
everything else is kind of.
Double a major Indies
twelve minutes. Things like
that all our games I think
that's what they're going
to flush out their
conference mostly with.
Well I was gonna say I mean
I find is facing an
appearance from Chris
Chawla and I did Xbox and
unity four of twelve
minutes that. But it's you
know this whole conference
is about ninety minutes in
length and it's not just
Xbox games. I it is the
first you know big join
Xbox Bethesda conference
so. I think it's fair to
say we can probably expect
a lot from death loop a
time when I go to see a
deathly a behind closed
doors. Not too long ago now
about I'm sorry five months
ago and it's looking. Like
it's looking great I mean
even though it is.
PlayStation 5 games but
it's also kind of strange
because- this is like
prime. This is prime time
for the game comes out to
put on the stage so we know
it's coming to PC. I'd be
I'd be really interested to
see if they have any
reference to it on stage
because that's kind of. You
know. I don't like. Fully
calling out Sony at that
point I knew they would
miss Edith loop. Yeah I
think it would be while for
them to not show at. I
think microsoft is a small
enough to know that. They
call throw one of the
developers under the bus
even if it is a you know a
platform exclusive game for
a while like there are
certain points. Showing
that game- so is a win for
you know they're just
octane Mike. And it also
makes microsoft look good.
Microsoft is amazing at
playing their the paragon
of the games industry right
now. And that is just the
most all time a paragon
move like has a show as a
game from all give one of
our developers that we
think looks cool. It's not
coming to Xbox initially
but you know still look how
cool they are they'll be
making stuff for undeclared
wealth. And I mean the
money goes in that pocket
right yeah the money still
goes. In their pocket they
don't have to mention that
I'm art. Yeah I am. That
going to end up on Xbox
eventually- and yeah I
think we'll see plenty of
it and- it's also just a
win for microsoft right in
the hearts and minds game.
Showing off a cool game
during a press conference
isn't gonna. It isn't gonna
result in people like
coming on our end about
exclusivity people are just
gonna and look back at the
conference as a whole
Namco- definitely looks
really cool. And anyone
that comes up with you know
artists only only those
complex. Is still
michael highgam and that's
a win for a press
conference showing. So I
expect I hope that they do
shut because they stand
only to gain from doing
that. Yeah I really I
really hope we see more of
it today- it's easily one
of my most anticipated
games of the year-
intensive other Bethesda
titles we're probably gonna
see something from four.
Seventy six will probably
see something from elder
scrolls online- do we want
to twist off field now this
is getting out like
starfield. And elder
scrolls six so announced- a
good couple of years ago
with hindsight because I
remember the time behind
saying you know like the
very. Very early in
development and then you
know the news a year or so
later that Xbox had
acquired but that's just a
cleaning one of those moves
were it was like. We're
gonna announce this game
that you've all been asking
for. Maybe the bumps on
price a little bit and we
can get more money when
we're being quiet who knows
but then you know I guess
this was look at yourself
to be on good and evil two.
It just sort of announced
that just to stave off
near. Vivendi takeover.
That's not the case. But
it's been a good couple
years. Three thing now is
the time that we're
actually gonna see
something meaningful let's
go starfield first because
that's the that's the kind
of big driver Jordan.
What's meaningful Lucy
what's like what's the
meaning. Bloodied logo like
don't you give me a PNG.
Well I feel I would love to
see what they're doing with
starfield and it's one of
those things make it still
feels like it's too soon
it's still feels too soon
but like you said it's been
years. I mean I think we
get I think it's a
cinematic take like some
cinematic teaser I could
see something like that I
feel like it's still. Too
soon for. Gameplay promises
on as a side- but I could
totally see them deliver
like here's like a-
cinematic- trailer that
gives you a little bit more
of the story look at all of
the other amazing sci fi
RPGs that were invoking in
our story that makes you
want to. Play kind of
reminds you of mass effect
doesn't it I can totally
imagine. Something like
that. Love the- grounds in
front of mass effect the I
yeah I mean I do I'm hoping
to see something
substantial. From start. To
get a better idea of what
that game is beyond- the
Remez and supposedly exit
of come on over the years.
But I'm I'm also. You know
it's ten years of Skyrim
this year and if you really
want to treat yourself-
Google image search the
Skyrim launch party from
twenty eleven. Because what
a last what aid. While the
vendor was like there's an
incredible picture like
Christina Aguilera just
giving like just not can't
rule just holding company
Skyrim so what is the tenth
anniversary we know that
elder scrolls six is in
production again P. Hines
did say it's very very
early don't. Hold your
hopes but time do you think
now now that Xbox
sympathizers strong
together we'll see it. I
nearest now I know I think
if we see anything it will
be. Much in the same vein
as what we saw when it was
first announced some things
C. G. that is a few seconds
long and just gives us a
hint of ways. I think that.
I think that they've
learned their lesson from
showing off things like
elder scrolls to Eddie
because- kind of come ons
the- it combines the
conversation above anything
else. And I feel like.
Going back 1 I think that
we might get surprised to
see more stock- then we
expect- perhaps even. I'm
just I'm just manifesting
again have well like there
could be a couple of
seconds okay even a minute
gameplay or something like
that but I cinematic
trailer at the very least
well I think I feel like
yourself is your thing if
you slide a Hey you. Elder
scrolls in there. It kind
of combines the
conversation and the
attention overstock- but
you know. Never say never
maybe we'll get lucky and
we'll see something more-
that was because I hope so
my 1 hope is Satan do not
even mention the name
Skyrim because please stop
and anniversary time. Its
current one has also little
platform is duration point
at this point. Like they
did when was little more to
be found on. It's a time
was using. Are there are
there Jennifer know I have
it. And then- you can't I
mean can't play on own game
yeah yeah so there
backwards compatible are
current Gen versions of
them yet so yeah tenth
anniversary releases again
this. Maybe all you know
what I. And I'm even vote
that's going to happen. I
think in the end if you.
Just say that it's a free
if it's a free up that's
how you. I think that my be
a big but- if they manage
if they're gonna do a
Skyrim. Announcement date
should be Hey scarring is
coming to whatever the new
platforms that run does-
and it's free and it is an
upgrade if you own it you
already get it. And it's
you know you need GamePass
version will upgrade
automatically and everyone
does a good job. And then I
mean it goes on. Who
doesn't own Skyrim think
they're not gonna. Make I
don't like the phone
already has it we. Don't
own Skyrim. Yeah I. I've
that elder scrolls line I
feel like it too late to go
back playgrounds it's a
great game. Degree I it
because sometimes we might
see today we know machine
games all working on an
Indiana Jones game. Also I
have to mention because
it's so weird to me the new
Indiana Jones movie is
filming here in the U. K.
and- in like Indiana Jones
himself are simple is just
up in the northeast of
England so. Attending I
guess my neck of the woods.
He saw that it was a little
teaser for machine games
last year I'm expecting to
see more of it. That might
be when you mentioned
earlier that's like halo
might be. Either the thing
that starts a conference of
the thing that ends at and
hello might be the big
thing that starts and
there's a huge surprise Dan
I could see. A gameplay
reveal or like a an-
extended story trailer look
at Indiana Jones being-
cool. Closing bang for the
conference and by that I
mean on that. I would I
mean I would love to see
just what eggs over easy
there have been Indiana
Jones games in the past
with a big canceled one-
that everyone was kind of
super excited about I'm I'm
do under this point if
Indiana Jones still has the
sort of same. Start like
it's a- very well known for
his friend has does it
still have the same poll as
it did you know when
everyone was super excited
for. Kingdom of the crystal
skull. But you know he's
very intrigued to see if
the if- if you kind of also
is. Lies into. The new okay.
The star field trailer is
up on the Washington post's
website for more reason.
Eleven of eleven twenty
twenty two years I. I'm
just gonna run to scan it
yeah. Let's let's go yeah
so what it's live now and
okay. So we don't. Live
it's been a trailer okay
the actually begins at
where would dissect this is
now a softer dissection
trailer. Okay so looking at
the moon here. For more
women crane is- Skyrim and
fallout four. I Braniewo
universe twenty five years
in the making. But as the
logo. Gamer studios logo
are you absolutely hate to
see this. I mean time you
might wanna check in our
new slack because I was on
managing editor they're
asking what we do. With
this one I it's still up
like really stayed so while
it's taken a real big
surprise I was- today well
she's. Right it's the only
ones I want someone getting
talking to. Yeah I yeah
it's I mean it's still
trailer. Hey I got it right.
Well or thanks. I like how.
Like I. And yeah it feels
like a very open you're
looking at venturing space
you're trying to find some
sort of. He Jean-Luc
something amazing but sadly
nope no room no no actual
game play so far we get a
huge No man's sky vibe off
of it- yeah totally I was
about to say the exact same
thing like this Jean-Luc.
Looks very yeah this simple
sauce like install was
going on. I don't know if
we should show it on our
stream right now. Shuttle
so do that Republican angry
cool off for a- I've Xbox
if we do but you know
learning about it live.
Well yeah I mean it's very.
Hey is there as well.
Eleven eleven twenty two.
Xbox and PC on is also
going on you slack. Yeah
Xbox and PC only. The price
is for. Specifically no
last year and- yeah
interesting well beyond I
think in a C. today what
are your dream of already
had L. ring we've already
had starfield. Yeah okay-
at ten go for I'll I'll
plus I'm honestly I'm kind
of hoping to see ghost why
Tokyo I know that my
chances all low for it but
that is a game I'm super
excited about seeing- and I
hope that- tango shows off
the game and Bahamian team
show off the game it's a
big one is sentiment mine
I'm- very keen to see what.
What was going on with that.
Yeah I mean that's that's
kind of the- the ones up in
the air for me right now is
what. Like a Blankos Y.
Tokyo has been- for a while
you know we haven't seen
it- and the initial trailer
how to so much promise and
yeah I think we saw I I'm
somebody as well by year
ago. I guess I can follow
up and I'm very intrigued I
definitely want to see more
of that one. Jordan Voght
you. I want something. Like
absolutely. Wild like. Way
back in the day Xbox helps-
bioware but mass effect on
to. Consoles would raise
the for the new mass
affects trailer to debut or
even dragon age if by words
like you know we don't have
anything mass effect ready
right now but we do have
this new dragon age trailer
you want to showcase at
your conference. Hi I'm
gonna have to pay off I can
do I can do the anything.
To I will be back here
after the Xbox press
conference we'll see then.
Nice. Your about what we
talked.
Do.
Not the last.
Not the first.
As much.
Hi
everyone and Razer one the
need producer off
Naraka Bladepoint. First
and only. More than one
million players at least in
part again. The reading
center for your- now read.
Is bottle get with
connection. The skin
provide ninety. Five or
within and on imitate how
close. Choose FPS. Killing
and for no. For well and
close school. You can also
use. Wakefield way to
Gaming. For yes we combo
deals okay. What we call-
check on that you. H. the
Soviet naval your own 5 the
stock there is also DLC
Direct- mentioned we can.
Well racial. Don't forget
power because- that is you
to a new have. Rachel
Marshall. We hope that.
Green fringe fiction.
Naraka Bladepoint will be
globally released hoax
twelve and you can pre
order the game right now
let's go PC playful. The
older players will also
lock a new hero and close
it Alfie. After the okay so
we will continue to release
new contains and what card.
Hecker's entry to. While by.
Gaming June sixteenth. One
week. Right now
Intellivision Lisa download
the demo and the angel
Naraka Bladepoint.
My
goodness. Like I wanna
scream what. It was so good
and- I know I'm- it looks
so fun and so just enjoyed
it so much we had to bring
golden boy. Yeah you. Yeah
yeah. I played the first
alpha and I was really
blown away by it like- I
feel like one thing that
the battery all space was
missing was like a awesome
melee battle royale-
because you know it's just
a fun like I know
everyone's EIC all battery
Ousley so tried in there
they've- done and done and
done but like. Something
like this is something we
really haven't seen before-
I actually got to give a
huge shout out to my buddy-
Genghis Khan who I saw on
steam he was playing it and
I was like dude with hello
this. Is a download is
super fun so I went for it
and I spent the entire
afternoon just gotten
through people nonstop I
had a blast playing it
that's why I'm so hyped
about it well we are all
very jealous of you by the
way. It looks amazing- but
how do we think this is
going to change the battle
royale dynamic you're kind
of touching on that a
little bit but 1 added up
to everybody yeah the thing
about about oils like all
of them are or the biggest
ones are shooters so you
can like take pot shots
yeah. Snide fools or you
can like maybe take some
shots at about nine. Yes
but Future with this game
you need to pull up your
leg you could you come
through in that
neighborhood yeah you
square up and you got all
your fine from all the
gameplay that we saw its-
it gets wild because
there's like spell casting
to the rights of spell
break which is another
battle royale that focus.
On on magic and stuff like
that and so you know and I
was also thinking of- we
were talking about Altman
indystar north Oldham
interest yes yeah because
it's super fast and loose
because I also play for
honor which is. Very heavy
and you have a very
deliberate but this one's
like not just go all out
yeah it looks wild
absolutely and just wanna
dress attention the pull up
right now when will
Naraka Bladepoint. The demo
starts and. Ends at yeah I
think we all know. The
ticket. This is. Intentions
okay we were definitely
attention so percent of has
been attention I definitely
to talk though I mean
there's a Fortnite call of
duty wars on apex like that
list goes on and on and on
do we think that Morocco
can compete with those
titles I think absolutely
because people want
differentiation there's
this feeling of battle
royale fatigue right now
because it's so much of the
same thing in this game you
can three sixty no scope
someone with a brand new
spear weapon now this like
Lucia anime esque style
fight up in the sky just
raining down holy hell it's
gonna be awesome like I
think it's something that
the space needs. It to keep
it fresh you can't just
keep adding on other game
components to that core
battle royale mode it needs
to feel fundamentally
different that's when Iraq
a looks like from this
gameplay demo I'm actually
I have hello different in
several examples of non
shooter battle rails have
been successful writers
fall guys there's ten just
ninety nine there was Mario.
Thirty five R. I. P-
regular. Awesome Saltzman
previewed for IGN and he's
are fighting. He came away
impressed. He said the
fighting mechanics in Iraq
are legit so I'll let. Real
deal- I definitely noticed
the grapple hook on the
verticality talk to me
about the mobility
mechanics yeah yeah people
are going to die after that
while so I think one of the
big things for a lot of
battery out games is EIC
when can you disengage from
a fight right. Yeah you
know Fortnite it's really
good because you have the
building mechanic and you
can build up game high try
and take your opponent-
who's on the low ground
right they have to been
trying to the same thing-
which is why they
incorporated like deviled
eggs I grapple hooks into
the game. Well the grapple
hook mechanic adds and I
said this what we're
watching it any game has a
crap look I'm in the I know
yeah I'm in there because I
love I just love the
freedom of movement- that
it provides and would you
have like the characters
in. What and also three
stylistic as well right out
of the under you were going
nuts about that EIC
stylistically speaking.
Really cool you feel cool
and I know that this sounds
like a hard core shell. For
the gamer. If you are a
competitive player if
you're in EA sports person
or you're just an
individual who likes
competing at a high level.
I guarantee you like again
because I did. And that's
my background- yeah I know
the first thing that I was
thinking of when I saw the
trailer for the first time
in my- okay cool so we got
the battle royale Fortnite
elements. Well like the
combat looks like a faster
blade and soul and then.
All the characters that we
see. Plus seeing that
character customization
option I'm like okay it has
the simple ability of
gentian impacted I'm EIC. I
can't Mike I think all of
us to jump into it it's in
the dictionary golden but
look it up I'll look it up
for sure- but no it just
looks sure there I'm kind
of. Dictionary cause so
excited for it as you're
talking about the parkour
ability being able to jump
and fly everywhere tired of
kids being able out build
me right. Mr in building
the dating stares up and
down and I just you know
they shoot me faster so if
there's you know some sort
of. Thinking involved in
here where I get to Perry
something and then run
away. That's what I'm
excited for I mean they're
so. Excited for- I
absolutely love the game
design I love the
landscapes and that might
seem like a softball
question but skins make
money people. Maps all the
time so this game got style
they- sell sold many scans
it is going to be out
piculet siad they are going
to be probably said she
wanted sparkle skins. Yeah
but I mean think about it
like all of the different
crossovers we've seen with
battle royales like
Fortnite is the big one if
we get any like type of
anime. I. P. crossover
don't even. Oh my god I
don't even I would like I'm
broke. We will be broke for
sure- okay we got thirty
seconds left which class
three picking I know your
crowd control right. No I'm
just gonna get a I'm a very
rest. Her soul no no no
that's classic misdirection
telling get up in there was
just. Yes K. residing I
just want to jump around
and cause chaos and
confusion so whatever that
is so when you are in eggs.
For me big sort for me-
yeah big sort big sort okay
gall is so- young catches
sense. I'll I'll do the-
archery just to be
something different I like.
Okay well we can't wait to
get our hands on
Naraka Bladepoint but real
fast we go take a quick
break but do not go
anywhere we'll be
previewing Square Enix and
Warner brothers games back
for blood coming up. As E3
twenty twenty 1 continues.
There's videos I can
specifically remembered
that I can't believe I did
I feel like I remember the
most regrettable once the
most when I lived like a
sim for twenty four hours
for anybody who hasn't seen
it it's- you let your let
your Sims lives. How would
a game and then you have to
replicate it because
sametime is so quick you
end up standing around and
doing something for an hour
that you take like ten
minutes. I did it all day
you can slowly CV just
deteriorating as it goes so
I'm pretty proud that he's
talked that one out. Very
three post date I just want
to say hi and- hope
everybody's doing good
staying safe out there I'm
so excited to see the new
announcements for some
games and- hopefully we get
to see a little something
about old school six. Maybe
I don't know but I hope
everybody's having a great
time. And- season. Welcome
back to E3 live from Los
Angeles California and Hey.
Do you feel like some sweet
merch money check out our
limited edition gear. At E.
three expo dot com slash
shot. Right here on here I
did a presentation
yesterday the Nintendo
there's really like right
yes go back if you remember
I was saying doesn't that
there. While crews have a
new which gamer at does
their- crews have a new
movie coming up. Where he
wears a bomber jacket yeah
I can wear this in the
theater yeah and then you
get up to leave you go like
this and I go. Way way way
are you are you one of
those I was like we saw in
the movie and you don't
know his own hi. I'm E3 and
they say what that guy got
electronic entertainment
expo in the back are you
went there you know like.
For those pandemic year but
I bought it. On E3 expo dot
com slash the shop high
quality hi I. notating it
actually is quite nice it
is really nice yeah yeah
I'm a still 1 Thomas you
want. He also the that had.
Been Hey kids. Are you in
bed with your- do some yard
work with some. Get the
fact. Hey kids are you that
are. We'll move. That's
easier said. I'll tell you
what type. Later today and
will get a world premiere.
World premiere Montreal
plus an update on Babylon's
fall details on the Black
Panther expiring on board
ash I'm on board in a first
look at life is strange
remastered golden boy what
are you most excited about
I'm glad you asked- AG
ladies and gentlemen in
September twenty twenty a
game called Marvel's
Avengers came out you all
enjoy it for like a week
but this guy enjoys it to
this day and this is my day
all right this is the day
where I take it back Black
Panther. War for Wakanda.
Excited are you the amount
they're Wakanda forever
anything Black Panther
related I'm totally in I've
always been a fan of the
character way back in the
day so I'm cool with that
good good I just want to
know what else there bring
interpretation of course
all right that's an
important thing it I mean
you know a funny games
aside I did put a video out
back or when they're
getting Razer last Avengers
thing that was Hey Avengers
isn't in a good place I
enjoy the game play I. More
out of it what can they do
in hopefully work for Khan
is going to be that right
we need end game content we
need things to be going on
we need raids we need one
hundred fifty power level
stuff yeah I need a reason
to turn this on again every
day and we haven't had that
for a while they've been
better about the road map
but today's the big test of
what they actually have
yeah and another game that
I'm very much looking
forward to hearing more
about because I don't know
much about it from your
personally. Is a balance
fall michael highgam going
nuts about thank god kind
of going into this one
super cold yeah so I want
to be dazzled plans an
incredible dad I have no
doubt my mind if they're
gonna bring the heat I
think it's gonna be really
exciting I think
Square Enix is going to
have a pretty decent show
I'm looking forward to it
bungie said yeah I can't
wait to see what they have
up their sleeve right I was
the other big thing that we
were just talking well
first off full stop on the
announce game. Life is
strange huge fan I want to
see more about the brand
new ones coming out
September Bob and then to
kick it back into a river
patrol right like I lost
Montreal all right we've
known forever of what
you're working on your the
dance acts team there's
been rumors you working on
something new yeah is that
true is it today we see I
mean we see something from
them today there's been
this conversation you
continue to have a bike it
is interesting because
obviously the rumors of
what's coming right maybe
Marvel property. But it is
also great time workday sex
could thrive in the state
this is true you know I
know that like dare sex the
franchise is one that's
kind of flown under the
radar but it has been for
the longest time one of my
like hallmark games EIC it
was like a huge part of my
job I mean day six
conspiracy on. The
PlayStation two I don't
play that like a million hi.
I love back. So much-
revolution. Another gray
game or human apple. Rights
skinny. Kind of- the you
know they they just make
great games I think with.
Cyber punk in the hype
around at that you know
Neil future kind of. Thing
imagine that the thematics
that we're seeing now. Is a
great time to do something
like that right like that.
Futuristic city appeal I
think they're such good
really mail it. But I don't
think we're gonna get that
today- and that's okay
that's perfectly fine just
don't let me down next
year. It's what I've talked
about before specially as-
a comic book dork you know
I mean. What excited for is
saying something I can see
I think this. Like
insomniac. Where I think
it's all mac is it an
amazing studio. Obviously
everybody knows it now. But
spider man really put them
on another level in terms
of European pop culture.
And I think as we look at.
The- the Square Enix
Montreal right Dana I don't
Montreal here right. The
same could be applied here
where day sex games were
great and people who love
them. Love them yeah but
now they were going to be a
property of Marvel title.
Let's see what happens I
sure ben howard available.
That's what I hope it is. I
remember the German what
are you excited for.
Hashtag E3 twenty twenty
one you can get right in
there you can see what's up
never get time. Get in
there baby now. Following
square and they want me to
read the teleprompter this
is another look at your
right here. Right here
we're going to I don't
either following square. W.
B. James. Back for blog all
my god golden boy we can't
wait. Hey that alpha and I
was like I'm- done yes the
people who may look for
data back to the spiritual
successor left for dead.
You know it's amazing it's
kind of deck building
things every time I play
the campaign's going to
different campaigns. Look
up yeah I had the
opportunity to preview this
game- with the WB games
crew. And they were all
amazing all wonderful
people. And I've got there
immediately and I was just
like. This is everything
that I want it is. Genuine
excitement for a game
that's ridiculous that. You
knows exactly what it is
and any plays right into
it. Even from the name they
know what. They are they
know what they're doing-
and- got that. With time.
Great you know I remember
talking to W. B. current.
Like the my best friends
like we love games like
this was like yelling at
each other in course you
know. Cursing each other
out and having a good time
because that that's just my
friends that's what
friends. And that they said
this is literally that it's-
exactly what you want out
of a co op shooter. They
added some new set pieces-
different elements of the
game. I come into monsters
right. Xbox Series X yeah
so I there's they're
bringing something new to
it. To the table but
they're doing enough. Of
the same that it just feels
right yeah M. VAT. At the
end of the day is all you
want out of a game like
this a 100% you know
yesterday was comparisons
drawn we're talk about
rainbow six for our
extractions not warranty
work. Rate was six
extraction right and I was
watching that and it was a
conversation that was
happening in the media
stage. Where there's going
to be those two types of
people who want the
tactical. Let's plan we're
taking out this hive right.
Invented for me it was
definitely like I want the
back for blood. Cool I have
been using now I have a
shock and it doesn't matter
I'm having a great exactly.
Everything up exactly and
that's the reason why I'm
so excited for we're gonna
see that. Later on today
but also another thing
we're getting is a PC game
show because it's coming to
town baby. We know one
thing we are going to get
in entertaining look. At
some of the best news
releases including. In the
release is coming to a PC.
Near you they've got.
Thirty nine thirty nine
thirty nine GameTrailers
Greg I just saw that pop
up. On the reader I didn't
even know that that's what
that's wild Hey that's what
people usually 1 in the
threes GameTrailers is
Danielle is there a lot. Do
you see things that they
might be playing yes I
think currently exciting.
Yeah and I I'm lost. An arm
brace. Investments right
you do that because I'm
short. You know but I'm I'm
looking for to PC games.
The only way for you to we
did it guys get your screen
shots right now is broken
friendship right. Asked tag
okay twenty twenty one
yeah. The like this that
they are. Like this bit I
don't know I don't know
we're doing. Right games
I'm talking yeah that's
what I I'm I am a
notoriously. Not a PC gamer
right. I am I am. I'm a
simple person I like my
because of the plugin go.
But what I love about the
PC gaming show every year.
Is the diversity of games
you get very training
course on plot I was chosen
to host it does a great
job. He's funny as well
DevOps always being goofy.
But we get to go in there
and we get to see a whole
bunch of different stuff.
Stuff that will maybe come
across a one day or will be
the game that inspires me
to turn off my PC.
Furniture and that is the
beauty of PC gaming it's if
there's so much variety.
Yeah that's out there- you
know you can go multiple
platforms. You can do
whatever you want to do and
by the way I just. Got in
flop stop talking. Stop
talking about. Because
microsoft. All and this is
just. Hey I need a twelve
minutes from date fill all
right I knew that I need
star. We need to see hello
don't do this to- get Tim
Schafer big cycle not come
out today it's a simple
request. Lighting can get
there that matters. People
are listening to this
podcast. Exactly it's
available if you're
watching this right now
just no man just bring the
thunder brother that's all
I want just bring the
thunder dude give me the
chief I don't think those
watching this right now. My
gosh that's his that's his
nickname now that- well
let's do a great. It was. I
know it is over. Okay fine
everybody now is the moment
master chief in golden boy
have been waiting for
here's the Xbox in Bethesda
game showcase.
Twenty years
that's how long Xbox has
been with us and like you
this is a moment I always
look forward to I love
seeing the new games
crossing my fingers for my
favorites to return. Hoping
for a few surprises most of
all though I love seeing
everyone around the world
come together and celebrate
what games mean to all of
us. I think you know this
past year they've meant
even more thank you for
being with us today thank
you for the support you
give us and one another.
Xbox is turning twenty. And
I wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for the friendships
we've had. That whole time.
At that says the we believe
video games to one thing
better than anything else.
They transport us. Through
art and technology. There's
real magic when you step
into a New World. I can
make it your own. We've
traveled the world of elder
scrolls and fallout. And
now for the first time. In
over twenty five years.
We're creating a new
universe. Was starfield.
Set hundreds of years in
our future it's an epic
about hope. Our shared
humanity in answering our
greatest mystery it's a
game we've dreamt of
playing and it wasn't till
now the we have the
hardware the technology and
the team is hard at work at
home. To make that dream a
reality. We're excited to
finally share our first in
game teaser. And something
to look forward to. Persia
earned me anyone he-
they
say the wonder is not that
the field of stars survived.
But that we have measured.
Your part of constellation
now. Popped off family.
What you. It's the key to
unlocking. This is in. Two
please come to. Humanities.
The only.
You are.
Awesome
to share with you for the
very first time one of the
most anticipated games in
the world from Todd Howard
in the team at Bethesda
game studios. I'm breaking
game and yes it's exclusive.
Welcome to the Xbox and
Bethesda game showcase I am
so excited and proud to be
here today celebrating
gamer because although it's
been an incredibly tough
here I am grateful that
games have been such an
important source of joy and
connection. We are
committed to forging the
next era of Gaming
conjuring worlds never
before possible unlocking
play across all devices and
delivering the power of
games to everyone. And now
we get to share that quest
of Bethesda not just as
partners but as one team
United in bringing the very
best games to more people
everywhere. So today we get
to reveal more of what's to
come. We have an amazing
show thirty titles twenty
seven Xbox game pass and of
course every single console
title you'll see today is
optimized. Xbox series X.
and at. Offering NextGen
performance speed and
features. We get to work
with the best studios on-
next is something truly
riveting. The latest entry
in the haunting and
evocative franchise created
by G. S. C. gamer world
Stocker to coming first
Xbox series consoles and PC.
This will be a true next
Gen experience targeting
four K. resolution and ray
tracing let's take a look
at what you'll get to play
when it launches next year.
No Jordan Voght. Good
persia. I know if I should
be a lot in. Spicy which
area. The millions still
conversions plus. No that's
why we gotta do utilize
slam.
With. Spooky in
nearly as you could shoot.
We'll by my two. Moon is my
here's the anomaly
Mussolini feels will
triple a with.
The
company's I get PMV usual
closer to it. The with
sewing and redeployment
Collis who should because
the did you do. Zone of the
issue more. The result is a
little different from them
as.
You should. Appeared
Luthor's about group will
oblige some reports his.
Numazu judicial users will
receive Russia she water
tank one. Is so what I
don't know what do they do
with.
The postal. Zero
three zero usually when the
wheel is Keith. Which will.
A delusion. At the very. 1
which also. Yeah at the-
one of the witnesses. Apple
is a social judge the Texan
plus the people. Should a
Scania mocha which is
business meeting.
Michael highgam lovely
snowboard not park on
streets. Listen what do you
know your- yes yeah. Seven
the line please global use.
Sure. Sure.
Reporter
equipped with the P.
believe it listen below.
Eight stop.
We're surviving
here rebuilding. 5 is not
enough. We've got the five.
No we don't need to do
anything. The last time you
saw repeated any number.
The rest for the wicked. I
love Mondays.
Local up
buttercups. Once.
This.
And
he was from beyond. Danger
calling Hey. No one still
this ruling. All right. Now
to see how. Yeah must start
I see even better life why.
I didn't realize IT company.
Caption checks back. Let us
fix you already knew.
Because of the trash Jack
store the darkness falls.
And if it's not stopped
this world will sing
shadows. DEC holds many
secrets. Right new body.
All I can do sure you. So
will receive sleeves if
nothing. This. A legion of
the dead. One day reach.
Well let me leave that now
is the perfect time to use
these Capcom. Well without.
Thanks. Thank. But it's
suppose by chance this is
the second one of those.
The sea of thieves I. Bring
me that horizon.
Hey how's
it going. Refutation is
everything Israeli
officials. Yes. Good happy
birthday.
Following back
whatever.
On.
So how's your
day no I. Who is this my
birth date. This is. This.
My only seen so much. If
you. I see this a lot to
play catch.
Court. The
final frontier. Ready.
For
the fate of the free
thinking the world PC. I'm
afraid that means in office.
Three always remember how
do. These. Of the world can
you do. Yes if I can find
some bacon. Hi I'm going to
ignore that last part.
This
is usually the moment when
I say hello and welcome to
the because the E3 showcase
we love that we can share
the stage with Xbox this
year and whether you've
known Bethesda for thirty
five years or are just
getting to know us we
couldn't be happier to
bring you the latest on
your favorite games. We
started the showcase with
my good friend Todd Howard
to give you a first look at
starfield along with the
first two games studios all
of our teams are continuing
to work on the projects
that have been in
development since well
before we joined the Xbox
family. So rest assured.
Epic games you've been
expecting and hoping for.
Are still in the works. And
today. We're bringing ten
more titles to GamePass.
For a total of thirty
Bethesda games. That
includes several in
software games like the
award winning. Two
maternal. If you're looking
for another reason the
plate. To maternal will be
optimized for Xbox series
X. and yes on June twenty
ninth. Powered by intact
this next Gen upgrade will
be free for everyone who
owns two maternal. And on
series X. it will offer
improved visuals at sixty
FPS with ray tracing four
K. mode end. Optional
performance mode up to a
hundred twenty FPS. Or
maybe you're in the mood
for an RPG lite Skyrim
which marks its tenth
anniversary this November.
We can't celebrate it
without you so share your
favorite scary memories
stories artwork and more on
Skyrim ten .com. Or explore
an ever changing post
apocalyptic wasteland in
fallout seventy six.
Everything you love about
fallout games custom camp
building bridge storylines
warring factions unique
characters places to
discover you'll find it all
here. In fact follow at
seventy six is now one of
the most popular games on
GamePass thanks to an
incredibly welcoming and
collaborative community.
Here's a look at what's
coming next and fought.
Seventy six. Brotherhood of
steel guardians of
civilization. For hapless a
safe. It came at a great
cost. The brotherhood must
stand United the super
mutants critics priority
this proves more than
anything the need for our
justice. Your our forces
the most important thing is
finding everyone that has
gone missing and returning.
I thought you understood
what that insignia mac. The
brotherhood. I said this
promotion I am the only one
who can stop. The
brotherhood of steel must
protect the future of
Appalachia end of the world.
Right just crusade has gone
too far. It may seem that
we have. That we are now
stronger than ever. This is
a choice that can never be
done. What the hell was
that. Expeditions what
delta report over. Squad
builder what's going.
Wasteland isn't the only
open world playground with
an amazing community the
elder scrolls online from
Cinemax online studios has
now surpassed eighteen
million players and shows
no signs of slowing down
right now our players are
enjoying the new black with
chapter part of the gates
of oblivion your long
adventure we've got a lot
more to come in here so
thanks looting the
conclusion to this epic
story later this fall with
VSO deadlines. And with the
release of ESO consul
enhance this Tuesday gamer
deliver a true native
experience optimized for
this series packs and this.
Nothing is off the table.
This battle will take a new
breed of 5. Wait.
Stupid we
get so. Trying to stop me.
This holiday marks the
twentieth anniversary of
Xbox and the twentieth
anniversary of halo. Two
are millions of passionate
fans thank you we wouldn't
be here without all of you.
Our goal has always been to
bring players together and
for the first time we're
thrilled to offer our
entire multiplayer
experience. All players
across Xbox and PC with no
barriers. Hello infinite
multiplayer will be free to
play and invite more of you
than ever before to become
a Spartan hero. Rector of
halo internet from helping
craft the original halo
combat evolved to leading
the fan favorite halo three
ODST. Joseph is a halo
visionary it is so great to
have him back with halo
thank you Bonnie and Hey
everybody. For us and I
hope many of you halo has
always been about heroism
and wonder. About fighting
to keep humanity safe
against impossible odds in
a beautiful and mysterious
sci fi world. This is just
one part of the Senate halo
ring the largest most wide
open environment we've ever
built. And we can't wait
for you to explore. The
heart of halo Spartan one
one seven. The master chief.
In the next chapter of the
chief story the face
greatest challenge. 5
they're not allowed in the
fight. So shut down. Hi.
It's enough. She. There's
no much time. What happened.
The okay I known as krypton
is gone she's been deleted.
Thank you. Of course not.
Did you hit your head or
something. Don't you
remember my instructions
were to enter this
installation imitate
Cortana and lock her down
for retrieval yours were to
take her back to the
infinity for deletion. So
if it wasn't you. There's
something else and
unsuccessful deployment my
deletion routine was
supposed to complete. Still
here. Good good something
stop your deletion. We need
to find out why. But this
wasn't the missi the
nation's change they alway
do. Are you sure
- of course
you can't have a halo game
without multiplayer and on
Xbox series acts you'll be
able to enjoy in finance
multiplayer action add up
to aundred twenty frames
per second finally I'm veryo
infinite first free tplay
multiplayer season andinfinn
campaign will launch
together. This holay.
Generaon to fight. To get.
Yeah. The enemy flag The
flags.
Now.
Survive the
dog figureonde in eeast. e'.
. R.
August our- but it wilbeall.
Three from alof us.
He'sy brother. .
Rk
sevey hours in your
president. All right hand
gu. Recognize that voelet mt
I am dd Hey I burning.
But exactly is triple a.
What has sing songs aroundt.
Time you learn about
wrese done a. Thank down
the field. Taking out a
high value target I have
just what you ed. You
wanna blow **** up one
guard your service.
Everyone what. Wait a
second. Whatever you need
to get the job done. Next
time I see you. I want to
play with that crazy about.
Seven one. So.
Bunch
welcome back right again is
a New Direct well I have to
go.
This is the whole east
laundering.
And. Marion.
The first year of. Millions
of players Capcom PC. With
crafting. The. The now. To
preset. The people were
they been asking. For news
usually a lot of people
were to sit. When you get
sick of. Mashrou. These
guys. Also. No one was
asking for. Ruled mother.
You could probably do it on
a rack mode cool even her
blobs the all of us. The
war never. What it looks
like we energy. Nice. PC.
Two cheers applying
solutions to conflict
situation. We wish to test
your ability.
History is
yes. Choices. Taking. Ten
E3 was your. Would you. We
should go. What we you be.
We begin by here in an old
why is sounding voice. We
see a quiet peaceful city.
This will make our games.
Something must the sheriff.
With this creature B. in
the. Say goodbye to it
forever. Suddenly and for
new. People these slow
motion shot. Make it seem
cool I should post please
number. But Los on can the
only way thing. Tim gettys
over thanks. For- national
B. use the title.
Let
everybody. You can give.
Hello I'm Mike brown
creative director at
playground games and I
can't wait to show you what
we've been working on.
Horizon is known for fun
freedom and beauty. This
year the horizon festival
arrives in beautiful
diverse Mexico. This is the
largest and most diverse
open world after in a forza
horizon game. And there is
no better call to explore
it Bandai stunning AMG
project one sports or
addition. Rented in
unparalleled detail and
with ray tracing in full
service staff thanks to the
power of the Xbox series
consoles. I think I did a
long some of the team to
help give you a taste of
some of the amazing content
that's waiting for you in
forza horizon 5. Please
welcome bill Matty Sierra
and don from the faults of
team. They might Hey guys
what's up. Everyone Hey
what's up Mike and we also
have Abraham with those as
well. He's one of the
talented actors who will be
appearing in the game. The
nvidia though some may he
go. I can't wait to show
you what we've been working
on. We begin in the
rainforest expeditions.
This is a new campaign mode
in which she sets out on an
adventurous journey across
Mexico to explore new
locations and discover
places. For the festival.
To expand. There you are.
I'm the call for the
Mexicans robbing. I can see
some. Best enjoyed with
others let's go and see
what some of our other
plans are up to. The Xbox
series consoles allow us to
capture every last detail
right down to the
individual needles on these
tractors. The scene looks
real but there are no
trailer. Gamer Monty is
behind the wheel AMG one
certification in mac lush
living doesn't. The place
to meet the with friends
and had a for a drive.
Thanks to the Gen of garage
life. Every else was here a
real. And it looks like
Marty has been joined some
of them of the city. Let's
leave money for a moment
and head out to coast and
meet don. John is already
on the move X. the ideal C.
town. This is a real. Of
Mexico is honest offense
and fill with love. Picking
up pulled on. Hey what's up.
This is a mural by may all
Frida Rueda just one of the
many face pieces of you'll
all of for horizon 5. Well
done dry down to the beach
we'll jump over to the
caldera volcano. Check out
this GL pizza M. with press
accuracy using photo date
caps on low. A top active
mac volcano the end way has
been reached based of the-
and his CM yeah favorite of
bungie. The volcano Sierra
and friends exploring is
not point at the end of
gamer. Thanks to the of
Xbox series. From up here
we can see my in direction.
In the distance which is
about make out why of my-
let's take closer. One of
what's is one of the most
beautiful city any in the
world. It's a colorful
undulating. Full of 5 all.
EA has a spiral network of
tunnels. And these. Turning
global industry I mean as
well as looking it plays to
as we say here is don is
Chad in. But we will. Using
our unique hasty all camera
rig we catch a twenty four
hour shoots of real Mexican
skies at twelve K.
resolution. Thanks to the
Xbox series consoles these
photo realistic skies
result in life like
lighting that dynamically
changes every right. Making
you feel like you're really
that. His mac the again
she's joined by Abraham and
some of the members of the
team. Our players are using
for the link then you I
assistant intelligently
tracks the status of you
and the people you meet
online and it helps to link
up and play together. Will
now head deep into the
rainforest and rejoined
bell and the rest of our
players. Here we see our
new volumetric lighting
system filling the scene
with cadres sunlight
dappled through the dense
rainforest. Risan arcade
minigame is about to start.
Fulfilling knows the bill
looks many games so
intelligently from Sierra
to invite bill. Bill
accepts and that seamlessly
links together with the GPS
resets. Without horizon
arcade minigames starting
soon. All of our players
are coming together. This
mini game is called upon
signaled by the horizon
cargo plane. Dropping a
payload opinions. Over this.
Kind of you guys. Our plans
now have to the to find an
Paul as many they can okay
don't to let. On the main
road. The bushes here.
There's some between the
houses. It has come for a
year. While team drop those
last few pinatas we're
going over to the stadium
because I have one more
thing to show you. This is
if banks lab the incredible
new toolset that allows you
to create your own races
gamer and game play
experiences you customize
everything right down to
the fundamental rules of
the game. Forza horizon 5
is the largest most fun and
most beautiful open world
we've at that builds. And
it will truly be an
astounding showcase for the
Xbox series consoles when
it comes to Xbox game pass
thank November nine. Thank
you so much I'll see you
all in Mexico later this
year. Team Xbox is on a
mission to bring the joint
community of Gaming
everyone on the planet.
That's why you the gamer at
the center of everything we
do. Today we showed you
thirty gamer. Twenty seven
of them will be available
on Xbox GamePass. Now
through the end of the year
you can look forward to
back to back monthly
releases landing the one on
GamePass. Led by five new
titles from Xbox game
studios as well as highly
anticipated games like back
for blood twelve minutes
and the ascent. And as we
look ahead to next year I'm
inspired by the creativity
of Bethesda and Xbox game
studios. We showed you the
highly anticipated RPG
starfield coming
exclusively to Xbox but we
also have some of the
industry's best RPG
storytellers working on
about. Be able the elder
scrolls online fallout
seventy six the outer
worlds to and elder scrolls
six. We unveiled the
stunning multiplayer mode
for the world's most be
love shooter in halo in.
Adding to the roster of
iconic Xbox shooters
alongside Wolfenstein gears
of war perfect dark in do.
We premiered the most epic
open world racing game
forza horizon by bringing
you a vibrant and authentic
depiction of Mexico in a
game built from the ground
up for next Gen while the
team at turn ten is hard at
work on the next forza
motorsport. Our growing
family of twenty three
studios is devoted to
advancing the medium we all.
Xbox it's been here for
twenty years and that's
because of you. Our team
strives to make Xbox a
place where you'll find the
greatest games the most
dedicated developers and
the most passionate
community. To gather we all
make Xbox the best place to
play. Before I go there's
one more thing. Take a look
at this brand new original
game from the arcane team
at but that's the studio
that created prey and
dishonored. Arcane created
something new for them an
open world immersive
shooter that you can play
alone or with your friends.
And like starfield this
scheme B. and Xbox
exclusive.
Yeah anything I.
Twenty five centimeters. So
right.
I field and rightful
Massachusetts behind me we
are witnessing this. Locals
and. Really the video was.
No. One all.
It's.
There's
higher in this really
what's it taste like be
specific like blood death.
So it's gonna keep moving
let's keep moving. Sure
thing at brown brown.
That's a good thing things
will ever go back to normal
would you want to go back
to normal. Not if I still
have.
We.
Bring me that
horizon weekend.
Welcome
back into GameSpot's
coverage E3 twenty twenty
one you're here for the
Xbox and Bethesda post show
I'm lucy james joined once
again by saying. Hello and
jordan ramee L. all right
let's what do we think of
that one- Jordan Voght
comes the first that's
probably like the best E3
that Xbox has had in a
really long time and
granted I guess it's wasn't
like completely Xbox like
was very clearly here's
Xbox and Bethesda games but-
that was a solid.
Conference it was very well
paced we got some gameplay
for some games thrown in
there was mostly cinematics
probably a little bit more
Cinemax and I would have
liked. But it. Definitely
seems that Xbox is. Going
to address the- issue kind
of had going into series
accessories asked where it
was like a- they just
didn't have many console
exclusives in comparison
to. Playstation coming out
of the gate with miles
Morales and then
destruction all stars and-
return all ratchet and
Clank. But starting this
holiday season if all these
games are actually hitting
their dates from holiday
season all throughout
twenty twenty two Xbox.
With the help of Bethesda a
lot of titles in the
pipeline lot of console
exclusives coming their way
and that's exciting that's
really cool it's awesome to
be. And Xbox fan again.
Yeah I mean even just
looking at some disruption
to it's like you know
you've got read full.
Starfield forza motorsport
eight and then everything
else and then on some those
are just kind of like the
big hits as they're
announced to be coming to
Xbox. In twenty twenty two
and like. God if you're one
of those people who like
Xbox gotten gains than. I
think we might have watched
a very different press
conference at time what did
you make of that. Yeah I
think it was pretty much
exactly what Xbox needed
right now and obviously
there were some conspicuous
absence service fable and
the like. But I think
everything. About it
without the consent I think
there. The messaging around
that or the lack of
messaging reading between
the lines is. Lines there's
dot stuff isn't coming out
next year it's coming out
we are often that's when
they'll start talking about
it. Nevertheless everything
that they've shown so far
has been. You diverse it's
been a lot of exciting
things and most importantly
the real winner here was
GamePass if you need an
excuse to subscribe to
GamePass this is. The best
hour and a half two
hourlong I'd vote for
GamePass that has ever
existed. Everything from
massive triple a games like
soft feel to smaller indie
games that are on the way
there and- you know that's-
dot is a incredibly
compelling case may fall.
Not only getting in Xbox
references here is S. or
next. Also signing up for
GamePass and from microsoft
perspective not only have
they succeeded in showing
off the things that they
are working on while also
giving the people who own
Xbox is and our subscribe
to- GamePass a reason to
continue and feel good
about what they have. Also
made a compelling pitch to
people who don't have an
Xbox any flavor of it and
don't have a GamePass
subscription and if you
order one of those people
was on PC. You also in the
same boat where you're
probably thinking maybe I
should get a game cost PC
subscription because a lot
of that stuff is probably
going to show up there so.
Like that is a rare ten out
of ten press conference for
me I think. Wow ten ten
yeah I mean- because I
really enjoyed it I think.
Like you said it was very
diverse just in terms of
the offerings that
microsoft have like. That
was a really impressive
selection of games. And it
fell to me and you know.
The moreover the top level
maybe even navel gazing
look at things. But like.
They let every game. Shine
it didn't feel like you are
rushing from one into
another like. The trailers
were decent. Length of time
like the big hit as- you
know you get taught how it
on there you go bungie
Ross- China by halo and you
know you they they were
given like. An appropriate
time for everything and it
just felt like it was a
nice press covers
everything could brief.
That being said so we're
gonna go through all of the
biggest announcements from
Xbox and for the role of
announcing it through. And
then we're going to go into
all kind of predictions of
a Square Enix presents
which will be streaming
right here. About forty
five minutes will be to
keep you updated- if they
decide to go early move
immediately throws them so.
Let's talk about Xbox. As
we saw in our pre show.
Starfield unfortunately.
Leads I mean honestly. I'm
really glad that. Like they
got out of the way. Because
I think. Being having
Braniewo arcane having read
full being the just one
more thing and not not
leaking like regarding your
parents don't feel we
starfield existed- but now
that we can watch the-
what's the trailer properly
and have it up- as we're
talking about it having
taught that to kind of give
context. Jordan Voght we
are media take Christmas
off field- I'm- it looks
good like the visual style
that there're going for I'm
intrigued by it it's like a
little bit of Star Wars
little. No man's sky the
suit design reminds me a
bit. Of returnable and in a
way it's like. It looks
really cool it's also. Like
one of those games that I'm
still kind of waiting to
see what the game play
actually looks like before
deciding whether or not I'm
actually. Excited for it
but- like like you said I'm
I'm very happy that this
was actually like the game
that they- lead with I was
really worried going to
this conference that
starfield trailer is going
to be like their final big
reveal michael highgam know
the final big reveal has
been. Spelled for the press
conference even began but
it was a solid way to start
the showcase it's like
here's- a giant new I. P.
coming from. The festa.
Xbox conflicts loser.
That's coming to a
GamePass. Here's the visual
style. Get hyped get
excited now let's actually
dive into a few games that
you can kind of expect to
get this year early. Next
year I'm like great way to
start the conference. Yeah
and I'm kind of glad that
like. There was still so
much excitement about the
even though at least at
least like so. Close to
the- to the start of the
conference but regardless
it Thomas took it to even
though it's- technically
the third store could gamer
I guess. I know you're a
big fan. What do you make
of that. Yeah I the I was I
really appreciated that
very focused on narrative
and a little more of the
atmosphere of it because- I
mean those first two store
could game stay well- you
have to kind of be that
terror. Terry at the ground
level to really appreciate
what they were. These days
it and they feel quite
janky but- in terms of
setting an atmosphere
stalker is I think yeah I
think there's like. Two or
three maybe even still
contains if you count like
the various expansions- but
I'd like to what I saw so
far of it- looks. Really
really published which was
a surprise. But that that
kind of like feeling of
being in this world plays
incredibly hostile and- and
your around a couple of
people who you're just
trying to brave it through.
That was a big part of what
the stalker- experiences
and not really knowing
what's out there the things
that go bump in the night-
that was As like survival.
Horror first person shooter.
Kind of thing- that that is
done. As well as it could
have been back then so I'm
excited to see that same
team come back K. with
modern sensibilities and
kind of like really go I
again for the storefront
tries like shadow Chernobyl
in call of Pripyat still
hold up if you're willing
to give them some leeway to
be old games so- if you
haven't checked those out
check them out because I
I'm super super excited
about seeing this game-
come out and- check it out
myself. Yeah I mean I've
never actually played
soccer before but
everything. I was watching
today I was like okay yeah
I mean I played my turn I
enjoyed metro so like. I
definitely feel like the
similar vibe is that Jordan
what are your thoughts and
stroke. It looks. Looks so
creepy and I'm I'm stoked
to try like. Xbox had a lot
of shooters at their
conference today but
stalker is 1 I'm like oh
it. Looks hello I have to
be careful like you said
lucy james got those the-
metro vibes and like. I'm
here for that I. Am excited
to do like a bunch of
really stupid. Crazy ****
and battlefield and halo
and stuff like that but to
get a chance to. Kind of
slow down and take a more
tactical single player
probably more story driven
approach this doctor to.
I'm excited I can't wait to
try it. Yeah I and then I'm
just okay we had a little
bit fax blood which I'm not
gonna linger on. Too much
because we are going to see
more of it later today and
I want to brothers and- I.
Until rock are doing kind
of a little mini standalone
presentations are back for
blood. Abilities coming
GamePass get day one
October twelfth so the
rumors were true- and we
talked about in the pre
show that's kind of a very
big incentives. For law
offices can get together
and play- but that was a
brand new games it- very
very brief. I cinematic- CG
trailer contraband from
avalanche studios so this
is the just cause deaths
because I there are two
game Dev studio called.
Avalanche if I'm right in
thinking. One is avalanche
studios in one of the
government's yeah one of
them. Was the old games
software yeah. This is B-
the just because folks so.
A co op open world game.
And like beyond this kind
of tone piece of a trailer
we don't really know much
else about it- time we're
kind of a media source from
this. Yeah I wish I wish
that we hit with. Didn't
seem to have been able to
see some gameplay but it
feels like towards the end
of just because they
started to take a few cues
from the community- in
terms of there was a lot of
modding efforts put into.
Just cause to make care-
kind of multiplayer and
kind of push back some of
the limitations- that what
kind of keeping that Gaming
held in place a game that's
already quite. I'm out of
control and wild but I get
the feeling that to play or
a multiplayer. Open world
game where you can create
mayhem is going to be a
similar kind of thing that
they go for again based off
the back of. The kind of
experimentation that they
did towards the tail end of
just because I'm so I'm I'm
excited to see it because
they were they they were
still here that's great
after putting together
these emergent gameplay
moments. So I imagine it's
going to be a lot of fun
and I'm excited for them to
kind of step away from that
just because- property
because you know just
because games were great.
After a while they had a
very familiar shtick and a
call back kind of tiresome
so giving them a new
playground to mess. Around
and seems like a winning
formula. Yeah I'm so. I'm
excited to see more I love.
I love the kind of tone
piece but I definitely want
to see the actual game play
is gonna be like- because I
to go a little bit
exhausted by the end of-
just because- and- you know.
We just love to see them do
something else but
something that's within the
real house right. Leg this
next one possibly my
favorite. Reveal just
because- in hindsight we
could have seen this one
coming because it just it
it matches so well thank
you I don't understand how
that hasn't really been a
big pirates of the
carribean sea of these
crossover. Until now- but
the sea of thieves a
pirate's life- contacts
power was that T. dominoes
that- Davy Jones- coming as
a free update June twenty
second I couldn't tell if
this is the actual- if this
is Johnny Depp voicing come
Jack or if it was just the
guy who did his voice
thinking the house to- but
it looks like. A kind of
fun mashup of both of them
so I'm Wheatley excited to
dig into this. Even though.
Anything beyond parts the
carribean. He was not a
great movie. Jordan Voght
one- I mean if it sounds
fine it'll probably be a
good enough reason for me
to just jump back in to see
if these real quick just to
kind of catch up on all the
content that I've been.
Missing out on and I think
that it's just a nice thing
for Xbox at their own it's
like Hey not everything
that we're going to show
you today is like holiday
season and twenty twenty
two we do still have. More
stuff coming this year
don't worry your decision
to buy next Xbox Series X
Aston axe was was actually
a good one you'll still
have. Stuff to play this
year. Well I mean to that
point- excuse me for
looking off to my- the
monitor- but we did get a
kind of look at that
graphic at the end which is
like everything coming to
GamePass- until the end of
the year and so. You've got
yeah because like a dragon
today- D. in the dock
aligns the centerpiece or
trailer for Haiti's. Twelve
minutes in August- are
gonna be too stable- full
twenty twenty one we've
gone. Anna cruises which
resort Gaming ward Scone
back to blood's. Shredders.
That brand new- it was
strange. A little say but
like the snowboarding game
they'll be among us hello
neighbor to the gunk. Still
possibly my favorite name
for game ever. At flight
simulator coming July
twenty second Psychonauts
August HM passport will get
and October. Fourth so far
horizon 5 on the holidays
hello influence so like
right good window saying
that like. They're showing
that it's not just twenty
twenty do they have so much
coming in for the rest of
twenty twenty one
especially if you aren't
Xbox game pass subscribers-
I know. Getting excited see
more of a see if there's a
love the way the game has
continued. To grow and like
not only. Sort of found its
audience but it's just like
catering to them and just
really leaning into how
wacky. Those expeditions he
gets or do you I do love. I
Tom what do you think of
Bassil field- so some
gameplay from that one.
Yeah I mean Belford. It
feels like that kind of
profit is always been a- I
chose the is I have small
ambitious than most other
first person shooters and
in recent years there felt
like technology investors
ambitions started to kind
of collide in a way that
didn't work like dice
always seem like they were
going for things that- they
ready patch Todd and then
towards when the game was
out it didn't quite hit
what they want. Dot trailer
smacked of something that
was like we figured out the
right balance between
ambition and technology and
now we can make this thing
happen properly everything
that was in there was
spectacular to say the
least and as a multiplayer
experience it feels like
even if you're not doing
amazingly at the game you
will see some absolutely
ridiculous things happening
around you. And the stuff
that is happening in in
each it's kind of like
multiplayer- kind of
portion that they showed
off with great speed rocket
taking off or just because
exploding in mid air planes
or something we've been
close to the ground that is
a level of exhilaration and
multiplayer that is unique
to. Battlefield and I think
the what a first time the
stuff like the
liberalization and the-
Boston destruction feels
like it could work well and
be as comprehensive as
they've been wanting to
care for rainy long time so
I feel like this is a
strong strong showing. For
battlefield and for Dyson
EA. I'm let's on then. We
kind of saw- some. From
twelve minutes ago the
release states Psychonauts
two got really state that
to join an oreo psyched
about twelve minutes you
saw it in action recently
right. Ever say it it it
looks really good and it
has three phenomenal actors
and I'm- excited and I'm
glad that we finally have a
release date work is this
game's been at E3 I think
for. Three years now I am I
can't remember it's been
around for a while and I'm
happy that it's- finally
coming out and I'll finally
get to. Play through the
entire thing instead of
just seeing preview after
preview after previous. I
don't know I think it has
been. Yeah definitely like
to a twenty nineteen I
think was the first time we
saw it- I will never get
overseeing the shining
carpet in the hallway it's
a little bit looser- then
we had- uncle Pete Hines
comes the stage can you
give an overview of a
desert Xbox- he was
actually wearing. The the
read full **** and I guess
because I think time we
were on the school and you
like what should is he
wearing like we- right now-
yeah. Looks like he was a
he was doing the- Phil
Spencer teens wearing
shirts- to tease an
upcoming game VS just you
know little updates that-
do internal coming to
GamePass along with- I
think nine of the game so
it's gonna get four K. mode
is gonna be optimized-
sixty frames raytracing the
whole. Shebang but I think
you play up to hundred
twenty frames once I. Or
maybe I'm mixing it up with
a local move on Skyrim not
the big update that we
thought it's just a photo.
Competition or like a- best
Skyrim memories
compositions single off
that. I for thirty six
getting Europe- steel rain
and expeditions the pits-
and then ESO as a bunch of
stuff- upcoming like just
had. The Blackwood's latest
pack and then you've got
like deadlines on the
console- impact coming so a
lot of cool stuff happening
with the ongoing games of
Bethesda currently have-
let's move on then to. Some
of them so I've skipped a
couple here because Haiti's
Reno's coming GamePass and
party animals looked a
little bit like. Gang
beasts but with cute
animals but let's move to
some of those so real is I
remember jump ship. I built
a studio built in
collaboration with the ex
CEO and co founder of
plated so yes those. That
makes sense. Vibes so right
now inside is. Phenomenal
Gaming one of my favorites.
It's such an incredible. I
use this word like three
times already- but like
tone he said is it is so
well crafted unlike
everything in again feel so
deliberate and precise and
I really hope that's what
we get from some of the old
zero Jordan what did you
make of this one. This is
one of those games that
like I know how press works
I know how marketing works
you can actually do this
but I would love it if they
just. Don't reveal anything
else until we get like an
actual like- and it's
coming out on this day.
Good luck I am totally sold
on this trailer alone like.
It looks sorta like limbo
inside that makes total
sense now that you've told
me who that developers are
and what not. I'm like I'm
in I'm sold the tone of
this game seems massively
don't like have. Any
dialogue whatsoever but I'm
already like in love with
this family unit that's
running from this.
Monstrous read I assume in
like this in the world
scenario. Great awesome all
I need don't give me any
more I'm we'll be there day
one. Well that's another
one of the twenty twenty
two apple let's look to
something a little closer-
still no. Concrete release
date hello infinite I think
that was one thing that we
already we hope to be that
today- especially given the
delay last year- all we
know right now is. Holiday
twenty twenty one- time.
What did this Taylor
presentation do for you was
it everything you wanted. I
think in terms of story it
was very like okay shoal-
there was some chatter
about Cortana being deleted
someone pointed out call
times and believe this and
actually happened- well.
The thing that really stuck
out to me was that the game
play it looked. They look
good luck it looks real
good and visually as well
as- in terms of how it
flowed it felt like you're
very active very practical.
Very punchy halo experience
and I really like the way
that the company was- kind
of integrated into it in
the single player section
they show chief kind of
moving around the zero G.
area- I'm using the
grappling hook to move from
point to point which was.
Ready ready coal I'm and
then in the multiplayer
they showed like play is
you know grabbing pieces
all of- weaponry from a
distance and using that to
good effect so and then at
the same time the guns felt
like they had a little
punch. I would like to know
what kind of that was
running out because it
looked. Incredibly smooth
like so smooth like to the
point where I was like this
almost looks it could be
like sixty FPS or even one
twenty yes Paul I know but
like I times I was like
this looks like a movie
like. Then again it could
be just a very well done
like high frame rate. A
kind of a video recording
of it that they've messed
around with in folgende. A
forty exists for this game
and I am and kind of put
together a GamePass okay
school but everything I saw
there was good like fost
frenetic fun. They had the
superintendent from ODST
pop up about one point-
sounded like they had a
different voice for the
voice over that cal
tacular. Guys seems to be
like not even a different 1
are you sounds like you to
mix the alphabet. But yes
everything I saw there was.
Inspire ever like inspired
some confidence in me- the
lack of a release date
still a slightly unnerving
I would like to know- what
is going on with the
single player apple I feel
confident in saying that.
The multiplayer launching
free to play that's going
to be mass that's going to
be so huge and I feel like
that on its own is also a-
pretty phenomenal case
being made for getting an
Xbox because- people have
been talking about Hey
hello. Multiplayer this of
Xbox and if your if your
now into where you're like
maybe I should get extra
and Hey is there three
multiplayer that is pushing
you over into the into the
microsoft camp. Yeah John
what do you make that. As I
kind of just- echoing
talent I love that they
showed up so much of the
gravel hook I was
incredibly worried going
into this that we were
going to get a kind of.
Halo reach situation or
it's like oh we should add
special abilities to the
Spartans are they can do
and they kind of felt. Like
something that wasn't part
of the core. Gameplay like
the whole armor locks
branch jet pack is like all
the other additional things
that exist around the core.
Halo combat but based on
this trailer at least it
looks like the grapple
hooks been. Implemented
into the core gameplay loop
like the halo gameplay loop
has evolved to incorporate
the grappling hook. Into it
so that you're- more likely
to actually use it whether
playing a single player. Or
the multiplayer- like tam.
Little bit worried about
that. Release date and
begin ready I'm- wondering
maybe they kind of do a
thing where it's like the
single player comes out in
the multiplayer is the late
or vice versa. Because of a
just a holiday that means
they're like oh one can
come out here and the other
one can come out here and
they're both technically
holiday season. But we'll
see it looks way better
than what we saw last year
so. That's good. Yeah I'm
I'm yeah I'm excited about
it I just really wish we
kind of walked in that
release date- but I think.
I think three for three
with feeling the pressure
because it is the twentieth
anniversary this year it's
already slipped by year so
I mean think it's because
it gets out the door. Where
you know. No crunch but
like I can imagine they
just as much as we want to
know what it is I imagine
they just want to confirm
that dates up. And ship
that game- we've got about
twenty minutes until
Square Enix presents so as
a couple big 1 tiles.
Couple big more titles are
constructed a- there's a
couple of those M. Xbox
will talk about how. Before
we discuss what we think
we're gonna see and it
squares press conference.
Most notably forza horizon
5- it's been on the rumor
mill for a while this one
will be based in Mexico.
And yep that was confirmed
today it looks. Really good
like the legal how good all
the four is the game's look
like every year I'm like
man there's no way that
they can possibly top this.
Then the next one comes out
on like. This- pretty. It
looks yeah it looks
gorgeous and for the Ryzen
are kind of under the
racing games I love because
I love the- Katie Phelan
love the sort of story line
that you're kind of there
is you know the way they
incorporate music the
greatest festival and so
now is that the new
campaign mode we
discovering new locations
with Russell to expand
into- but overall it just
looks it looks. Great like.
H. I'm January very excited
and it's November ninth-
time when you make this
one. Yeah looks stunning in
a I like that they've
leaned into the wacky
aspects of it we showed we
sold like driving into
bowling pins the well the
thing about four days like
they talk about how
beautiful it is and it's
like oh we've individually
rendered to every need on
this cacti and- this war
based on their size like.
Well done by will be going
past all of that a hundred
and million miles followers
so I that is not of that is
going to register to me but
I'm glad you did it- but
yeah because a- I think
probably oppose all rise
in. Certainly probably.
Some the best racing for.
Are currently exist rest in
peace but now- I yeah I'm
over the moon to see them
come back- and it coming
out relatively soon and
again GamePass baby. As
baby I'm finally- so I mean
Phil expensive did sort of
acknowledge you know we
know you want to hear
updates on games like fable
and elder scrolls six and
around and- actually as we
were talking- parris lilly
part of the show- he's
actually a part of our E3
coverage this week two is
hosting. Xbox game showcase
extended this day June
seventeenth whether he'll
be in conversation with
devs from some of the
studio's like double fine
like ninja theory and
obsidian and rack so
interesting to see if it's
going to be more news that-
but the show ended. On
after kind of those little
teases from Phil about the
other projects that haven't
worked the show ended on a
genuine surprise it's Akane
Austin's brand new game
read full so good to see
the kind of CD trailer I an
open world in Massachusetts
because it misses you so
what else could be expected
from the lovely folks
arcane Xbox exclusive. And
it's like a mix of sort of
the supernatural. And magic
with. I mean maybe it's
just I played so much just
but you know you I see the-
and I'm like oh. Okay yeah
this is this is a cane
magic Gaming- but also a
vampire is and technology
so. I wonder if this is and
like definitely was already
this kind of. Evolution of
previous Akane games and I
wonder if this is equally.
Another evolution like
taking the best bits of
previous arcane titles and
putting them into.
Something new Jordan what
did you think about this
one. Well first off whoever
at Arkane studios who is
responsible for like
creating the hair certain
characters I want to like
think you personally like.
Its owner to death loop now
this like someone there
understands how black
people hair works and I
went to like. It's
beautiful great work thank
you so much but like beyond
that. This is one of those
great like you said total
surprise I'm here for it I
think I might have been a
little bit more excited for
it had a game like this
been announced before we
got to use this for things
like. Back for blood for
aliens fire team before
like we were looking at a
year of like here's a four
player co op shooter we're
gonna fight lots of words
of these monster things
with your friends. And take
now get this game on top of
that I'm like. Okay how
will you. Be different I
assume it'll be in the
storytelling because arcane
can tell a story like few
developers can but just
while. I'm waiting. Loading
and there's so much. I'm
recording- so it is. Evan
no cease- previously of
could talk and I- nine- who
wrote rise of Black Panther
the Marvel and worked on
miles Morales. Is working
on this game. Unlocking so
that's the that's the
narrative so I'm I'm very
excited. A long way that
Ricardo Ricardo bass I
previously worked on
discounted premium crash-
and hazel. The mon Fulton-
who previously worked on
dishonored death of the
outsider so yeah big. Wow a
powerhouse team of
narrative those a criminal
summons and- I'm miles
Morales so I think very.
Convening a confident in
the narrative team- we've
gone in just about fifteen
or so minutes before we had
to square so I'm gonna wrap
up our thoughts on Xbox
overall tam I easily gave
it ten out of ten he's
standing by that. Yeah
absolutely I mean like
between all the or the
games are coming to
GamePass. Like in the
smaller games that you know
1 led by the tone pieces as
you call them to the big
stuff like small field. I
mean like- read full is.
One do you stand out for me
like I'd love all canes
games and- there's already
this sowing the seeds for a
fascinating universes and
characters which I really
you know and love out of
them I'm so. And then
updates folder existing
games halo looks great.
They had a pretty much
every box that you would
want them to take tect. So
you ready con argue waves
within the quality of that-
press conferences like
Jordan said install one of
the best Xbox press
conferences that they've
had so far and most
importantly. In a big way
addresses some of their-
implants are criticisms
that have been leveled
against them you know
people saying that Xbox
doesn't have games. They
absolutely do- they were
proven right. A time to
fall with the this strategy
with GamePass and- as time
goes on I think GamePass
going to go from strength
to strength as it already
has and- if you're an Xbox.
Owner it's a good time to
be an Xbox owner if you're
not it's a good time to
jump in and just enjoy the
games. Jordan closing
thoughts on Xbox I'd- what
tam said two thumbs up
awesome job Xbox like it it
was good like finally you
gave me the E3 that I've
been asking for you to give
me for like the past four
years. Keep it up. Well
merry Christmas Xbox I mean
I don't think anything will
ever pass the- you know.
House when she did all
those reading random videos
but you know we can we can
hope that you maybe you'll
get him back in to do some
more- we've got our fifteen
minutes until Square Enix
presents so they've already
announced. I believe some
of the games that they will
be talking about today
let's start with apple
lawns full so collaboration
between Square Enix and-
PlatinumGames. Reveals back
I didn't realize 1 is I'm
putting together the run
show today I realize it was
released a revealed way
back in twenty eighteen so
it's been quite a while we
saw an update from it I
believe. Last year
originally it was listed
for PS four I assume that's
going to be changed- arms
crossed. Session but like a
low. I mean and I mean this
and as being a huge
compliment that looks like
a platinum games during it
looks really cool are you
immediately you get the
devil may cry's vibes I
know it's Capcom don't ask
me for that- but looking at
the Bayonetta vibes.
Rockstar games. Yeah it's-
it looks great and I'm just
very excited to see more of
and I'm glad that they're
also kind of saying we're
gonna be talking about it
today time one of those
games are your bag- we
think we'll see from apple
in full today. I'm I like
I'll take anything and like
I've been. Watching the old
gameplay videos for so long
I'm obviously doesn't need
to be said. Find the
muscles of the character
action game and- the
recent. Collaborations
right Square Enix
especially as it pertains
to- yeah. Is eight have
been. Front and center for
a long time now they they-
have developed a good
relationship and they've
also kind of. Develop a
client old reputation as a
result. Inadvertently the
expectation for story is
now way highland. Platinum
games I mean. You know your
Qatar date the heavy
lifting on that stuff when
it came then came from the
airport it's- it's now
inextricably linked now
people are gonna play
minigames. New York comic I
specifically and thank god
this is a studio that makes
awesome character action
games and they kind of
really compelling story
with unique clips and
mechanics in that. It would
be wild of them to take a
step back from this point
and know how they a good
story to tell. Having said
that even if it's something
as simple as and she's
lucky and fun as BAndai-
banquet show any number of
other games that they have
made wave wave. You know
just kind of popcorn flicks
tell me stories that you
can experience and throw
away that's still enough
for me the things I want
from them on the mechanical
stuff I want to press
buttons and based on what
I've seen in Babylon's
already and looks like you
will be pressing. A lot of
fun. He refreshing bonds.
Very quickly the changing
those come- yeah I'm I'm
really excited about this 1
RT. Because what was the
last time the games on the
switch. Which game I didn't
your. Active all chain
restaurants I mean. I
believe that was planted by
I can really get on with
the one. Trying out but I'm
I'm he is hoping the
problems full after having-
like quite a long time.
Sort of behind like
tinkering waited behind the
scenes I hope it's
something really great we
also know we'll be seeing
more of life is strange
true colors. Now I. Really
I'm really intrigued to see
that they are breaking away
from the episodic model
because that's kind of. I
that's what I associate
with life is strange that
I. Am going- from doing
that but like that's what I
associate with life is
strange it's like. They
took that telltale formula
and they it was they used
it a lot in the way that.
Each episode is structured
like every episode had its
own Arkansas I'm interested
to see how that. Is going
to translate to just one
game I know this is deck
nine this is not- the
original death- don't know
and so. I'm intrigued and
also. I've been reading
missed phone recently and I
love to Alex. Chan's
character is essentially- I
see the- which is a
reference. Only for people
who read the specs but
still. 1 what do you think
we'll be seeing her from-
from life is strange. I've
I don't think they will
probably get and- or at
least I hope some sort of
extended gameplay thing
like during their big
reveal it's like here's
life is strange true colors
they covered a lot of. The
story they're like here's a
few of the characters are
bringing back from previous
games. Here's the powers
and everything like that we
don't actually know what
that's going to look like
how that's going to work
like. This is a game that
has an actual central
location and since it's not
this episodic release where
you're moving from place to
place but every. Injury
there's gonna be this one
space you return to that's
constantly evolving over
time and we don't really
know how that's going to
look obviously I want to
show their entire hand it's
like. Here's all the
secrets for this game but
we- should probably get
some sort of indication of.
How how they're able to
transform the traditional
formula for life is strange
by transitioning away from
the episodic. Model like
it's still apostolic
they're still like episode
one two and three but since
we're getting the entire
package. What can you do
with that how can you
change how this game- plays
an evolved depending on
that we're getting all of
that one. Yeah I'm I'm
really intrigued to see
more of it- I. E. very I'm
also very interested in
like the power itself it's
kind of the- able to kind
of absorbing manipulate
strong emotions and you
know each emotion is-
verses by color hence the
name lifestream true colors
and I just think that kind
of sets itself up to be.
For lots of cool- gameplay
moments and sort of
character interaction
moments but I hope. I don't
know I don't if I want that
system to be really rain
Dan or if I wanted to just
kind of been going the
whole time because I
imagine that could get
overbearing but nothing I
do about life is strange is
how they work with music.
And I remember the original
life is strange had an
incredible soundtrack and
that's one thing that I'm
really hoping for this one
I know they have looked in-
I. Cannot remember the name
of the big on tech talk- I
think it's the post new
signing- a- problem of the
artists- amex. Dressed yes-
so I've seen them too much
stuff and- maybe we'll see
more of the soundtrack
today- but that's so that's-
strange movie seeing some
that Square Enix presents.
Marvel's Avengers our-
terms yeah I come to you
for that. Did the only per
still play this game.
Convey that's called baby I
was gonna say sign call-
delete it from his hard
drive- to make space for
something else now. Yeah so
we get a C- and you go five
to- they they took a
picture Black Panther
yesterday. I what is this
gonna bring you back Sir
models I mean he went he
went even then because he
wanted to be that you were
that playing begrudgingly.
I mean like. Hi I am like
you you're bound to
experience most mobile
content I'm in. Before
everyone gets off my **** I
was into multiple makes
before the MC you relax.
Okay chill- but yeah I mean
like I I've- I my issue
where Marvel's Avengers has
and continues to be a death
of content. The drip
feeding approach is not
enough and that has been a
big problem everything that
you've given us so far is.
It's a drop of water when
we've been walking through
a desert that's just not
good enough. What having
said that the Black Panther
content feel substantial
it's a new character a
character that looks
interesting and will have a
new area for us to explore
and play in and then also.
You know that's going to
have a knock on effect on
the other content in the
game so I'm excited about.
The Black Panther content
for condo in in Marvel's
Avengers. I hope that it's
a little more. Me either in
previous expansions all
content drops have been
we're still waiting for big
things like the rate and
that kind of stuff and
we're not going to get out
for a while I hope there's
enough in the Wakanda stuff
to keep us coming back and
maybe even bring a few more
plays into the fall because
that is a game that talk
about games that could
benefit from being on
GamePass. That is one of
them it's unfortunate that-
it's still a full price I
mean you can find
discounted everywhere at
this point but I'm it's
unfortunate that the game
has such an up hill
struggle to bring people in
because between what it has
now like if you're if
you're the kind of person
who wants to jump in Plano
vengeance game and then
bounce. Why is now is
pretty good if you're the
kind of person who wants to
jump and play the Avengers
game and then keep playing
the Avengers game the last
cell but I'm hoping the
waffle kind of stuff will
bring a little closer to
being that you know games
is service assistant
experience that we've. Been
hoping it will come soon.
Yeah mean I agree with you
on the point of EIC coming
to GamePass but I think
with the exclusive. Spider
man I mean where is the
exclusive spider man stuff
for Playstation. I do not
know what it meant. I so
yeah I'm interested to see
if- if the work on the
stuff can bring a lot of
planes back to Marvel's
Avengers because I mean the
I am. Single player motors
it was a lot of fun hello I
had a good time with that.
It's just I called to. The
grinds man this was enough
for me- speaking of Marvel
we- we know that there is
going to be the new game
from Eidos Montreal room
as- the rumor mill. Been
going over time believing
that it is. A guardians of
the galaxy gamer I think
the movies coming out is it
next year. Jordan Voght you
big find. Do you think
this. Is rumor is going to
be. True like a you a or a
site for guardians game
would you kind of wish that
Eidos. Would maybe do a 1
Ian just. Slightly
revealing of the day's
hacks that everyone is
asking them for. Well when
you put it in those terms
and it's like well you know
I want. ASX but- if the
rumors are to be believed
and we're getting. A
guardians game. Thank just
just take. Heed of what
Marvel's Avengers has done
right and what it has. Not
quite captured like show us
something that's really
story driven maybe just
make it single player I'm
not quite sure how you do
that given that the
guardians of the galaxy are
a group of people. I'm sure
you can make it work I'm I
just Marvel Avengers S.
shows that sometimes you
don't have to go with the
GamePass service model with
your new game you don't
actually have to do that
every single time sometimes
you capture something
really really good with the
single player game. And so
if you are going to do
guardians of the galaxy
game I. Gosh I hope it's
that. And if it's not there
then I hope the rumors are
wrong. Is it just like
sometimes it's okay not to
have a press conference
be doing is a service.
Apple. But I want- square
has announced that they
kind of- and we talking
about today talk about my
favorite bit rumors because
I mean that's that's full
games for like forty five
minute press conference. I
think there's more we did
just have the release of
final fantasy seven remake
integrated I would the you
for each chapter I've not
had a chance to play it
just yet I but do we think
will get any. Read crumbs
about a remake. Seven
remake part to ski scan
into kingdom hearts. I
levels of- titling the time
we reckon. Absolutely not.
They will be showing up to
I would love it I would be
1 up for if we do get
something it would just be
a logo that says final
fantasy seven remake pot
to- ever. The thing that I
still feel there will be
final fantasy seven content
I don't think it's going to
be this specific game but
they have a lot to work
with they brought the
mobile games they've got
the we had power royale
game they'd call a bunch of
other games and then there
was that roommate action
game that's being developed
by. Team ninja that is
supposed. Action angle so
we find get to see that- I
hope we do get to see that
because that sounds cool
although I'm still very
wary of- teenagers doing
action games based on other
people's IP. I live through
Metroid other M. and I
still have nightmares about
it bought. They have
improved as a studio
massively in between I'm
Neal and the various other.
Games that they have been
working on. Yeah I mean I'm
I'm very intrigued to see I
think that- the team ninja
1 is cool let me see 5 has
the origins that's
according to a report by.
Fine by I mean I'm down to
see it I think that could
be really interesting. I do
1 how much 1 offensive they
are going to run like a
lien on this press
conference if they do all
because- obviously there is
seven point two like you
said there are the mobile
games there is the file
right all. Game there is
the- sort of seven. The
make. I suppose you could
call it does that one- but
then there were all these
rumors to- I saw Jason
tried throughout the city
today but like it to the
final twenty simple
collection- which makes
sense and people were kind
of tweeting out the other
day that. All of the- the
act- short. On iPhone like
the old artwork could
change so maybe there's
something in the rumor I
don't know. I think it be
cool I do think sixteen.
Okay anything from sixteen
now you don't and there's
not there's no there's no
way let's like Pam says
they they have flooded
themselves with so many
final fantasy projects
there's no way that there.
That they have all of these
plates spinning and they're
like oh yes and where well
enough on our way with
final fantasy sixteen that
we're able to. Show
something off. There's no
way. I don't know I
remember. I know I remember
the rumor mill last year. I
remember people saying that
sixteen is further along in
development than people
think it is. I know I would
I would be very. I hope
it's better I really want
to today. Playing on my
mind like hot if I was
working that and coming up
with strategies slash
marketing I would say to
the team that. We should
right now final fantasy
there is it's like a rubber
ball and haven't so it has
a lot of that stuff was
popped off so hard and
everyone is in love with
all of the animals stuff
we're doing this is. EA
team that is responsible
for a lot of that. We can
parlay a lot of good will
into this new final fantasy
project. I'm and it would
at the very least behoove
them to. Show something
small and how from the team
W. the MMO this game- even
if it's like a short teaser
or even just like a kind
of. Splash screen. I think
that would do a lot of good
for them I know so keep the
conversation around final
funds C. sixteen going. I
think it's pretty important
that they for them to do I
would think anyway so I
hope they do and I'm kind
of just willing it this
fall Michael hi I'm- Sally
just manifest he's not
yeah. He said he's these
are easy E3 so you will see
him on the ESA stage-
probably screaming about
final fantasy shortly after
this. I mean we were
watching the- the
PlayStation press
conference last year when
they announced final
fantasy sixteen and- he
lost it. Because it's such
a huge fan so it was very
very endearing stuff I want
that for michael highgam
basically I'm we've got
just under a couple minutes
before will go to the
Square Enix- presents.
Conference I 1 I mean for
Spokane- formally project
Althea. I'm I wonderful see
more of that today but also
I think what's more likely
is it is the twenty fifth
anniversary of tomb raider
this year. I would love to
see them do something with
that I don't know if I it
would be a new tomb raider
game or maybe even just
like a remake. In like you
know took what they did
with final fantasy seven
remake in just like really.
Put a lot of time and
energy resources into fully
remaking the game- just
makes a platforming.
Investors because I
remember playing as a kid
and it being. Unforgiving I
wish only gonna go over
less than a minute until we
go over to square. Time.
The production what you
wanna see. I nobody can
about to make this is
legacy came seems when.
Along where usual review
wherein if do and friend
pressed about my like okay
all read a you. Most of the
way that can be again
reporter Laura in a grave
revive runs all fine and-
hello dare you I know.
He'll get reprimanded as we
as we watch- Jordan what
about you. Give me a twenty
twenty two year road map
for Marvel's Avengers give
me any indication to re
download this game because
you care about its future
anything any indication I
don't care. All right we're
heading over to square now
make sure to stay tuned
because we'll be. Breaking
down the press conference
as soon as it's over we'll
see soon.
Good afternoon
everyone its members are
here and I'm back is your
host of Square Enix. Today
we have a special E3
edition of the show for you
new game announcements
updates and exciting news
from our studios across the
globe. So let's kick off
with the world premiere of
a brand new game from Eidos
Montreal. We hope you enjoy
the show. I am so proud of
you. You know what
birthrate is Peter.
Something that. Gardeners
of the galaxy no rocket so
I led group fill out the
paper. So we got. Six
thousand nine hundred and
sixty three sure I know.
Your plan.
We just. Could
be used to such traction.
Make your world. You had
one job. Exactly what.
Of
course. Hi my name's nvidia
pool senior producer here
at Eidos Montreal for the
past few years we've had
the privilege to work on
our version of Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy and
reimagine its into a single
player story driven third
person action adventure
game it's our own fresh
steaks on the guardians and
something that's really
unique to our game is that
you get to be Peter quill
as star lord you're
constantly in the middle of
the action. As you try to
lead this band of misfits
but today I'm really really
excited to have all of you
to join us on this journey
and you'll hear more about
the game from our team
behind this project. Let's
do this. I've always loved
models cosmic characters-
growing up as a kid abroad
read them enjoy them let
them. Yeah I had the
opportunity to right. Full
model on some of that
because we talk hi went
back with the help of Bill
road in the end it's a- and
kind of cherry picked
characters from Marvel's
cost. The opportunity here
was to build. But all under
the- so that the reader
with my. Gosh how is this
team. And that became the
guardians the galaxy. Which
loved working on. I
remember first time that
the Marvel came to Montreal
we were showing them the
design of the characters
all they would look at the
state's silent I don't know
if it's some minutes but in
my head there was a minute
I was like. Oh my god like
they hate it we realize how
much the marble I don't
Montreal share. Common and
that we knew the card is
working perfect yeah
looking at some the
products are going to show
me I think he's fantastic.
Absolutely spirits of what
these characters out what
makes the game expert.
Unique me is either what
phase of the game you are
whether you're an
exploration. You're
fighting the guardians are
constantly around you and
you never feel alone well
you're the leader the
guardians will also
challenge you and make
decisions on their own. And
you will have to adapt to
it you all. Really truly
pops off the guardians the
galaxy. The decisions will
make will have light
hearted to hunting
repercussions and the game
will react to what you do
and say. No killing
teammates who literally in
your contract. I made no
such commitment. You are
playing a star lore in your
using blasters and you're
using your jet boots.
Starlord is really
empowering he's very agile
on the battlefield you can
slide it over with his chip
boots of course he has a
mental blasters at that
different powers as well.
And on top of all of this
you can use the unique
abilities of his guard.
We're not pirates relieving
corporate heroes for hire
gardeners of the galaxy
note. This story is about a
group of misfits the
guardians in our world has
been together for less than
a year the create something
on the small scale looks
insignificant and as the
progress through the story
discovered that the created
something really big that
transcends the galaxy.
There are a lot of very
interesting villains in the
Marvel franchise and when
you're starting to work on
a story like this you get
to get your fix of which
ones will make the best for
this story that gives us
the opportunity to bring in
some that are well known
but some that. Are also not.
What I was getting so right
about. Is caption what it's
like to be a misfit.
Sabrina Mays imagination
clans and characters
they're gonna blow your
mind interpreting in its
own way I think makes it
incredibly fresh and
exciting it's not a matter
of trying to replicate the
comic we'll try to
replicate the film it's
trying to take the medium
you're working in and make
the best version of
guardians out of that. On
the rock and roll they
deliver everything you want.
In the gardens gamer.
Thirty seven units. Six
thousand nine hundred sixty
three short Nintendo keep
our ship I know I know we
clearly need a plan more
screen what's come on
you've been hoarding that
stupid knickknacks ever
since you first joined us I
mean don't tell me if you
prefer not quarantine so it
was always going out
figurines are not Nick now
seems in trouble and you
can't. Make no sense. Of
course. Your head take us
the majestic. Geis I did we
should. Era group. You know
the only problem with your
plan is that leading
hellbender only fights
monsters and you are not a
monster are you really
offering. No he is not off
K. good work so group I
guess we could bust him out
after absurd. Eighty
hellbenders seeks. Small
ugly is clearly choice is
cruel sadistic initial
issue. I've always thought
group I honestly think lady
hellbender will go for now
well I voted for not I also
vote for the creepy little
beasts. C. H. well rock
it's definitely scary on
the inside he's in stable
and vicious and totally
abilities to the needs of
others. Okay we- all right
let's do this let's go sell
monster. Seriously weather
patterns are from nine to
five temperament. That's
not how whether.
Is an
impregnable fortress. There
is nothing to figure out.
Easily gain access. To we.
Right.
Jacket some of us.
GamePass. We want to throw
this. Storms. Thank you
very much your welcome.
One
okay. We should've gone
amok. For I would be wary
you know when I saw my
freaking half world to get
scared.
Your.
We asked them
for directions. Maybe the
art direction. Sign post or
something I'm not saying
it's an error with the word
fortress on its but statues
suggested Playstation and
the only Solomon I saw when
we were topside. Lady
hellbender scorcher S.
right it's retractable. The
controls are on the other
side of the giant chasm.
The creature over the chasm
Activision. Activate a hole
through your. Me down be
fine just curl up in a ball
Drax the role. Future it.
The guess that only applies
to cats. Order the bees to
do its. Drop by 5% I want
can okay deal. Rocket fuel.
Again I.
Future again
something. Right K. H.
twenty four look at this.
Alright rocket. I only got
one are you sure about this
Future. Better have one
hell of a sales. David
Morris right. Try selling
group instead this is an
affront to democracy I just
think that we might be
rocking on the outside for
this one. Yeah we notice.
You want to make that call
then you better not mess
this up. You hang tight
there but when the time
comes I'll get yeah.
Rockstar thank. Draft more.
What why. I don't look at
me I. Everybody menacing
let me only. Not bad. So
for someone else
. Sixty
gadis. Many. Thank you. You
B.
no we're going to
revisit why Connick brands
that are being remastered
for modern platforms first
up relive the classic games
in the final fantasy series
and then give one more peek
at legend of Mauna ahead of
its June twenty fourth
watch.
Next earth's
mightiest heroes can. Bite
to defend the world in
Marvel's Avengers the team
of crystal dynamics is
excited to share the latest
updates with you. Including
new mission types and a
growing roster of heroes.
Sure that's super weapon
and all. He is building.
Capital. You.
You don't
understand.
I applaud your
efforts to connect with two
hoops. But is the man who
has seen three black
candles for. Hey must one
of the few thinks. I hi you
are able to look. Wait. The
school.
Hi you. I will.
Now
it's time to give local
players a quick look at
some of the games that will
be available in the coming.
Good evening for twenty six
our intelligence reports a
new threat to global
stability. Their reach is
unlike anything we have
seen before. Following
Asian forty sevens
disappearance you were
selected because you
remarkable skills.
Execution must be perfect.
Strike from the shadows.
And they will never knew
what hit. The first mobile
entry. Reincarnation.
Today
the team that platinum
games is giving you an
exclusive look at the world
Babylon's fall featuring
fluid come back powerful
weapons in the unique art
style. Is it was meant to
be a our. It was Thomas.
Undermines the coldest two
wins. Tower became a symbol-
vision.
This. Little begins
its tale of both hope and
despair. The whole Gearbox.
Circus C. Neil. Fox
optional. Also it get over
it on this the stock market
support bungie can you Neil
optional. Channels simply.
This well done works get.
The currency of all. The
auction a- Direct is
critical today must. Under
state also molested. Yeah I
want to make a decision. St
still- also not on the
surface. About the W. of.
Yeah I need to do. And also.
Georgine saw to listen. PC
six. Carpenter. Twenty on
the solicitor so it's going
to come comes. Six all we-
have to stay the mobile
data between. W. is wasn't.
Triple a posted by thank.
This was. Now let's check
out the next major engine
popular life is series true
color the team at deck nine
is ready to give you a
deeper look at Alex chan
psychic power of empathy
the first here's a look at
the life is strange
remastered collection.
Feels weird to be back
after five years you're
still Max Caufield. Do you
remember about us as kids.
I think about us as little
pirates running and jumping
through Arcadia bay. Or
take my picture with you
can't. Three two after my
dad died and you moved I
felt abandoned. Good Pregel
save my life. She was my
angel. Something happened
to her we have to find. He
should. What's going on. I
discovered I could reverse
time. Hello is this.
Whatever's going on between
us is special. Back before
you. I realized I had a
choice and the power to
change everything. Based
the edge of disaster. Time
to change time. Whatever
happens always have your
back. Hi I'm Maya also
known as MXIM tune I'm a
musician and did the
singing voice of Alex chan
in the upcoming life is
strange true colors I hope
you enjoy that first look
at official gameplay from
the remastered collection
as a long time fan I know I
did. You can see the love
and care that deck nine of
put into remastering both
life is strange and before
the storm this collection
features improved character
animation lip sync and
visuals breathing new life
into these two beloved
games. Back in March we
also revealed the next
major game in the series
life is strange true colors
a small town supernatural
mystery. Alex chan must
uncover the truth behind
her brother's death using
her psychic power of
empathy to unravel the
shocking secrets of heaven
springs. Today we have a
first look at Alex's unique
power in action. Here's
game director his accuracy
for more. Alex is psychic
powers empathy is integral
to the story of life is
strange true colors.
Impacts every relationship
she builds and every
decision she makes never
thought I'd have a free
GamePass friend. Three
years Alex has been unable
to shut out the strong
feelings of others. The
sheer. Sadness and anger of
those around her leading
her to believe her power is
a curse. In the wake of
GamePass death Alex
realizes the only way she
can find the truth is to
increase her power. I can't
believe this is happening.
The only way to understand
is to feel what he's
feeling. From the very
start you can use Alex's
power to focus on brightly
colored orders to gain an
insight into people's
emotions. Just to. These
valuable insights deepen
Alex's relationships with
the focus even springs as
well as sparking new
dialogue options and events
is here from a scene very
early on in the game you're
gonna lose service can a
loser and it's all your
fault. Alex has uncovered
his secret and mac wants to
keep hidden from his long
term girlfriend. And now he
is terrified that Alex will
revealing before he can
talk to Riley. She is the
best thing that's ever
happened to me. Please help
me out. Max telling you a
whole lot of chess thanks
for telling me the truth
Alex are we still together
for you. I need to get back
to work sure Alex will.
Alex encounters a
particularly strong aura
she can reach out to
actively connect with that
person's emotions. This
generates a Nova
supernatural flair that
transforms the world around
Alex into a reflection of
that person's psyche. In
this altered emotionally
charged state Alex can
experience fragments of
thoughts and memories to
get to the- you. But not
every emotional crisis can
be easily dealt with some
carried dangerous even life
threatening amount of power.
I wish you. No decision is
easy and the consequences
will be felt across the
game this anger could kill
her. What if. I could just.
Take it away. Using Alex's
powers the only way you can
uncover the truth behind
her brother's death. What
would that do to her. What
would it do to me. And even
if I can. Should I. How far
will you go in pursuit of
that truth. The choice is
yours. Alex's powers looks
so awesome I have no idea
how will make some of these
choices but I can't wait to
play with you all when it
comes out on September
tenth. Don't forget you can
pre order life is strange
true colors now and if you
choose the ultimate edition
you'll also receive the
life is strange remastered
collection. And that's it
for today make sure to
follow the life is strange
social channels for more.
And now we are excited to
unveil a brand new title
from Square Enix Japan.
Chaos that's my mission.
Looks like this is. For
thank you yes we do sure. I
only know one. I wanted to
this need to. It's not
dream. You can always call
us monsters for so long.
Doing pest control this is
the short. We just have. To
this is. This is it no
doubt. There was. He never
returned. E3 J.
we're here
to. Prophecies very own
warriors of light.
I'll
leave you with a look at
some of the amazing
Square Enix titles you can
play now as well as those
to come. News just hit me
with trap number seven
they're going to do what.
Thank you for joining us
today keep an eye out for
news about our next
Square Enix presents I'm
Sir see you next time.
Hey
everyone and welcome to the
games will post show full
Square Enix presents at E3
twenty twenty one I'm
lucy james joined by
phil hornshaw. That's going
and tamoor hussein not
everyone needs to have a
press conference. Yeah
because you can doesn't
mean you should okay. So is
it. With them I'm sorry I
don't think that was. I
yeah I would as bad as as
Gearbox I think it started
strong and then it just.
Definitely derailed a
little bit- but we'll we'll
talk about it are we here
for the next half hour or
so breaking down what we
saw as a part of the
Square Enix presents just
now- as well we have so
much more lined up for the
rest of the afternoon you
know wanna stick around
we've got more from back
the blood. As well as the
future game show and PC
gaming shows- so you know
date I guess you call is
day two of the three but
this is the big one lots of
stuff to talk about let's
talk about what we just saw
it as a part of Square Enix
presents. Let's go from the
talk. Let's go free
guardians. I so we talked
about it in a pre show. It
would it's been rumored for
a long time and finally
made official today I'm
glad that they- are the
kind of put it. Right off
the bat because it's coming
out. Much sooner than I
think a lot of people
anticipated but it's coming
out in October. I so. The
day sixteen unfortunately
not making other days as
well they are working on
Marvel's guardians of the
galaxy. Phil what do you
think this. I'm into it I'm
a big day sex human
evolution ten- mankind
divided. Less so. But you
know- I like what it seems
like. I just Montreal's
doing here with these.
Service focus and- and the
over the top humor like it
really feels like they're
nailing that tone- what
people like about the
guardians of galaxy so it
seems like it moves really
fast it seems like it has a
lot of fun. Character
moments and you know sounds
great to me that's that's
exactly what I like about-
DataStax. And looks like
it's mixing together those
elements really well. Yeah
and it has this sort of
choice based our game plays
well- I really. Our well I
like the fact that it has
kind of tell tale is
elements to the point
where- Drax is gonna throw
rocket over a bridge sort
of thing and there is the
sort of rocket will
remember that. Coming up in
the corner which I kind of
like. It's I mean I think
after. Marvel's Avengers
coming out I don't think
anyone really anticipated
them going. Just district.
A single player route but
they are with this one it's
like a full complete story.
I time you are big. You're
my comic Scotty. This is an
original story but that
taking some well known and
less. Well known. Marvel
characters in this. One if
you who you're excited to
see. Honestly like I'm most
excited to see the actual
team I mean. I was gonna
say the actual team members
all the guardians but then
forgetting that because
michael highgam was shown
in there because of all the
Soviet dog who's going
telepathic. Abilities which
is just- an incredible cold
for that team to grab
because mother dog actually
becomes a member of the
guardians if I remember
correctly- so I don't know
maybe the chance I hope. I
did I did speak to the
developers behind the team
behind the game I just
Montreal. And I also like.
Hey so we gonna have other
guardians joining because
mantis was shown briefly
and because. Right I don't
know man dog in combat
would go down pretty well.
And they kind of just
smiled and looked at me so
I don't know if it's gonna
happen. Michael highgam my
fingers crossed for-
because my- in the actual-
playable role but- yeah
it's looks like. My general
impressions of the game- my
preview of it it's off now
on GameSpot dot com video
game website. And the thing
that I kind of try to drive
home is it feels like the
polar opposite of- models
of engines from crystal
dynamics where. That game
came out and it kind of
stumbled out the gate it
get ready No Way what is
people are like is this a
single player game is the
multiplayer. Game what the
hell is this thing. And it
was hard to tell for white
ones. For ages what is this
game they came out it came
out like kick the door in
they said exactly what is
it what was we knew exactly
how it's gonna play. And
it's call confidence and
it's got a self assuredness
that the Avengers game
absolutely did not have.
And I think that went a
long way in winning me
over. I think I ended my
preview by likening it.
Quite a lot to insomniac's
game when spider man came
out it was like. They had
this why can't they know
exactly what they were
doing and they were
confident in what they
were. Putting out there and
that's what this kind of
feels like it feels like
it. It's closer to
insomniac's mall will games
then Square Enix his own
other mobile games or
something like mobile
devices Capcom infinite
from Capcom which. Was a
bit. Rough yeah I mean I'm
I'm super intrigued by the
fact that they are telling
their own stories but they
all. Was he pulling from
all over in the models sort
of universe- I mean it's
going to be held under in
that you've gone like I
said because no. And mantis
I wouldn't be surprised if
we didn't see some kind of.
Much more famous faces- but
I think as well the thing
that's really intriguing.
Hello Chuck are browsing
online is that like. Well
they're not using you know
the Chris Pratt- Dave
Batista. Likenesses they
are kind of erring towards
more of a comic thing. But
then people complaining
that they haven't gone. To
they haven't got this one
to fall the other. Way
which is like while this.
And there's always there
but I'm I'm into by it I
eat. Really that they
picking all over they the
kind of picking up on music
as well as- is it is always
been a huge part of
guardians- and the fact
that they are having a
license contract because-
just like time I also spoke
to the developers and
you'll see that interview
as- a playful late. This
week- but yeah like they're
picking up on the music and
that kind of. They get to
cherry pick from all over
guardians Laurie suppose
which is very exciting for
me. And I don't know like I
feel like the smart thing
to do is to not- tie
yourself too closely to the
MCU versions. One because
you know. You're just
setting yourself up for
failure once you start
looking like a character
from. The MCU people
crossing can why doesn't it
sound like that character
that's not what this
character would say
eccentric such EIC sestra.
And you just like I said
you set yourself up by
Fabio for failure by.
Trying to invoke too much
another version of that
character. I just makes
more sense for. This
material to define their
own versions of the
guardian. I for one think
they have designs all rainy
cold like I really love the
way. More a specially logs.
She looks incredible. And
rocket and Drax looks good
as well to me. I think the
only weird thing that
people are probably can.
Call up on is P. as half
what. He also 5 don't worry
about it you'll A. yeah I
think it's well I mean.
Gameplay wise that's the
bit where I'm- it looks
very very fast and frenetic
which on the one hand can
be a good thing but I worry
about sort of getting a bit
lost in it like a maybe
just because I'm playing
plus the fact again at the
minute I'm playing mass
effect three the minute and
I'm you know you have
squadmates who you control
and you can micromanage and
time slows. And I worry
with a hard like that with
the- the you are the way
they have it it reminds me
a lot of like- dragon
age's. Where like there is
there's no. Waiting next to
whatever that power is it's
just an image. And I'm
gonna have to remember that
for three other or for the
members of the guardians
and I worry. About how
that's going to be to play
but I do like the fact that
you know that this is
stagnates or you can have
this kind of big. So to
finish EIC shows Dr the end
I suppose- Phil what did
you take away from the game
play. Yeah so I'm I'm-
wondering like how
independent. The other
guardians actually are like
that was kind of the
impression that I was
getting from. Talking ten
stuff and it's that you're
a member of the team and
like you're giving orders
but you're not necessarily
controlling everybody so we
yeah like to your point
about how those icons are
going to work and how all
those powers. Are gonna
work it seems like it could
be okay if it's not super
micro managing and if
you're just like tracks do
a direct thing and then
Direct handles it right and
so you're worried about
Peter quill and- you're
utilizing each of the-
teammates- at the right
time potentially. But not
necessarily have to think
about what everybody squad
powers all the same time.
Yeah I'm interested to see
how that all works. Yes for
me like the way I feel
about it. In a lot of ways
is mobile versus Capcom has
always find games online.
I'm kind of. Reference
point for most things but
it felt well looks like it
could function a lot like
the assist mechanic where.
You control one character
qualifying and then you tap
a button and what happens
is. Your backup character
jumps in does a move and
then jumps out. And you
used up based on what the
attackers to control space
all create a juggle a
situation that kind of
stuff. And it felt like it
was kind of moving towards
that way you know you've
got your- doing these
attacks and that kind of
stuff and you know- there's
a character that I'm almost
like. Done with well I need
them to not run away or
anything so you know you
top the group funding group
like does a long range
attack to keep them locked
down in place. Something
like that I'm sorry feels a
lot like the- they're kind
of like there to. Behave on
their own and you. Their
their special abilities to
your benefit. Which if it
does work like that I'm
really intrigued to see how
good it. Feels inflows
because- you feel like you
and- like I said like
about. It was like a
platinum games idea and I
do want to well I don't
Montreal can. Pull it off
of the same kind of
sickness and- and I'm kind
of like a flow to it the I
would 1 out of it. Yeah I'm
totally I'm I'm I'm I like
I'm holding- seven
judgemental actually play
to see how it all feels
when it all comes together.
I'm January court like not
even close that risk I am
very optimistic about this
game I really love the look
of it I love. The
soundtrack got me I think
whenever you Joan Jett I. I
michael highgam came in. As
so that's the guardians of
the galaxy coming out later
this year coming out in
October so don't worry so.
Long to wait at all after
that we got the final
fantasy. Pixel remaster.
Going and he I mean that I
you can basically the
sentiment has has not
explained the sentiment
that Square Enix USA
Twitter account has changed
his status to private so
you called following naval
at square USA managed to
Square Enix like they just
got rid of it on everyone
I'm like oh god what is
happening all this is
Square Enix okay is there
is there is anyone like
relaxed right now because
the holy **** is going down
like a lead balloon I think
the main issue with it is
like. It mo bile and- I
don't know people went in
expecting way more out of
any kind of re what final
fantasy promise that I
would I think it was. The
general sentiment I think
confines of final fantasy
is why do you keep doing
these classic games which
are some of the best so
day. And it doesn't make
any sense why they keep
doing it. Like you all it's
really devaluing the
historic impact of final
fantasy some of those
stories remain best final
fantasy stories to exist
and they somehow both. It's
a screw up in the original
versions of those out all
remaking them into
something that. I wish I
could like grab someone
else Square Enix and shake
him and be like please
stop. Abusing your own
franchises like the state
is that bad. But are you
calling I mean yeah yeah
that but no one has not
gone down very well I think
it's because- I'm not going
to be on switch which-
everyone seems to think is
a huge. Misstep so kinda
understandable the sort of
anger behind that one. I
was a new trailer for
legend of mana. I'm coming
out June twenty fourth
number so for that one.
Marvel's Avengers now fill.
At any moment. So I played
a whole lot of Marvel's
Avengers right up until
like two weeks after lunch
right so I got into it I
really enjoyed that game-
specially Winston story
content but yeah I think
like just about everybody
else I hate that and point
and- kinda lost- interest
in the in game stuff you
know like it's just not
enough content to keep you
going and- I would really
like to get back into it
because I really like. What
backing does with
characters and the synergy
stuff can be cool- it's a
fun world champion and I
think that's- pretty much
it's pretty strange. And
the so I want a reason to
get back in that's what I'm
hoping for- with the- black
panther. And stuff like
that like I. Bring me back
I want to come back I'm-
I'm right there. I still
have it installed I didn't
pop yes so. Come trailer.
So we got- the June update
which is the cosmic cube
and then a new mission type
with Monica controlling
cube than those the July
update with whole crying
you mission- defeat signs
reprieve and then summer
and beyond is a war for
kinda at times you like
what you sort of war for
kinda. Yeah I mean from
what I saw it looked like
there was a lot of cool
things to check out I again
my question is how long
will that loss is only so
long before like if it the
problem like I said in the
preshow was the content
that they deliver becomes
you start repeating it
extremely fast and then you
lose last. Very very
quickly. From what I've
seen like this story style
stuff around. China and the
Black Panther and that kind
of stuff is it's making me
in and- I'm I'm a sucker
for Marvel stories.
Especially one set in
Wakanda and kind of like
far off regions so I am
excited for that part of it
again the question is how
long will you hold my
attention for this time I
hope it's longer than the
last few drops have been-
I'm cautiously optimistic
about what's going on
they've been dropping like
cool skins and that kind of
stuff so for me it's been a
case of. I still have been
my dip in an alpine kind of
storing stuff up so when it
does launch maybe I'll go
through and get a bunch of
scans and the cosmic cube
stuff on the red room stuff
and the Wakanda stuff and-
all in one big go and
hopefully that carries me
through for a little while.
But yeah I like what I saw
so far. Phil do you think
the willful conduct of. Was
enough to bring you back is
it is it going to be the
thing that finally. Just
booted back up on your on
your Playstation. It's
definitely the stuff that
I'm interested in it really
looks like it's- cycling
back to that you know big
story focus kind of- kind
of idea and I. I do feel
like the game does that
stuff well it really does
kind of have a good
understanding. Of those
characters. And the way
that they interact with
each other and I'm really
interested to see. That
take a new direction and
develop. More characters
more stories more bill and
stuff like that so yeah I
mean- I'm kind of I'm- I'm
gonna approach and I think
cautiously optimistically.
And kind of see. How other
people react to it see if
it's it really is going to
be that draw or not because
you know it's kind of an
investment to get. Back in
and start leveling up and
all that stuff. And I kind
of forget how the game
works. So they- put some
time in you know- now get
lost in those like games a
little bit so. If it's- who
is called it looks in the
trailers then yeah I'm down
for sure- but I'm gonna I
think you have to take a
minute and make sure that
it's really going to hit
those marks. I mean I so
after the- mother's vendors
update we saw a few mobile
titles so bring you hit
mine sniper. Gamer we saw
some of the reincarnation
of the final fantasy. Aksel
realistic is it was that
one- coming out this year
on iOS and android. But you
mentioned live service
games that fail. Nicely
about Babylon's it was the
Gaming time and I was most
excited to see more of
today and a pre show. And
yeah what time did that
when they said that is
going to be a live service
game- one one what a worry
why does everything have to
be a large live this game
stop ruining all the good
ideas live service nonsense
I don't know maybe it's
gonna be amazing and I
don't know like platinum
haven't gone we. Live
service game by. God this
there's just something
about the- the kind of
points- Fabio on a live
service experience all
considerably more than in a
you know a standard first
person no offense but the
standard single player game
or even a multiplayer game
just a straight up
multiplayer game. When you
introduce a live service
the chances of you putting
out something that sucks
just exponentially
increased even if you are
one of the best developers
around like. There's a nine
M. X. is a great great
studio like. But pay
introduced they give
himself a well of problems
by making Avengers I live
service games. Unlike I the
last thing I want from
platinum is a on going.
Multiplayer game that is
gonna have ask me for money
every now and then and make
meat grinder four things
every now and then. And
just I don't know like a
felt like the rug was
pulled out from underneath
me I'm sick of live service
games other times just over
saturate on live service
games they're just
everywhere and- I was
looking forward to playing
at you know classic.
Platinum action game- some
of the most and like
between don and the one two
punch of very questionable
voice over a in that
trailer. I was just like
deflate it by the end of
it. Having said that.
Taking a positive stance my
name's mechanically they
make the most re playable
games around EIC Dakshin
mechanics they set out a
foundation to execute
mechanics that are just fun
from start to gamer to
finishing to finish the
game so if they have
created good enough called
mechanics to the combat
that they consisting of an
ongoing. Multiplayer
experience I'll hold my
hand up and be like that
play you did did you get
the good stuff at at that
point the question becomes
are they going to monetize
the crap out there I need
the grind going be like
unbearable well I'm willing
to give them the benefit
under the benefit of the
doubt I need. Hopefully the
combat is good. This call
it works as a law service.
If it is. It's going to be
on the side with platinum.
I assume we don't have
before going throw back the
S. history of very. And I
did want to talk about this.
While we have the time. To
stranger apartheid final
fantasy origins which has a
demo going live later today
which is playable from-
today June thirteenth until
June of twenty four- we
knew the rumors that team
in June we're gonna be
working on a final fantasy
game- we saw in the in the
kind of opening credits
said- Namora- is involved.
And I really struggled to.
I don't like writing on on
games like I try not to do
that but the- what was
going on with that like
what W. what is the problem
with chaos what's their
problem is. K. is all about
passages. Business means
yeah it means you're gonna
kill chaos and Namco chaos
and chaos will become
chaotic and then you have
chaos in your hands and
that means Kelce's
everywhere and so you have
to fight the chaos and kill
the Kelso. In review chaos
is happening and you have
to kill the kale so
hopefully you will see the
Kelson kill the chaos thank
you for your time. In this
presentation about chaos. I
mean yeah not yeah. What
did you make of I got a I'm
genuinely surprised that
the word chaos is not in
the title of this game
that's really Romeo. Well
what did you. You're fired.
I don't know I feel like
temp kind of summed it up
you really kind of you know
hit every mark. Trailer not
but it. Seriously it does.
At least looks. Fun to play
I don't know. Anything else
I don't know like it's a
lot of cut scenes a lot of
chaos. And to that point at.
You know that's not what I
go for final fantasy game
I've 1 it like be engaged
in the world and that.
Trailer for me. But you
know what teenager. At
least it looks like you'll
be doing cool stuff with a
sword in like turning
people crystals and buying
them and they explode and
all kinds of weird stuff.
So to that end I don't
know- I've I've really
enjoyed combat in final
fantasy seven remake and
that. Looked a little bit
reminiscent of the same
thing- so maybe okay we'll
be into the- if it's
mechanically satisfying
that can go. A long way I
suppose- to push through
some of that. I mean this
is so that's the thing
when. The initial sort of
words came up on the screen.
Didn't I say always has a
kingdom hearts by. Men like
Moore was involved and I
was like okay I can see I
see I see how this is come
together and that's the
thing it's like when I was
younger I could push
through. The dialogue stuff
like I mean kingdom hearts
I'm a huge fan. Like don't
even country I love kingdom
hearts. But sometimes you
have to you just have to
admit. Some of the dialogue
so great and I think you're
much more forgiving of it
when you grow up with a
franchise it is very
difficult as- and it's all
these give me playing my
game to kind of. Approach
it. And just sort of agree
that yeah chaos. Unlike we
should definitely be done
we can send so. Very
intrigued to see more of
that and like I said the
demo's going live today so
maybe maybe it was just a
bad trailer and maybe the
actual game itself provides
a lot more context but who
knows- we'll have game play
up very. Very soon- we're
gonna throw the essay and a
little bit- and then we're
going to have the fact the
bloods showcase one of
brothers are showing up on
but as we got confirmation
in the Xbox- and as the
event earlier today that's
going to be coming to
GamePass day one when the
game launches. In October
will be here afterwards
breaking down everything
from the press conference
and then later this
afternoon we've got the PC
gaming show as well as the
future game show and then
the very end of the day
we've got Kurt Jordan until
you come back- it's a wrap
up today to E3- so please.
Stick around- now we can
head over to the essay- and.
Then like I said it'll be
back for blood. Okay-
the.
So I oversee entry colors
initial became a fight at a
motions to an extent why
you know this is actually
pro fourteen sahabi game
play what you done to
ensure that this most
awesome emotional impacts
of the general stories
still being retained so in
order to do that- we have
our town haven springs
where main character Alex's
walking around and she's
able to interact with-
characters all over the
town with the range of
emotions from fear sadness.
Joy and anger- and the way
we visualize this is
through what we call
emotional R. as and which
Alex can see around the
characters and then it also
allows the player to do the
second hour of empathy to
read the characters
thoughts and emotions-
which allows Alex to
connect with them- and have
yes side storylines and-
more emotional connections
with the characters and so
on that subject actually
regarding the emotions and
you know this connection
access with them just
before the storm. So in
contrast to the other two
life is strange games it's
a much more grounded
experience way have us yeah
I need babies should not
relent element of C. was
secretaries visions of a
father but Hey you've ready
if from yourselves in Sabah
like a strange element of
more supernatural so why
did you decide that was the
route to go correct yeah
this one is a much more in
the supernatural element.
When we first started
talking about using the
power of empathy we felt
that it needed to have a
supernatural element to
really allow the player to
connect with the
characters- and also give
Alex this extra element to
use her power of empathy
and the best way to show
this was to embrace the
supernatural I feel like it
really- follows the life is
strange staple of having a
beautiful setting and also
this supernatural element
on top of at say one thing
about all of the longest
range Gaming cream based 1
have in common actually is
the crummy place real
teenagers. It was a
conscious decision you'll
pop. It was I think Alex is
by a lot more than know
just age as she really a
well rounded- but we wanted
to have a strong female
leads someone- that players
could really connect with
and relate with- and you
know with her power of
empathy she's just a great
character to connect with
them I'm really excited for
fans to see her I think
she's going to quickly
become a fan favorite. And
then Femina choice in life
is strange overseas very
important what should be
your first service in true
colors in terms of is a
good choice always Clea
well actually I think it's
interesting question
because one of the things
we strive for is not always
you know labeling what is
good and what is bad I
think you know in life is
strange one of the things
that fans really connect
with is how dynamic the
characters are- you
characters have elements of
good and bad but we try to
stray away from just a good
character or evil character
it's their choice and they
can own it- not to be
judged or feel like they
made the evil choice or the
bachelor is. Yeah I'm
actually going back to the
issue of teenagers I mean
it was generally speaking
hello to you know you could
save it during your teenage
years no more emotionally
volatile it's not something
that you're reflecting in
the game the toll it
because I'm a to have
noticed what you feel
inside 5 Ross over its
primary teenage girls
awesome older carts is well
is not reflected in the way
of emotions workers who.
Are well it's interesting
because Alex had a very-
yeah trouble childhood
coming to the foster home
so even though she is a
teenager- she's very mature
for her age she's been
through a lot so I think
that you know a motional
knowledge how that you're
talking about we can
actually see and characters
of all ages I even the
thought she connects with
the- their value follow
Thailand there emotions so
we tried to have. You know
a more realistic approach
that- even though teenagers
may be emotional about how
even in our adulthood we
still feel those emotions
and have. A wide range I
know you if the speculator.
How this is this- game than.
And else in life just there
is far. And of these
optional injury. Are in to
any of those. An anybody
more impactful from the
claim EIC specs. Looking
he's an admissible
character or choice. So the
optional content we really
wanted to keep as optional
unmissable- I think it will
impact the user's
experiences they might not
be able to connect with
these characters as much
but if you stay on the
critical path and just do
you. The primary
interactions you won't miss
any of the key elements of
the story. All of the open
spaces like you're talking
about a really just a way
to explore the town connect
with the people. Use the
power more often- and it
could you know help as you
go on so you know more
about the characters but
you won't be punished for
missing any of this
content. So one can I have
noticed with life is
strange of the tumbled one
single site before the
storm which also so really
captured- is it just it
looks and sounds and feels
like an indie movie. Is
fine tension on if it is
what is I mean if you
haven't you catch about.
Absolutely I think we
really try to capture the
indie feel because that's
the roots of life is
strange. So for this title
to colors we actually
worked with a lot of indie
artists- so the music so a
big elements of it- as far
as the visuals we did a lot
of research on and- you
know mountain towns. Being
out here in Colorado- we
had a lot of inspiration
and so we really just try
to capture that sure that
cinematic style and the
music. It's a it's a big
trailer for what the game
is. And again such a
reference before the storm
game. If I will see you
were allowed to love
creativity and by you will
simply have to sort of draw
within blinds back Chloe's
character was already
established the ultimate
ending you know when you
wear was carrying. But we
Trikala it's first. Lucky
strange game if all of you
I am characters you have
complete control of the
story. What we are able to
take from before the storm.
So it's to help to help you
prepare for about yeah
that's a great question-
for us says you know before
the storm we did use the
Chloe character which is
amazing she was the big
favorite of the studio but
at its core you know before
the storm is a love story.
It's about relationships.
And so but you because we-
that. We want a story. An
that the we want to stay
about how. And connects- so
we really started that as
our core and then we built
these characters around it-
but we really made sure.
That all the characters.
Fit into the life is
strange universe like I was
saying earlier about
dynamic characters we
wanted them to feel
realistic feel dynamic. And
have. Be able to have a
connection with these
characters- and then talk
about connection- she bet
is. A visitar recognition
tree before the storm
Trikala is in terms of
staff. Who crosses iva
instructor also festival I
want to ask. All the
characters but you had
introduced yourself. Why
staff why bring staff to
true colors and at robin
anybody else. Yeah well I
think you know working on
before the storm- I as
excerpts on that title as
well- we all love staff and
you know she was a great
character. So we were all
really excited as a studio
to bring her back- into to
reveal her in heaven
springs- and then I think
beyond that just the
connection that. Her and
Alex start to form
throughout the title- I
really excited for fans to
see more staff- I think
there's an element of staff
we all know from before the
storm. We're going to learn
more about her as a
character in who she is and
the experiences she's been
through- so I just think
she's a she's a great fit
for the story and just-
character that we all love.
Writing and working with.
Yes as a show S. U. B. a
bit more before front then
invest 1 than she was
before the storm. You'll
see. A decent amount of
stuff about the game- so
I'm going to be. To see
that true because- will.
Roseanne most. If have
multiple endings correct
and I'm well it will the
endings depend on like a
final choice as a tradition
started a series or is
there something a little
further back from the end
you can dave jewitt will
send you down a different
path. Like how how far back
if it is due for roads to
be ending diverge there
what's really exciting
about you because it's
actually an element of both
of that- your final choice
will reflect the ending but
there's also an element of
the relationships you
build. Throughout the game-
and how you'll see this and
the dynamic and things so I
think it's really important
as players are going
through that- you know
build these connections and
make these choices. We
didn't want a situation
where you just get to the
end and 1 decision-
dictates your experience at
the most recent footage a
bar scene occurs in a
little bit more dates how
what happens when Alex
comes was basically
powerful Laura a member of
there's no better talk
about it actually affects
the environment. I'm could
are you able to translocate
more detail about what
happens and- how the play
explores this or to the
barman. Absolutely so we
have different tiers of
using the power- there's
the 1 explained earlier
when you're walking around
town and you're able to
interact with characters
read their emotions and see
their thoughts and that's
what we're calling the
frequent use power as
you're walking around
you're able to use it in
our free rounds in our game
play. I we also have these
major power moments- where
like you're saying there's
a really powerful emotional
ara and- the way Alex
actually absorbs- these
characters emotions and
she's able to go into this
world that changes the
environment- and really
gain more insight into what
that character is going
through- so she's able to
explore the environments
they will look at objects
and all these objects
relate to emotional
connections. That the
characters she's-
interacting with has gone
through from your
perspective and okay now
this is back. A vehicle the
most control over. Well you
have. That players will get
of it. That's a question. I
for me. I'm really excited
for players to see- this
power of empathy that we're
talking so much about I
think especially in these
times. It's really
important to be able to be
kind to each other and
understand what others are
going through. You know we
use empathy a lot but with
this game really allows for
players to connect with
people see their struggles.
See what they're going
through- and really
understands. Mac you know
people are dynamic and we
all have our troubles and
we all have our try and
send. I'm really excited
for players to get to know
Alex. Which is. For me the
favorite character I've
ever worked on and so I'm
really excited for players
to see her she's just such
an inspiration- and then
also to be able to use this
power of empathy and
hopefully. You know allow
people to take a step back
in their life and see
others as well and a whole
new light. It should be the
first life is strange games
be released. As a complete
package of once- but it's
still splinter percentage
is that right. Yes that's
correct so there will be 5
chapters as we're calling
them right now but they'll
all be released. Together
is there anything that
you've done in true colors
that you weren't able or
didn't have time to do in
before the storm. I think
for us insure colors- you
know really embracing the
supernatural element like
you mentioned- this is a
big thing for us that.
We're able to now have a
longer game- a longer
experience and add more of
these power elements in. I
was I think the team is
really excited about. Also
the locations that we built
for true colors at the
environments are beautiful
and we were able to spend a
lot more time. Just
focusing on one town and
one location- that we could
really make and see this
dynamic place that it feels
like you're part of haven.
As you're playing. I'm and
speaking of the powers.
What was the process to
funny deciding bout was
what would be the center
began on empathy and
emotions yes Sir I think it
was a core pillar of our
initial story was having
empathy. You know like I
say we really want to tell
the story about kindness
and connection. And as we
were exploring that we
realized we had to have
more game play elements to
the power then just to have
this narrative- moment that
she could use and that's
what really influenced us
that. We need to have these
major power moments where
you can. Look into insights
and you can connect with
the characters. And then
from there we decided it's
really a great place to
just be able to connect
with the town as a whole.
And so we started to enter
game play into the town and
these open spaces. As I say
it was really an editor
pastas as we were writing
the story- you know. Us in
game design working with
narrative to really find a
great way to. Make the
power really sell and
something that players will
enjoy what what is it
around about what he'd done
to try and really flesh out
and build. Miscarriage of
his you know going to be
with the play from start to
finish. Yeah well I think
with Alex what makes her so
strong is. Just her realism
as a care there you know
she's. She's on a she's.
She's she's brave- just has
a lot of really good
qualities that I think.
Anyone can relate to- so
you know we didn't take
anything specific with
Chloe. Or previous
characters from before the
storm we wanted Alex to be
a character that stands up
on our own- someone who's-
who's real- and I think you
know I writers did a great
job of writing here and
then. Erica the actress did
a great job. Performing
answer and that. Is now the
character that we see and
love in this game it really
was a team effort to. Make
Kerr as great as she is
today. One thing is I just
catch me is an age of life
is strange games. Of many
couches have parents 5
absent or antagonistic or a
little bit about your-
system GamePass is. A trend
that continues into true
colors. Sorry gain was 5
conscious decision and all
the way. How do you think
about fades into the story.
It was in you know we did a
lot of research to make
sure that we gave the
foster care system justice
you know obviously it's a
complicated subjects. So we
just tried to tell like
most like the strange games
do- something that's Rio
but also tragic and- you
know in which in some
regards- as far as Alex's
parents- it definitely
influences. You know who
she became and who she is
as a person- I don't want
to say. Too much more than
that because there's
moments in the game where I
would love for fans to just
experience. For themselves-
yeah. Okay I think that's
what about it may second
thank you again so much me
time to talk to me I really
appreciate it. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you once
again to our friends over
at PC gamer for that line
and lots more to come here
but first. I want to
mention that our friends
over at door dash doing
some pretty cool makes a
tag in a tweet. Follow them
for your chance to win. All
one hundred dollar gift
card that's right folks one
hundred dollars now- so
make sure you guys do that
follow the prompts here and
you'll be a Gucci handbag
so. We've had some pretty
awesome moments are already
from this year's E3 it's
been great but I don't want
to take a second to you
know do some Mario
storytime among says friend
might might I add. How cool
is it that we get to sit
here with. IGN and GameSpot
both me and your G. for
Nerdist as well to talk
about this is probably one
of the highlights. For me
personally- but you don't
want to go down the line
Dan what is a- and E3
memory from your first E3
my first E3 well I grew up
reading like game prone EGM
and always reading about
right three year after
you're done right. I would
love to go to that someday
finally in twenty twelve I
got the chance and it was
just like. Full body chills
it was such a like a really
incredible moment for me
was like one of my first
jobs away from like waiting
tables it was like one of
my first real numbers rose
like. I'm working in the
field of like entertainment
journalism in covering pop
culture in the stuff that I
love. And I remember I got
to sit in the closed door
session to see Star Wars
thirteen thirteen R. I. P.
and- had my brain rent
asunder by how awesome it
looked. It basically that
game looked like it was
going to do for Star Wars
what the Mandalorian
ultimately did just open up
this whole world of scum
and villainy. And it also
taught me to embrace pain
because some. Sometimes not
all of your dreams can come
true in that case it was
sadly dashed upon the rocky
shores of reality and
development hell but one
day hopefully we'll go back
to correspond to a level
thirteen thirteen check out
that seedy underbelly but
for now. Hello yeah that
memory to hold onto a boy
can dream waking dream boys
and girls can dream Ali
what about for you- mine is
probably. A little bit more
evil so boys and girls do
not try this. At home- well
she's. Well I know Kinsey
my you all gone Jean-Luc so
I was maybe seventeen
eighteen years old and I
came is a media partner for
my high school newspaper.
Totally legitimate wasn't
in high school anymore at
that point. But I will
never forget them for some
reason handing me the badge
putting that lanyard on and
then just walking into the
convention hall and just
looking up all around me at
all of the different yeah
and like seeing like the
big Nintendo booth and I
think there was like
persona four dancing all
night. The house later
something yeah and then
just. Going over here like
you want to do little. Matt
was probably like my
absolute favorite memory of
just being in shock and all
that I was very yes you
know we saw. E3 on G. four
I found E3 from like Hey
Ashley what's your plan
they did like a blog there
and I'm like. Oh my god I'm
here this is this is it.
Yeah yeah well we have a
lot of time but-
michael highgam what about
for you. I grew up watching
the game spot and I had a
two thousand fourteen spot
DVD where they went around
E3 I'm like it be nice to
be there. Twenty seventy
was my first E3 and I did
it for GameSpot's webapp
and I'm like y'all this is
wild. Whimsical like I'm
doing work but it's just
it's wildly collaborate
with the giant bomb folks
because like what we see
them the office will let
you go to the drive on
couch like wow this stuff
is real I'm really here. So
I'll never forget- twenty
seventies a lot a lot of
work you realize how much
work is put in for like
folks at. GameSpot IGN so
yeah it's wild and payment.
Mac carbon date myself here
my first- forty with IGN
with two thousand six wow
so I got to I got to go to
some of the behind closed
doors demos. And river- to
doesn't six PS three and we
worked out yet three sixty
was apple didn't have one
yet so I was playing PS
two. GameCube original Xbox
games I got to go to the
behind closed doors there
was a mass effect and
bioshock. And I was
completely blown away I was
like. Feel like real. Now
Gen. Over everything I'm
playing right now it's like
wow this is a really
exciting way to start my
career and I didn't. Buy it
before we throw to our next
segment I did want to say
my- quick E3 story. I
commentated a majorly
Gaming show match for
GameSpot. Where I will
Lewan the last day of the
three. Because I was like
all they could afford. Fly
me in the last every three.
At the last moment and last
hour of E3 was my first one
but I remember being on
that airplane. Going to LA
and saying to myself. Mama
I made it. There is a great
time. But we have so many
great stories not just from
us but also from all of our
friends. All around the
industry and- some of your
favorite streamers as well
as- influencers. All
around. Had a bit to say
about what was their
favorite moments from E3.
I'm a criminal. Well I can
tell you growing up E3 was
like the holy grail right
like that was. I mean it
was like E3. I'll never
make it there wow- you went
in nineteen ninety nine
that was my first E3. I got
to see- they cool midway
like basketball cager
member that. I believe that
was the E3 were they
introduced the dream cast I
was in all. At every the I
tried. Everything I I've
played just the ads you
know the Ubisoft with was
incredible. They have made
just in a roller coaster
simulator and I was bad. At
that time I don't know what
I don't know apple.
Probably similar to a lot
of the other content
creators on this show we
just make it man we were
little kids like I was in
high school Nintendo was
handed out posters these
have only go. All the
posters up that I was like
yes and I framed it
immediately and put up on
the wall and I was like I
got that E3. Don't even act
like I didn't get IT E3
there it is right there the
time that I went to my
first E3 in twenty sixteen
I. I think I called in sick
that day I was like. You
know you turn on you stick
with yeah I just I just
don't think I would be able
to come in- sorry I don't
work there anymore so. I
can't get in trouble for
itself. Stories out there.
It was just. So surreal to
walk in and see something
that I've been watching for
so long. And it's there
it's in front of me here
and I I'm part I'm in it.
The college plays I love
meeting new friends I love
the panels. I love walking
on the- show room floor and
just seeing all these new
things it was just unreal
and it really. Solidified a
lot of feelings for me
knowing that I wanted to be
in this industry I had all
this swag on me. From one
of the holes where I played
a whole bunch of games. And
then I get to the next call
because I want to go in
there and see what it was
it was 1 with Sony and
Microsoft and also.
Nintendo and the due to the
door stop meals like. Polo
let me see your baggage and
I was like. Minnesota bad.
And he said. What's your
name and I've got that name
on the back.
What's up
everyone I'm Brian
o'donnell in today's sticks
we get our first look at
avatar frontiers of Pandora
far cry's most iconic
villains are back and
better than ever in Mario
Rabbids sparks of hope has
been officially revealed by
yourself after Nintendo Lee
get themselves yesterday
I'll get to that in the
sack but first here's my
friend Stella with some
news about the upcoming
avatar gate. Take it away
Stella. It's official
twenty twenty two will be
taking us back to James
Cameron's epic science
fiction world. In avatar
frontiers of Pandora
following a similar
announced then delayed then
wait forever precedent set
by the after movie sequels.
We first heard about this
game four years ago. It's
always on today's he was
off for presentation it
looks like this action
adventure game is set in
the first person open
world. Featuring the
western frontier a part of
the planet not previously
seen. Home to the
franchise's signature
living reacted Elian bio.
Well the game stars do
characters it's clear from
the trailer that it still
humanity and Max first is
the nabi and the wonders of
nature with a strong focus
on air combat. Somewhere
mac school is thrilled by
this news. Developed by
Ubisoft's massive
entertainment studio
frontiers of Pandora
promises to utilize the
division snowdrop engine to
expand and deepen the
avatar universe an exciting
and innovative ways along
with the film's. Massive
reportedly worked in
partnership with James
cameras production company
and Disney which could mean
a game very close to the
world of Pandora that we
now. Fans different from
massive other titles
notably Tom Clancy's the
division and an upcoming
open world Star Wars game.
The game is being developed
for next Gen consoles and
PC and yes this is what we
got instead of beyond good
and evil two. At long last
my dream of delivering far
cry three famous insanity
speech myself is coming
true. Previously leaked far
cry six is upcoming DLC is
all explore one of the far
cry series most enduring
elements the villains. The
DLC season pass will let
you play as Vaas Montenegro
from far cry three pagan
min from far cry four and
Joseph seed for far cry
five. All three previous
villains were shown along
with some real first person
gameplay seemingly set in
worlds that exist within
each big that's terrifying
mind. All three charismatic
characters seem to be
surprised by the fact that
the present but happy
nonetheless to be back
causing havoc. And so are
we that's all for far cry
six a season pass it will
also include far cry three
blood dragon in some form.
This much loved twenty
thirteen standalone
expansion for far cry three
featured a retro futuristic
world and- many nineteen
eighties action genre
elements. He was often
arching Kerr recently
announced a Netflix
animated series spin off
called captain Razer hawk a
blood dragon remix so it's
a somewhat surprisingly
good time for blood dragon
fans. Thanks a lot I cannot
wait for far cry speaking
of colorful games full of
terrifying villains a
nightmare animals the
rabbits are back and
they're teaming up with the
iconic Italian plumber
Super Mario once more. In
Mario and Rabbids sparks of
hope officially coming to
Nintendo switch in twenty
twenty two we actually got
an early look at the game
yesterday ahead of you be
soft conference when
Nintendo themselves at
least the game on their
official website. How dare
you Nintendo. It wouldn't
be a Mario and Rabbids game
without a leak happening
that's part of the
tradition at this point
either way the first game
was surprisingly awesome
and also a sales hit. So
here's hoping the next one
is even better even if
rabbit Rosalina is one of
the scariest things I've
ever seen in my. Entire
adult life. Anyway with the-
now in full swing what are
you looking. To most are
there any games you're
hoping to see onstage let
us know in the comments
below I'm Brian on time-
and that was your daily
fix. Now that you're all
caught up in the news make
sure to check out the rest
of our E3 coverage on
YouTube across social media
or even on your smart TV.
Download the IGN apple your
mobile devices and
subscribe to the IGN daily
fix on Snapchat for all
things everything else
video games. E3 and scary
**** rabbits IGN .com
thanks for watching.
What
Intellivision making twenty
three RD body. Sitting way
Chester dave jewitt. To ask
you. Going to the gym
what's up with the. So
cynical divisive yeah but I
John think. We should get
back. The Chinese well we
need to check on the new.
Fortnite. I tend to the
response. What if I was on
top. As a part of life for
all games but we'll be
bringing you the latest
Gaming news and
announcements interviews
with developers the biggest
press conferences and lots
more playful is our yearly
online event that combines
the excitement and
announcements of E3 with
charity live streams the
following week with lots of
special guests who gonna
help us raise money for
able GamePass. So join us
in June for E3 and playful
on GameSpot dot com Future
.com slash GameSpot twitch
dot TV slash GameSpot and
as a part of E3 official
broadcast. The event. And a
big thank you to our
sponsors the door dash to
get more from your
neighborhood from
restaurants and. R. eight.
A lot of talk about Sir we
do back for blood can't
wait for that to go we have
to I mean I for leads all
Cooper getting out there B.
cleaner take on the radio
yeah wait you know it's
funny- I was talking to
Damon and I was like oh
used to kick Greg's but
what's left for dead and I
was like nah we played
together and also we do.
Work I was thinking. Squad
ladies and gentle. Other
part we're tearing up
them's and let yeah is why
I'm so still to see rock-
return to this in come out
and do for blood you see
around the of this present
what's interesting if you
not what Twitter keeping a
with their this proposed I
think interesting
explaining more of their on
con. I'm the squad together
they said either do it that
if the PC leader has for
Peavey which means of
course of a pot something
vital B. to me in part so
if you to mention that
invest just leader to. And
then for P. V. P. vehicle
was how do you it from
being paid win they're
doing a thing where all the
PC P. N. com you can get
for by part so could pick
up by know because a lot it
right away but if want to
you can it for in the game
to which is a look you know
it's been interest me about.
For is a you know with
games we see them just tiny
bit yeah and there I was
kind of how anyway I know
that that's waiting I
apologize I've all- but
back for blood the exact
opposite like you yeah 1
you to know it. What this
game about have got and
very long. I all cleaner
yeah very inside look at
the is and I have I. Loved
every that I've yeah the
cleaners are. Varied
ability but- I mean it
because. This is all we
need that's thing I really
I've seen is been a Peavey
you which is why I get
let's talk about TV here it
is ladies and gentlemen the
back for blood show. You
know there was. A little
while. And W. games reached
out to me and I. Me if I.
To be a- of the reveal. Of
from the- and I knew. What
it. And I was so X. about
what this game. Is in any
the reason why. That was.
Stoked for ever. At home to
enjoy this so. Up next. W.
B. he throne you. So in the
middle. Of action with
there. Fan shoot. Back for.
So grab weapon of choice.
Because here is WB games.
Back for blood. Hello and
welcome to the back for
blood PVD showcase you
don't already know back for
blood is an upcoming four
player co op zombie
shooter. Made by the
creators of left for dead
they were diving deeper
into the new P. V. P. mode
called swarm. How it works
and what you'll be doing
maybe even a little bit of
strategy. Also talk with
turtle rock's lead game
designer on back for blood
Brandon Jana's to help
piece it all together.
Before we get there though
let's start off with the
reveal of the brand new PDP
trailer. And see what it's
like in action.
One this is
what when you don't stick.
That would intenso sorry
how the guys back for blood
T. V. P. mode swarm to hear
more about it and to take a
deep dive into the gameplay
mechanics we have turtle
rocks with game designer
I'm back for blood Brandon
Yanis. Brandon can you tell
us a little bit about the
inspiration of this you PC
mode and what makes it fun
and unique of course so
just like our previous
titles we really enjoyed
bringing new ideas to the
table are retaining the
spear and the genre that
while working and so
backwards PDP is heavily
inspired by a previous
titles and makes survival
fast action. Massive
monsters and a touch of
ports are goal is to make a
balanced and find P. P.
mode with just as much
replayability as the main
campaign so what's the
structure of the P. V. P.
like do you play around-
can you both. And written
one mac or are we between
the two yes so play as a
best of match team of four
take turn swapping the and
player the job of the
cleaner is disk supplies a
place on the map to forty
five position and try to.
As long as they can the
Britain's main object is to
kill the cleaners fast as
they can- this is achieved
choosing the right read and
to counter the other team
strategy using mutation
upgrades and by courting
attacks with other A. Eisen
players as the round
progresses the swarm is an
so this increases the size
of the written of tax and
sh. The play of space
sometimes forcing the
cleaners out of their favor
positions right so when a
team is why from the points
or score for how a server-
then both swap and then
they go from the other side
the team they runs the law-
as the- is the winner. Now
enter you play as all the
different in both in TV I
do have a few character
that you planned okay- the
mom a lot she's about
Saddam shock on she has a
lot of bill to that. She
can also help team instead
of. During battle all of
our have perks so now.
One
okay so Brandon we just saw
that each different red and
I- has their own variants
as well as their own
mutations on each variant
so can you expand on more
on the special abilities
and how they work sure so
at the start of each round
players can choose between
nine playable written each
with their own unique
abilities so for example
the stalker can pounce a
player and pull them away
from their team. Or an
exploder can time their
technician in the middle of
a group of cleaners and
fling them on separate
directions now knowing that
each region has these
different abilities- how do
they change and improve
throughout- the match and
improve the region's chance
of winning so as the
written battle against the
cleaners they gain points.
To spend these points
nineteen wide because you
take intentions are
improved lot different
things on the Razer. Maddie
facts their fill I might
the commenting I wave
inside strength to the
really cool thing is that
the whole team and they
between rounds so as a
written team starts.
Upgrades get pretty wild.
Right so if. You get them
to spread out and stuck
hereby stock MusicCast and
grab one of the cleaners.
And dragged them off into
the swarm the rex's vomit
also slows their victims so
if I tamoor hussein
actually pretty slow. Can
attack one of those slow
characters and really be
able to problem another
good one is an exploder
waits for a- cleaner to go
revived their friend they
can use that as an
opportunity to. Charge and
then on and sending them
flying to doing a massive.
Damage sounds pretty bird
also with that being said
which is your favorite
written to play out. That
has to be the Tallboy.
Pretty easy to pick up and
play and a lot of fun
hitting cleaners across.
Speaking of fun let's talk
about weapons now
throughout the trailer is
out you can see a number of
different weapons can you
go a little deeper into
what those weapons are and
how they work. So we really
wanted to expand on the
amount of choices the
player had in back for
blood with a weapon so of
course there's hand guns
shot guns LMGs. SMGS sniper
rifles and a whole bunch of
other types of weapons each
with sort of like a unique
character feel to them now
how deep. Does this weapon
customization go I really
want to know what are some
of the different attachment
options and how do they
change the gameplay
overall. Absolutely so
there's a lot of different
customisation options for
weapons. So throughout the
world you can find scopes
silencers stocks sites all
that good stuff you can mix
and match and so there's a
ton of options. Last
question. Do you have a
favorite type of weapon
absolutely so as I said
earlier. I really really
enjoyed playing mom so her
shock and is definitely a
top my list. That's a solid
choice. All right we've
learned a little bit about
how it all works the
cleaners the red in the
mutations as well as how
the customization works for
the weapons. Thank you so
much for joining me
Brandon. I'm for giving us
a little bit more detail on
back for bloods new PPP
mode swarm. Thanks for
having me- can't wait for
everyone to get their hands
on this game we're all
really excited. I can't
wait either the good news
is that you guys won't have
to wait too long. There's
an open beta coming up on
August twelfth with. Early
access portion on August
fifth available to those
who pre or- that's all for
today. The back for blood.
Still has a lot more to
reveal in the coming. So
slate and- hi.
Welcome back
to games but at E3 twenty
twenty one and we just got
a look at some back in full
blood that so to talk us
through it we've got
tamoor hussein. Hello I'm
back global. Do you have a
coffee in the middle of
that. Hi there. Phil long
show Hey Hey. He did not
match the energy but
honestly I don't know I'm
not gonna. What inspired to
have yeah I mean yeah it's
like ten PM over here- but
we got to take a look at
black back in for blood
that either running from
tower studios and as we saw
earlier this morning it's
going to be day one
GamePass we gamer launches
on October twelfth this is
gonna be open beats are not
even going to look at the
chart for this because I am
gonna get. Ripped to shreds
saying pizza last August
August- fourth of fifty- if
you sign up if you pre
order the game- so got a
little bit of information
that- with our- friends and
I mean Kyle hosting that
little. I info section we
talked a little bit about.
The red in the cleaners as
well as like how the US
warm gameplay- is going to
work. As well as how Razer.
Again working in the game
but Phil I'm gonna come to
you because you've actually
played some back the
bloods- when did you play
it what state was it in and
how did you find. So I
played way back in like
December- back from the
mispronounced. And so we
didn't play the P. P.
stuff- haven't had a chance
to try any of that. But I'm
really into what I've seen
it's very much- left for
dead- brought forward into
sort of the modern. Era of
multiplayer stuff it's
bringing in a lot of really
great ideas from areas like
battle royale it feels like
you know that that sort of.
Quality of loot lots of
different weapons getting
attachments. The longer you
survive the further out you
explore the more cool stuff
you get. And the game is
really good about making
those things work together
with that sort of left for
dead- core underpinning
right. So like I put a ton
of left for dead when it
first came out I believe
it's on the left to when it
first came out. But at the
same time like eventually I
kind of fell out of both
because- as different as
they could be a run to run
they were always more or
less kind of the same rate.
And what I think that-
black acrylic is doing
really well is working in
all these little elements
the sort of broke like-
dates with EIC its deck
building and stuff like
that. That make a lot more
variation in any given
match and so. What I played
I really enjoyed we got
rolled a lot in the end of
it it's you know for
extraction and you get to
the end. The hardest one
and we just got completely
demolished but it was cool.
Then we got completely
demolished you know is
different every time. So.
I'm into all that and- he
was kind of one of big
questions that I had at the
time. And I'm really
excited to see all this
because- really my favorite
part of left for dead. Was
that sort of- underdog
feelings of being zombies
and trying to coordinate in
order to out smart the much
stronger and like better
equipped. Player team and
this looks like from what
I'm gathering from well we
just watch it really looks
like that's where they're
leading to it they're
getting that same. Original
feeling from left for dead
of like you have to work
together if you want to be
effective at all but you
have to come up with like
really smart ways to use
your powers and- now we're
just seeing a whole bunch
more options and like a lot
more strategy in that and-
totally totally exactly
what I want from left for
dead I think that turtle
rock. Has really shown that
they're very good at that
kind of thinking especially
with- but Lebanon and also
with like a ball- and it
seems like it's really.
Taking that Korean
stretching it out really
cool ways. So yeah I'm I'm
really excited for this one
because I really want to
get back in there with some
teammates. And rip some
people to shreds just jump.
From across the map Landon
somebody carry them off and
just ruin their day that's
my favorite thing. Time
what did you take from
this- presentation. Yeah I
am it sounds really this
message it looks like left
for dead and- that's enough
for me M. obviously the
world has changed in a
significant way since left
but that first came out you
know. I'm as a as a-
community where closer
together and things like
this according to this a-
you know online plays way
better communication via.
You know consular services
I'm PC uses considerably
basso. I remember playing
left for dead in a time
when that stuff wasn't as
slick as it is now and
having just the absolute
best time but that stuff.
So the idea of playing a
game like this even if they
just re released left for
dead EIC SNH improved
version would have been
enough for me but- the
amount of. They're putting
in both incredibly well
like I had the 1 things I'm
most interested in seeing a
little more open. It's not
something they're making a
big deal but they did when
they were making left but
that is the ideal of an A.
I. director- that's
something that I would love
to know if they have talked
to you about fill the idea
that some there's almost
like an algorithm or like.
An A. I. that's fine you
know and- kind of
manipulating events in the
background to make as
challenging and as
interesting as possible
ways you get a good sense
of that fell. It's exactly
the same thing is exactly
what you wanted to be so
for instance we played the
same map two or three times
partially because we got
killed- but the director
totally change the
situation on us like. Two
or three different times
right so the first time we
came out of the safe room
nothing around not a big
deal we're going through
all these like outbuildings
and stuff for finding all
kinds of good gear. We
found like a locked door
that special locked or you
have to find he I think it
was somewhere around in the
area so there's like a lot
of interesting. Exploration
elements in that one. We
and then we restarted and
this. Time first thing out
of the door. The ground
rips open this huge twenty
foot tall older guy comes
out and he's just like.
Turning it into a run for
your life and it's the
exact same portion- but the
directors. Apparently
thought we needed to be
challenged more despite the
fact that we got run over.
So it just you know it's
created a completely
different. Situation and
the other thing that the
game does with the director
is. It has a deck to kind
of like you do as you're
building up your per card
decks there's apple like
deck building aspect of it.
The director throws a
couple cards out every
single time so you know.
Vaguely what you're gonna
be running into it might be
like fog. It might be-
enemies that have armor
because you know all this
what guys got eaten by
that. By the parasites as
well. So you get. A bit of
a sense of what you're
facing it's not totally
random but there are a lot
of things that the A. I.
is. Definitely a definitely
like actively tweaking. And
they can be. Small things
and they can be huge things
like a giant zombie thing
coming after you. So yeah
it's it seems like there.
Again like those great
ideas from left for dead
our- all. Sort of here in a
in an updated fashion and
they seem like they work.
Just as well as they did
back when. Those two games
came out- there it was
pretty exciting. And we had
a pretty good time. So
we've already talked a lot
about- the influences of
left for dead on impact for
bloods- but obviously tell
rock did. Kind of spin off
on their own for a while
and they made involves. Kit
and you know evolve hides a
lot of great ideas it was
kind of at this point
where. A secret
asynchronous multiplayer
was. In invoke really like
back in was a twenty
thirteen to fourteen minute
long term would have been
quite a lot of asynchronous
multiplayer stuff involved
had some great ideas. But I
think it was ultimately
hampered. AP by like. It's
a frankly bizarre pre order
stuff. I the- then there
was a lot of- Hey which
addition do you get in
which monster which-
unlockables it's the truth
that you're- but ultimately
as well just like the
playbase wasn't necessarily
that and that was a game
that probably could have
benefited from being on.
GamePass so is there
anything that you think
total rock also taken from
their experience working on
involves- when we look at
the PDP just now that kind
of gave me the same sort of
sense is that you know what
made of all cool when you
were playing as the monster
were all the different ways
that you could kind of.
Customizer experience in
like you know you were
you're running around
trying to make yourself
better- so that you could
be a more effective fighter
and it seems like those the
same ideas are kind of
there in the PDP site tours
like. But it more teamwork
involved which is cool.
You're thinking about your
evolutions and stuff. To
make yourself. Better as a
team. And that's all really
interesting to me and- it
seems like the- the right.
Takeaways from of all of.
Because you get to do it
with the team- that said
like. Like you mentioned
all that. Stuff that's- if
there's a thing that has.
Given me pause that's a
little bit. Of what it is
that sort of long term
multiplayer idea. Of like.
Okay how do you monetize
this but also how do you
keep the player base
together how to keep people
playing. How do you make it
so that it's- not. A
situation where if you
don't come into the game
six months. Up from lunch
to the first six months.
You're not like totally
balanced out. By and you
know I think that was. Of
all the major problem that
was a great game I loved
that game. Please so much
of it. For lunch after
lunch. You know I think
that you like you said
there wasn't really a race.
And people couldn't really.
Figure it all out right and
so I'm really hoping that
this. Finds a way to make
sure that everybody is on
the same page- I they did
just mention that. Team
leaders when they have paid
content everybody else will
get the same. Content in a
match which is great. But I
hope that there are other
ways to keep everybody like
connected and- playing on
the same field because-
evolve. Really deserves to
be a bigger deal I thought.
Then I never became and it
was for I really just think
it was. That trying to
navigate the whole business
side of it. Kind of doomed
it in in the early days of
the sort of live game idea.
So I'm really hoping that
back for blood figures that
out because- I really love
these long term. You know
weirdo. Team based
multiplayer experiences
they get so cool they offer
so many interesting unique
experiences of all pearls
really great about that
letter that was really good
about that. This looks like
it's gonna be great about
it too. Yes I mean you
mentioned and actually we
have the- the sort of
wedding from to a work
themselves they said in
PVD. So maybe if your party
leader owns a paid content
drop you will be able to
play that content with them
including maps. Gameplay
and campaign it means like
no separation no exclusions
no split and they kind of
followed up with MTV PC.
Everyone who bought back
for blood can get access to
full additional PVP content
so that's unclear if you're
getting it through GamePass
with everyone who bought-
even without purchasing
content drops- plays you
don't buy the content
drops. Can and you playable
characters and written in
P. V. P. for free through
progression additionally
OPV peak players have
access to the same cards.
The start of each match
regardless of whether those
plans have purchased
content drops. On so it's
definitely all thinking
about in trying to level
the playing field for
everyone. And I hope in
doing so you're you know
you're kind of going to get
that balance that you want
words people who just drop
in because they're friends
of playing and then there
are the hardcore players
who are going to play.
Frequently will buy every
contender because it's
available to you PC. Keep
reading go but I'm I'm
excited to see what the
future is the back but I
think it's bright I think.
I hope that the GamePass I
announcement will have the
same effect as it did for
outright is like we were
talking about. I want to
say earlier today it could
have been a week ago. Could
have been yesterday- we
talk about how I write is
sort of maintains. Sort of
a steady level of interest
and then you can see the
spike when they announced
it was going to be on
GamePass I hope it's the
same for. Active line is
that like. It felt like
there was always this
audience for it but now
that it's being opened up
to so many more. He's
hoping that that works out.
So for the rest of today-
that was always the
outback. Full bloods. A
post show we have to PC
gaming show which will be
streaming right here as
well as the future game
show. And then. Fill your
back with courage and joy
did the end of the day. To
wrap up. E3 day to. We've
got a few moments before we
go to the PC gaming show so
I want to know from tier
view. What's been your
highlight. From the day.
Time for you I will say.
All of the three because I
know what you highlight is.
Corn what is offering baby
it's raining all day every
day still undefeated as
best friend LV three
nothing's come close elven
rings gamer E3 E3 is not
even over yet by itself the
ring minimal chaos Maximo
fund. It is a valid we
definitely got cut off-
while we're talking about
all of the chaos- this
warning so- Phil what about
you what if you love seeing
E3 so far. You know I hate
I. Having a hard time
picking anyone things out
of that Xbox showcase I was
really just excited to. See
microsoft come out with.
Just a great. Line up of
stuff that I want to play
on GamePass and- on the
Xbox series acts that
frankly I have not given a
lot of attention to and I
kind of feel bad about
that. You know- I forget
the name now but the that
the new one from play that.
Is like extremely relevant
Ellie. Some of thank you
and- you know I was a huge
fan of inside and limbo and
I was like okay great that
sounds awesome. But there
is- handful of other cool
indecent whole showcase I
don't. You know if I can
pick any given one I had a
really. Good time watching
that that's really felt
like E3 in a way that I
don't know that. Yesterday
quite reached you know that
was the whole exposure
cases just like top notch
perfect. And then the halo
stuff- Hey Luke Corey in
motion the like- in the PDP
I've done actually that
might be it I think I'm
gonna go with a low
because- you know I've been
a halo player. Since Xbox
one just you know we I'm
old and I've played it with
all my friends in high
school we used to cart
around. C. R. T. T. V. EST
each others houses so that
we could do. Like the
system link lan parties- so
like good. Faster new halo.
Is really doing it for me
and this grapple hook looks
like it's going to do.
Something for halo that
I've always kind of wanted
to which was to speed it up
just a little bit or
something that I really
liked about reach when it
added all the- the armor
powers and stuff that. Like
you could sprint and maybe
you weren't gonna get
spanked by that guy. All
the way across the map who
is twelve and has really
good twitch reactions. And
you know. Master chief like
movies like he's on under
water a lot of the time so-
having a great look looks
like it's going to speed it
up in a way that. Really is
exactly what I like about-
FPS shooters in
multiplayer. But also
capturing that halo feel.
That you know I miss I miss
it bad so yeah I'm. I'm
really into that that was
really great. Yeah I agree
I really dating what I. Of
halo two- even though I
personally not like a big
halo play I've played halo
EIC Tamanna you and I and a
friend Simon. We're playing
through halo- last summer
when we were all sort of
locked inside going through
messaging collection. I
think overall I mean from
Ubisoft's. I we- I don't
know I. I'm trying to think
what there was. Download
the song hi. Johnson if
there was anything like
amazing. I think it was it
was kind of like more of a
slightly more predictable I
think showcase for
Ubisoft's and so it's kind
of like a soft sort of
loans to E3 official I
agree with you time but
anything Elden ring as a
part of something GamePass
looked. Incredible we are
hungry. Yeah I was gonna
grow from from microsoft
Lafayette replaces a
replacement or replace as I
think that looks so yes
like those of the- games
I'm like. Yeah those are
the three things I'm like
looking at my all girls are
awesome. Yeah and that's
the thing it's like there
are way more showcases to
come but I think I think
like Elton remember to give
that looks. It was kind of
like exactly what you want
from a from soft trailer I
think it really up the ante
in a lot of ways and just.
Already the speculation is
as to what this game could
possibly be on the fact
that it's coming way sooner
than we originally I guess
what they would- you. Just
kind of like a fairly
straightforward customers
may not really. Many huge
stand outs I think I think
the avatar game hops. I
mean like it certainly
looks beautiful but- as we
said yesterday I don't
remember anything about it
so. So the output of the
one that has to sort of
really works C. get me more
interested in it and then
from Xbox today I think
Xbox had. A really really
strong showing and I think
the real winner. Xbox
GamePass- we've been saying
it for I mean through
generation next to console
crew every time they talk
about GamePass it's
unbelievable just how could
that service is and the
fact that you know Xbox has
that in the cap to kind of
go look all these games are
brings the service- and by
the way day one they'll be
on the service- and you
can. Download and play them
thirty three to go but I
think in terms of like the
actual games R. Russell
obviously I am a huge fan
of arcane- and yes we
didn't see any of-
definitely today to be
expected given that is a
PlayStation. Five console
exclusive a for a while.
I'm really glad we got to
see something new because
obviously that's the
talented team at Leon is
doing definitely. But one
of us Austin been up to we
finally go on system that-
and every square I really
really love the look of
guardians we talked about
it earlier guardians just
looks like. A breath of
fresh air it looks fun.
Funny in particular like I
think. That's a really
difficult thing for games
to nail. As to be funny. I
think from what I saw of
guardians and from speaking
to the team. It's
definitely a focus for
them- and then yeah. I
think. And you can tell I'm
losing my voice which is
probably a sign. That this
is a time when I done for
the day. We'll have like I
said Phil could enjoy and
we're back after- future
game show and after PC
Gaming- to kind of run
through. Wrap up the day
will be back again tomorrow
with all of the biggest
press conferences from E3
obviously got Nintendo. And
BAndai as well on Tuesdays
so fingers crossed. For
some breath of the wild to
news I don't know anything
but I really really hope. I
thank you for watching
today we're gonna pass over
to the PC gaming show. I
have a great time and stay
tuned to GameSpot. Space
here twenty twenty one.
Having spent the last
twelve months hunkered down
in definitely not hiding in
a subterranean bunker. Our
heroes have letter the
board a spacecraft with.
One the hottest trailers to
bring the best interviews
to bring you.
Shuzhen clans.
Speaking. It is so good to
be back Gaming and this
year we're rooms. Captain
happy to be remotely
onboard shown well I'm so
glad you were able to
finance this year's PC
gaming show by you know
selling all those black
market graphics cards
you've been ordering. I yes
the crime with absolutely
no real world consequences.
Hey Frank you wait a minute
is sixty five ton catapult
mac model CBLT C. one is
featured in mac or your 5
mercenaries still in I
always knew you had
immaculate taste. Yes I
can't wait for this year's
significantly more
weaponized PC gaming show
to go off without a hitch.
Which reminds me Debat just
run a quick hitch scale yes
of course. Running his- and
I also want to warmly
welcome someone new to the
crew Micah burn welcome hi
everyone I'm so happy to be
here and look for to bring
all of you fresh new PC
games and hardware. Zero
presently in. 900-100-0600
and sixty five possible
futures how. Yeah. Well
Frankie dumbass gonna send
you the coordinates for
your first target- now your
targets might be exclusive
interviews trailer
premieres or any number of
amazing new computer games
to beam down to the fine
people on earth Mr Mercedes
well this is going to
continue until all the
targets required our
mission is completed
smoothly and without a
hitch isn't that right dad
bought yes no hitches
located shine. Not a single.
Right but first let's
teleport down to the stage
to check in on E3
happenings the only reason
were allowed to legally be
back on earth. Hello all
landed- great to be back
right right one of my
favorite planets in the
whole galaxy that's alright
and thank god that
teleporter was conveniently
built just out of frame of
camera maker are you ready
I'm writing well ladies and
gentlemen hello and welcome
to the PC gaming show
twenty twenty one it feels
great to be back on a live
stage once again over the
next ninety minutes we're
going to bring you
showcases the most exciting
upcoming PC titles with
world premieres and
exclusive interviews and if
dozens of new trailers
wasn't enough for you guys
later in the show we are
going to tell you how to 1
a custom made for your 5
theme to PC. Powered by
Intel so you're going to
want to stick around for
that now make sure to keep
out a special look for a
special promo code
throughout the show from
humble bundle during which
you can get a ticket to get
civilization six 5 medicine
for just ten Bucks but
right now we're gonna kick
things off with not a Cup
blade point probably the
most original entry. In the
battle royale genre this
year. That's.
HM I instead.
She now Gaming service. To
purchase from digital
sources like C. store.
Dying light. Three the
first trailer for teens
Donald. Be sure to check
out G. force now. PC she.
S.
my time is now. The.
Make sure to check out
dodgeball academia out soon
from humble games all that
was we don't you agree to
have Bob sure whatever you
say shine I agree with
whatever. You say. Since a
little bit of resentment
there buddy is some rusted
your port. I am happy to
play second fiddle tune
cabinets charming and
handsome as you. Also
definitely not dedicated
multiple cores to computing
revenge. Legalities great.
New target quite Capcom it
looks like chivalry to with
a special word from Steve
Pickett CEO and creative
director of torn banner
studios. Hey guys Steve
how're tormentor studios
and creative director I
should read too was just
launched five days ago I'm
so happy to be here the PC
game show. You're free to
if you don't know is the
first person slasher which
is like a first person
shooter except as the guns
and grenades you got sorts
battle axes longbows and
players are fighting it out
on these huge sixty four
player battlefield. It's
all about creating those
epic sword fighting tools
that you see in the
medieval Hollywood movies
and also that huge clash
with our. Master's kind of
chaos and carnage- slash
support plans look like a
mixed of me and- massive
level function updates.
Coming across this year.
One of the things we're
most excited brothers
taking. Two different
errors in the- for we done.
Our closer to the leaders-
any up coming up where you
know you're gonna get a bit
more reform armors fine
this year's you can go into
partnership. Over but we
really want to take players
in different experience in
make each of our maps is
only gamer and make it
something that you don't
need a army would actually
do when they go into a
space. And you know when
you come across the
pristine gardens and this
beautiful castle you got to
tear it all down and in
because- you know as a
canvas for your destruction.
She persia Future is
basically. That is on the
scene and started the
company and its the game is
going to take a so much
further. Post launch
planned for June two the
team at lunch is the
foundation's intentionally.
Built to be extended it's
not just and done we're
going to support a lot with
post. Canaccord is the
first year map that's
coming out post lunch deli
card is going to take us to
hi medieval times or the
late medieval times. Choose
the Kathy and ideals of
being was like noble rich
wealthy place more
prosperous live you're
gonna feel like you're
seizing. London for
worships kept talking to
he'll also be blowing up a
couple ships which is five.
The weapons coming in at
lunch but they'll be more
and more added to it post
lunch as well the new
fighting style is really
gonna change up the
experience and- she tried
to fight every. Content is
something that we're going
to be working on for a long
time. The game is really
going to at least double in
size for. Next up we have
an exciting look dying
light to you. And make sure
to stick around to find out
how you could win a custom
mech warrior PC from our
friends at Intel.
Hi my
name is. I'm migrated
directly in thank EIC to
stay. Today especially
proud of U. S. of the PC
gaming show I'm gonna tell
you a little bit about the
dying light the universe so.
Stay tuned. Every tragedy
begin someone this one
started with a virus that
is K. from around the city
we met in the first Bob of
the game and it's reached
the whole world including
the city wed dying thanks
to takes place remember
January sixth two thousand
twenty five the day later
known as black Monday the
military all the chemicals
to be dropped on the city.
It was a mistake. A huge
mistake. The chemicals
mixed with water penetrated
the soil killing clans
turning to most people into
blowout first few months
this. Don't think of them
as on these go. Down all
EIC hopeful life suffering
people who attack
everything that lives as a
result of their pain and
rage. Those who survived
the chemical rates to creek
to John the roof tops. I
knew all that has been born
in the city people leave on
the rooftops monsters. In
the streets. Nobody in
their right mind would that
to come down. Well let's
say almost nobody. The
exception is the main
character holding right to
pay them. But why is he
braver than all this. How
did he develop such a
unique buckle and combat
skills. Good evening guys I
will gladly answer all
these questions about. I'm
not here to spoil it for
you. Let me tell you one
thing nightmare haunts me
every night I'm locked up
with other kids. I don't
know what he did to me. But
he did. Over and over
looking for something he
couldn't find the worst
part was that he did the
same to my sister. Never
forget her scream when they
separated us. What could I
do. They had rifles and we
were five years old. There
was a fire. Chaos Bandai
soldiers took me out of the
city my sister state. There
my media. We need the item
as one of the many many
children undergoing
mysterious medical research.
The last thing Hey then
remembers from that time
this extreme pain then the
fire and- a little go this
was being tested with him.
Enables me on she was the
system. What happened next
after the fire is still
alive the following
previous home today then
with these questions and
would give the although
leaving her. Moreover media
is the only answer to the
question- a then the really
it's now in two thousand
thirty six we need to aid
in when for the first time
during his pilgrimage he
finds a clue about how to
find his system. Hey then
spat the truth is tough
full of challenges and
adventures. The difficult
choices to make as well as
the consequences that way
too. You're going to
discover them all in
December.
Two thousand
twenty one- that was dying
light to and it looks great
spooky well we are here
back on the E3 stage so we
can get closer to your
comments and reactions to
what you're seeing on this
year's PC game shelf that
is all right Sean so you
out there keep your
comments coming in and as
you're watching this year
we want to get your input
on a subject that usher. In
about PC building so this
year we put a number of
prototype PC is based on
mac warrior 5 bites we're
only going to manufacture
one of them and you get to
pick which custom design
becomes our flagship PC for
this year's PC gaming show
powered by the eleven Gen
Intel core I. nine
processor that is correct
each of the prototype PC is
that you see before you on
the screen are paired with
one of the six factions of
mac or your 5 the free
world's leading the
Draconis combine the
federated Suns the
compelling confederation
and more so cast your vote
now for which faction and
custom PC you want to win
and help us pick the best
design. I am currently
personally pulling for the
drug companies combine
because as you can see by
my beautiful patch I'm the
biggest fan of mac where 5
in PC game show well all
right we'll check in later
to see which group survives
this mac or your showdown
but for now let's check in
with our very own mac pilot
Frankie ward who went on a
special mission to get a
closer look at ceta and
amplitude studios upcoming.
Strategy game humankind. In
humankind you'll be
creating a civilization as
unique as you are. Speaking
of unique it's ME thank you
lord. Do you think.
Wondering how I got into
the game. Let me show you.
You think you can beat me.
Posture all you. I've seen
more impressive and highest.
Get ready to play against
me in the human kind clans
be. Starting now.
Show is
your artificial
intelligence. G. force now
you. Like any solutions on
your device. Nine hundred
games and titles and there
is something for. Police.
First. You wanted. Coming
get. Well it's about time.
Joining me to talk about
forks must die E3 from
robot entertainment is
design director Jerome K.
Jones welcome zero thanks
John glad to be here so for
anyone who's never seen a
horse must die game what is
the force must die series
all about blowers must die
three is a third person
tower defense game so
basically there are tons of
works and bad guys trying
to get into these riffs and
the player has to stop them
we give players tons of
weapons and traps and tools
to do this and while you're
defending the riffs you can
play solo or you can.
Invite a friend in play
cough. Now this is the
third game in the series
what's new compared to
previous two titles there
are two new campaigns but
the main news story
campaign takes place about
twenty five years after
which must EIC to self. Not
only will fans be able to
catch up on any new
developments with the order
but they will also. Place
all some new heroes in our
all new war scenarios which
are these new massive
levels where. You fight
hundreds of works on the
battlefields outside of the
fortress themselves so
you're fighting indoors and
outdoors which is pretty
new. We have a new mall
called scramble it's
basically adding random
elements against the player
making levels more
challenging I want to know
about the toys with any
weapons in the traps that
are coming we added war
machines and work already.
So a war machine is like.
There are these massive
traps like you might
release a giant tornado on
the battlefield or- you'll
climb into a catapult
annual fire. You know giant
work army. And then and
then the war guardians are.
This EIC putting further
warnings on the battlefield
with you to fight with you
except they have their own
attacks in their own
special ability. Well I
gotta ask then when and
where can we play it works
must I three. So only three
is coming out. On July
twenty third on steam
PlayStation and Xbox in
preorders start today so.
You should rush off the
steam now and put. Only
three on your wish list
well thank you so much for
joining us Jerome K. Jones
once again just a few more
weeks to wait for. Must I
three for now though it's
time for us to take a look
at vampire the masquerade
swansong. For 5. He. Nine
he. Get out here.
You come
for me nine. At first you
need to find us. All I want
is to be with my little
girl. Is that so much.
Hello this is certain from
pressure pumping games we
are a Malaysian based indie
game studio working on.
Multiplayer arena brothers
inspired by hi jeans and-
today like to showcase some
new and exciting gameplay
footage oversize correct
disconnection please join.
Let's check out a trailer
full name this gate and
make sure you hang around
almost to its for the
develop the interview was
shown. For total
annihilation we stand on
the verge of extinction.
Spreading across the globe
humanity's last living
generation. Major
scientific breakthrough
there is. Each the project
known as the leftist if we
are to some. First we must
go back.
Three you have
only one mission. Activates
the landscape. Joining us
to talk about lemon this
date is the game director
from rap loop games Canada
it's James Anderson thanks
for joining us James so
it's great to be now let's
begin by asking what the
heck is a first person
shooter turn based strategy
game playing games inside
of a twenty five second
time live so instead of
playing continuously you
play for twenty five
seconds turn by turn so for
example all tickets in the
place of twenty five
seconds and then you'll
take it. Like twenty five
seconds and then we turn by
turn lighted you characters
into the same twenty five
second time with so for
example I might run down
the whole way and throw
their night killing one of
your operatives but then on
the next to you might
intercept my operative
before he threw the
grenade. So we have to
retrieve exam C. can
destroy a classic
deathmatch. And we have a
gamer group domination. Can
you walk me through the bit
of like what if you turns.
To start around looks like
you can see the board you
can see the time that
everything is happening.
And then we both get time
to like observe plan and
then execute. When and
where can we play it so let
us get it will be launching
on August third it's open
for pre orders right now on
steam. And we're coming up
to a open beta in July. The
game will launch on PC and
console both current and
next Gen platforms. Thank
you so much for joining us
James Anderson once again
that is the genre bending
first person shooter turn
based strategy game. Landes
gate. Now we're not the
only one room to the stars
out here. Coming up next
let's take a look at next
space rebels. No man's land
has a technical term called
called. Which means my
friends that space is for
every. One right.
You are
friends thank come on in.
You guys just saw it next
space rebels Hey if you
plan on thank you maybe a
get good enough at building
to up up on orbit but do
anything like. Nine what we
set up our Intel and mac
warrior 5. PC con as you
guys a home to vote for the
winners well just to. House
now with TV. Ross Hague and-
being a- so rip to those
facts. Press after pay
respects. Cetera now that
we means we only three
houses left greet us. And
Merrick so makes to vote
because the winter to turn.
The build of the custom mac
warrior 5 theme PC powered
by Intel. So let's keep the
show move. And next up it's
a- new mid. Are this is war
tales. Hundred years. Since
the rise. And it's untimely
demise. For this troubled
time of foreign facts and
hello roaming land. Because
sketch. Most is.
That was
the debut of war tales an
open world RPG from Shiro
games about leading a
mercenary troop on a
sprawling adventure and
speaking of mercenaries our
battle for the best custom
PC based on mac or your 5
mercenaries continues we'll
be back live on stage soon
so make sure you keep
voting for the PC build you
like the most and head over
to PC gamer dot com slash
and tell M. W. 5 for your
chance to win so. How about
another game announcement
this is E3 after all and
this year's PC gaming show
is sold full game set in
space it's- a little
crowded up there but the
next game we have to show
you is very special. It is
the world exclusive reveal
of XC on a deep settlement
management game set in the
stars and Exxon you
struggle to maintain a
space station stockpiling
resources managing external
and internal threats. And
rescuing the survivors of
other failed expeditions we
think this will be a
brilliant entry into the
genre when it releases so
here is your first look at
it see on.
The earth our
home. She is unique. The
ingredients of evolution.
The. Beyond the safety of
come. She received
something greater. The
person she- which is found.
Humanity destruction. To
today we are paying the
price for this. We know the
taste of a dying world.
Thirty years is not to be
our- the mother does not
wish to see. She wishes to
see. H. to carry on. This
coverage. In. Your courage.
The station is. These. We
are masters. As she into
the. You.
Shine what 1
segment I was you were my
psychic what who's ever
heard of a human sidekick
there are inside catia
believers stuff known
humans- stance and- no no
no I need human side kicks
to robot heroes can you
compute that DevOps. Did
you there is no known
precedents set for human
sidekick. There you go-
embodiments I think it's
time. Frankie can you take
over while I sort this out
I let's take a look at the
next gamer they'll.
Gaming
show she. Be sure G. force
now .com. Remember she
tried creation of space you
can trailer. Hi performance
yes. The special offers
available for a limited
time. Jurassic world
evolution to and- first.
Shop. Aghdam Bob I love you
so much more as a voice
with out of body let's talk
about mac for your 5
mercenaries and joining us
to do so from Parana games
is the senior marketing and
community manager Darren
Katz thanks so much for
joining us. Thank you John
great to be here now the
mac for your universities
July GamePass this time
against it. Even played
back for your- back in
nineteen ninety five.
Thanks for your 5 sit in
the space yeah obviously
those are very rich legacy
of games that go way back.
But in particular mac where
5 pays homage to mac where
two mercenaries. But it has
all the modern design and
technology then I'm super
excited to talk about with
you today well let's start
at the- real basics of what
makes being in a mac and
doing mac on mac combat
awesome. You become a part
of your machine and when
you're out in battle it's
not just a matter of
pointing and shooting at
everything you're also
managing your systems
whether. You're you know
shooting a lot of energy
weapons or missile weapons
that have high heat out but
we got a manager he so you
don't shut down in the
middle of a battle when
you're facing your foes.
You can salvage these
battle mac so if you see a
mac that you want well you
might want to not want to
destroy it completely you
might want to. Take out of
the lake right take out its
own weapons so that the
pilot has to eject and then
you can just take the mac
well the last few weeks I
understand there's been a
whole lot of new content.
Updates to the base game
and a new DLC heroes of the
interfere talk to me about
what's in the DLC. Boy
there's a lot in the DLC
I'm excited about all this
stuff there's a new career
mode when you start with
the DLC you can import your
campaign. Previously if
you'd like to or you can
start over from scratch and
start from any of the
greenhouses- and then carve
your your after the galaxy
from there. There's
speaking about this new
career paths which are
earning powerful upgrades
for your battle next and
it's a really exciting new
feature for me and there's
a new procedural missions
michael highgam beach at
this is. This is a big one
for me- BJD is basically
you're- clearing. A an
enemy base landing zone for
your invasion force. So as
you land on the planet.
You're wanting to take out
satellite- installations
the enemy can't. With each
other- you're taking out
the- artillery in. You're
basically clearing the path
as I said. For your
invasion force which- leads
to a really cool. Ending of
the mission if you succeed
as your invasion force
comes down there's a new
biome called extrasolar
moon which- you know that.
May be able kind of
represented in the image
behind the answer it's a
really cool. Moon or
typesetting we haven't had
before and then there's a
lot of new equipment and
weapons things like-
electronic countermeasures
and other electronic
equipment like- galactic
broke. Mass which is a
little. Like a turbo boost
for Max. New weapons like
family users mac rifles and
stream SRAMs. So a lot of
new content I'm really
excited about. Talk to me
about what are the new
different Max how they-
play differently- that the
seventy charities of the
Balkan dervish corsair
broader to champion.
Charger and Honda MotoGP
but a couple of my favorite
familiar names in there.
Yeah yeah so the first one
talk about as a Vulcan. The
very unique mac it's got-
the nickname the scarecrow
which you'll see from the
profile is just a- very
unique looking mac there's
nothing else like it in the
franchise. It's a forty
time mac. It's highly
mobile in typically it's
used for reconnaissance or
scout missions. Because of
its mobility so it can get
in and out fast you can if
you're looking for a
specific target. If you're
on an assassination mission
for example. Get in there
find your target get back
out. Another mac and I'm
super excited about this is
one of my favorites is the
Marauder to. This thing is
a hundred tons of salt mac.
And it is just huge. Yeah
and it is terrible to see.
Out on the back. Some we've
talked about before modding
I know that may for your
has a body community some
of the I'm mods you see-
there's modification from-
hi changes changing colors
adding Max weapons and
equipment to four. Months
we've got basically I'm a
mac commander mon- in
development that is just
amazing that top down real
time strategy game- so
really anything you can
imagine somebody out there
in the community is
probably working on. People
go to get my four year 5
personnel. Yeah you can
pick it up on steam god
games store microsoft PC
and of course Xbox. Thank
you so much. For joining us
to talk about mac for 5
mercenaries and of course
the warm thank you to my
four year 5 for sponsoring
the PC gaming show. And
giving me this whole
package coming up next
let's take a look it's
still.
Hi I'm rich devote
game director dress
detion to. Following the
incredib succe of the
first game we are very
excited to returno such
an amazi world and bng
u our most authtic
experien. Yea setfter
the events addressablefullyk
alonide iconic character
from theilms alway
birational talen Such as
Bryce Dlas Howard and
Jeff Gollum. You will
ad efforts to contain
ntrol in concert t many
dinours now out inhe
wild. And for the vy
first time you'l be
building parks and
facilies beyond it's t
new law As y explore new
stunning locatns across
the obe. Of course it
wouldn be Jurassic wld
if it wasn't for t starsof s
and we arehrilled to be
bringing to li eveore
thenc spees than er
before. Includi or
iniring flying I'm mine
reptiles To sit back and
allow me to welcome you to
drs it will be pluti
to. We haveo. For god'sbleso
Welayewith genetic EIC
It was A now. Here w
are. Ts i a vydifferent wod.
You jus
w Jassic wor
evolution too andou kno
terll your failed
attets at running adinosaurl
oseeople kild I tnk
is i finaloing to be
thene where you fally
pull it offithout hitch
with aost of nefeatures
a nedinosaurshe sequelfrom e
deep to  an en deeper
manament sim wit a brandnewe
makeure to whlis on
steam now. Pice laterth yeae
mese'veover so fartoy werels
see what yo are tkingaboute
the chatter onocia media
isll aut war tales
Naraka Blapoin and I'm
rprisingly mac warrior
nson aas I have a
feing thoh th may
ange as we hav pley
more to come let's now head
on or to the lks at n
blood teraive. Havecoing. T.
All
it just woun't be e PC
ming show whout a
faasti new new blood
per cut and jnings
fromew Zland.s new
ood CEOave Austriaheay. y gr
yearou knowhat youust
sawas wt newlitz got
goin o forwenty twentyonsomt
knowbout some stuff you
mit n know about andsome sta
to talk aut.ust yetutwhat Ie
it as you know i our ntflagm
shock.ark spates howhis
ll couldoon- and ofcose thin
upda on sorry- that's-
ally great Davaha. Go
this is kind of
barrassing I'm- we-
rried up a little bit I
just wan make surehat
we he enough timor our
ne vid we are. Got a
incomingessa for GabeNewellm
really sorry to t you off
but see you next year. What
I'm sorry at you're
bumpinge. You Bune.
You buing  for gamer.
Gave cdles look hedon't he e
doesn't en go he is
erytng okay. We've
spent yea onhishere
is gamer where is Gewhere im
it take me toabe
Newell. GamerC gamer.
This i't over.'m sureDavid e
and ife's not. Who car
because we ha a special
ssage froaming all
ken away game. Hi thisGamine
opportities it gives us
as developers to connt
with gers around the
wod and highlight the new
anexciting projects we
have comgne of those
for us is steam next fes
an evente're hosting
just a few days to give
players. A chance to try
demos of upcomingames for
free we'll beeaturing
some of theemos should be
saying during this wk's
PC gamer effect and dozs
more here's a look at justse
featured durg steam next
fast. Welcome to steam nex
best where we're showing a
massive colction of
upcomi titles on steam.
During the week of the
festiv developers from
around the world reased
their demos for unified
cotry could only gamer
pain. To go expre the
newest titles. From first
time dads to seased pros
this is the next. Some
etty good.
I bought you
and your cruise every need
glad to have you back
Gearbox you know shower I
wouldn't ever want anything
to come between us me
neither that's a weird
thing to say. Disagreement
over hosting
responsibilities for. Chris
is human or. You know it is
time to look at some
hardware here on the PC
gaming show you know we
keep framerates high and
the Razer accurately traced
building and upgrading your
rate is as much a part of
the hobby as playing the
games we put our heart and
soul into these machines
and if that means using
enough RGB to like the
Vegas strip who's to judge
us this year with the help
of PC gamers hardware
editors which- just you
know we're brains in a jar.
We've picked out four of
the most exciting pieces of
kit set to emerge from labs
soon. First off something
fittingly sci fi. The apple
is a neural control. Aims
to make you a better gamer
by cutting out response
times almost entirely. It's
not quite Alex Vance's
gravity gloves from half
life nor isn't quite up
there with Gabe Newell's
dream of a direct brain to
game interface. But the
impulse is as close as
we're going to get this
year. The glove measures
the signal traveling
through muscles in your
hands to beat your finger
to the click. In theory
it's giving you the chance
to nail that headshot
precious milliseconds
ahead. Of your opponents.
If it works out we could
see a tech like this become
commonplace in the sports.
And if it doesn't let's
hope our neurons at the
very least remain on fried.
Next up you guys might be
wondering what this chunky
beast is so allow me to
introduce you to the
fanatics CSL DD wheelbase
do you want to feel like
you're really burning
rubber at Daytona. Well
then you need a serious
force feedback wheel direct
drive wheel bases gets you
as close to the feel of a-
real racing machine
without. You know having to
have gas and stuff like
that. Historically the
problem with this tech has
been the price which is
involved robin. Car money
on your wrist so fanatic
aims to solve that the CSL
Didi comes in at. Three
hundred fifty dollars which
still isn't exactly a
bargain but it's much
cheaper than its
competitors. And the CSL
the D. is already wowing
Die Hard sim racers. In
overkill to use it for
rocket league but- believe
it or not sometimes less
really is more. If you want
to play the witcher three
on the subway like we all
do you don't need to drag
your tower along for the
ride. Just use the one X.
players away with more
powerful processors have
finally made handheld PC
gaming a reality. Inside
the switch like machine
you've actually gotten
Intel type relationship
with ACSI graphics please.
Many machines are going to
be cropping up more and
more so expect me advances
still to come. Lastly let's
take a look at the suse RPG
three to you Q. acts not
the most catchy name for
this Gaming monitor with
all the trimmings but-
it's- actually one of the
sexiest PC products this
year. That's because this
monitor comes with a mini
LED backlight featuring
full local dimming. The
result is a screen that's
not only fast but brighter
than. The sun. Started long
enough and you might not
notice the three thousand
dollar price tag for those
of you still love standing.
It's time for more killer
games starting with chaos
gate.
You just got the
chance to witness chaos
date demon hunters the
newest Warhammer forty K.
game from frontier and
complex games your fan of
turn based tactics
strategic base management.
Brutal combat or you're
like me and are really
hyped after watching these
austerities animation
hundred times. Make sure to
wishlist chaos gate demon
hunters on steam now to get
ready for the twenty twenty
to release. Next up we have
a trailer for pioneer a
spooky and gorgeous looking
shooter that draws on the
lineage of games like
stalker let's take a look.
Seven please. She.
Yeah. It
shows that there was no.
Stipulations I mean it's
pretty good so we're using
you wish anybody. To
instantly with. But idea
stuff you so. N. N.'s when
since national edition
thank you it's only got a
at the city to their name
you see it's almost. W.
initially. And it wasn't
working as a catch up. I
don't know know the nature.
Thanks it's a. The question.
Sure.
Time is running out
to vote for which custom PC
you'd like us to assemble
so vote now for one of the
remaining mechwarrior
factions by typing in a
chat where ever you at home
are watching so now we've
got another stack of brand
new trailers for you
beginning with a special
transmission from one of
our favorite games based in
space. Eve online. What new
recruits on behalf of
Concord's I would like to
welcome you to the eve
online's academy great job
and surviving so far I'm
quite amazed that you
actually manage to get past
those pirates earlier
you're about to take on the
venture like no other the
stock Razer is filled with
all the caption here's and
it's up to you if you work
with them. Or against. You
can make a living as a
peaceful explorer. Verizon
industrialist shaping the
foundations of east
Condamine. If competition
thing. You can work
yourself up the ranks as an
enforcer. Or prove your
prowess read a soldier of
fortune whatever your
choice we will lose many on
the possible becoming a-
that I believe you have
what it takes to become
caption. The one line you
reporter on. This is you
know it's all crazy
universe where anything can
happen in however you want
to do it. From the CEO of a
the school corporation in
online 5 mind alteration
and we specialize in
manufacturing and
delivering food to the
chips in bulk. I want to be
on the of the people who
are fighting against the
oppression against the bad
guys and it's like a
project you're kind of put
the pieces together by
getting the skills ready
for the ship and all the
modules emancipate the
dream. Tim gettys cloaking
device. And down on the
costs of space. There's
always the threat of being
discovered by another. The
mobile hunting exploits.
Your heart's racing every
day you know for the
clients for all over the
place A. R. C. John. HM.
She teaches TV's or PC
gaming show us 5 guest
writer correct G.
television reporter near.
You should expose game day
there has GVA came out last
week it some of that. Total
into the power plant. Intel
backup supplies and most of
all the **** clans. With
our next step of the time
is right. But today let's
focus on getting their
strength back. This would
be a start. Only really
interested in one thing.
Where is she on. I'm still
chasing. I don't know what
to tell you. Before we into
the lion's den I need to
triple check everything is
ready. The stock value in
position. Band and building
pretty little the entire
power plant. One six not
great arable. Yeah working
somewhere else so your
friends can trailer. That
decision should. Six PC.
Twenty Activision is truly.
Did you see. Sure. Stick
around more trailers
interviews and reveals
coming up.
Or. This. This
session in two thousand.
Was your only option. In
this world RPG on the
jungle the streets. Maybe
if you can infiltrate the
fraction. The syndicates
your team together and
stand. Just find a way off
this planet. Jim. This is
it for you guys this is the
final opportunity for you
you are watching to decide
which of these final two
diplomats warrior fighting
PC's gets crafted for your
chance to win courtesy of
Intel wherever you're
watching the show just go
crazy and chat with the
colored house support
number of the bill that you
want to see so here is
where we are so far it
looks like Carita is at 46%
mac is that 23% and- is. At
30% Are you guys if it is
not the one you want to win
here you gotta get to vote
and we are almost out of
time to vote but there's
still some trailers left so
here. Is the wandering
village.
This has been such
an amazing show so far that
I must ask you my loyal
crew. What's been your
favorite part. I definitely
am looking forward to
vampire the masquerade
swansong- sorry hard to
choose every year. But I
think I'm gonna have to say
humankind. No particular
reason- no doubt for me
personally I cannot wait
for a win this game because
I got to know what a turn
based strategy first person
shooter game even is what
about you. Bob lips. The
end never mind no no no not
never mind what did you say
wait what's system change.
No.
All right you guys this
is the moment the moment we
have building up to all PC
gamer showcase thanks to
your tireless efforts to
spam the chat we have
figured out which custom
made for your 5 PC we are
going to build so thank you
guys out there for all of
your votes to help us pick
the perfect way to
represent this year's PC
gaming show great day nine
can I get a drum roll.
Tommorow can I get our top.
Nvidia. Are you guys take a
look at the actual PC
winning build one more
time- I cannot wait it's
coming up we are going to
take a nice peak at that
beautiful looking PC. There
it is and now that is a
beauty great choice
everyone I knew I could
trust random strangers to
upload on things on the
internet. Help our master
modern Intel we'll get
right to work building this
custom PC and more
importantly. Now that
you've chosen it you've got
a chance to win it go to PC
gamer dot com slash Intel
M. W. 5 and enter for a
chance to win that. Sexy
machine it's for dress and
thank you to our sponsors
for this sweepstakes. Intel
of course the customer PC
will be powered by the
eleventh Jan Intel core
desktop processors that
push Gaming performance
with up to five point three
gigahertz speeds and
deliver the power needed to
gamer. At the highest
level- well we are now in
the home stretch. We've got
a few more brand new
trailers to show you before
we get out of here and
returned to us. First up a
spiritual successor to one
of my favorite games of all
time heroes of might and
magic to a day we reveal
two years ago the PC gaming
show let's take a look. At
songs of conquest.
And.
Wake up sleeping. Dreaming
again. Every cycle you take
your chances you roll your
dice. If you do the work
get paid survive. It turned
out for your friends.
That's. We got steeper.
Your body is not. Land
obsolescence. As an artist.
Eight workers. This. You
can remake yourself. Mario.
With their guns. In their
spells. They're great. For
let. The clans the world
invaded by demons.
Introducing warlocks.
Because this. These. And
there you have it the
twenty twenty one PC gaming
show as I stated at the
beginning it went off
without a hitch huge thanks
to my co host Frankie ward
make a burden and of course
my incomparable side kicked
out Bob there's- okay so
callously. Living
scientists about it might
make me feel what word box
incomparable. Well it's for
the site to. I'm the one.
The second. What's worse
for- you can do this we
just had the best PC gaming
show ever and now you're
going to ruin it all.
Reminders she wore
situations. We.
All my
goodness the DevOps is gone
said seeing people that is
actually going to be very.
Yeah that turned out very
climactic ending well I was
I was well I mean it's
happening in the real world
people just don't know yet-
it's welcome back everyone
building where alongside
Jackie J. we just saw the
PC gamer show awesome
stuff- as always big shot
out once again. To you know
the incomparable Frankie
wore the amazing makeover
and of course the legendary
day nine always a pleasure
to hear from those guys
and- yeah I mean Jackie
lots of games and talk
about. Honestly I filled up
pages and pages and pages
of titles that I love and
we were we're like which
title do we pick to talk.
In post apocalyptic vibes
it had that classic twist I
just was like vibing with
the protagonist yet like
that fade haircut like
wider bluish hair. I don't
know I just loved the look
of this game it was just
giving me the stalls are
field I felt like a kid
again like this looks like
a game that I probably
would have played on super
Nintendo but again with a
modern twist now yeah yeah
and we're seeing a lot of
that as well a lot of games
that. Have that you know
classic look but you know
the H. D. two D. that we're
beginning to see another
one that was sending out to
me came right at the end
was project warlock- that
you know gave me incredible
doom vibes. As the doom
fanatic that was something
that I quite enjoyed I
think something like that
just goes to show like that
style of game is clearly
not going anywhere it's not
it's just as good as it was
then as it is now you know.
Yeah it's nice to see that
we're seeing all these like
a retro like games I mean
the music was definitely
there yeah I definitely got
doom vibes as well like I
was like okay they came a
hundred it was a 100% there
for it. I sacrifice for you
and I both we recommend now
is okay and is that came up
yeah we were. It was a
again we were talking about
this earlier the
combination of two D. and
three D. effects just
meshed perfectly in my
opinion and- again just
like a kid again wanted to
yeah. Twenty twenty one
because anything is the
year of the grapple hook
and also the year of the
Dodge ball game because
dogs barking Daniel was
also pretty pretty fine so
it clearly there is a lot
of stuff to look forward to
and there I say. There's a
lot of stuff to look
forward to in the future.
With the future games show.
Hello there and welcome to
the future game show
powered by W. D. plac. I'm
Laura Bailey but you may
know me as Abby Anderson
from the last of us part
two or- Katie is from years
of work. Today though I'll
be taking a break from
fighting the apocalypse to
bring you a whole host of
exciting game trailers
reveals and updates. That's
before we get into all
that. I need to get
michael highgam host online.
I'm sure going to be
familiar with this person.
He's appeared in the last
of us uncharted god of war.
You name it he's probably
in the credits so without
further ado here is my good
friend and continual
costar. Charlie Baker do do
do do do do do do do do
hello Laura. You look
amazing as always- yes you
may know me from a few
video games- Joe Miller the
last of us or good old
agent Josie from Fortnite
but over the next. Hour or
so Laura and I are going to
be giving you the inside
scoop. A some incredibly
exciting games that also
showcasing developer
interviews exclusive
trailers and a whole lot
more. Including world
premiere there's also a
chance to win a five
hundred dollar gift card
and a W. D. black hard
drive by following the link.
And we have a new addition
to the show this year the
virtual show floor more on
that later but let's kick
things off with the first
world premiere and for
that. We're going
prehistoric.
You can put
hats on the dinosaurs
inspection is expected in
twenty twenty two what's
next Laura next up gross
song of the ever tree is a
sandbox adventure about the
healing power of nature
let's throw it over to
prideful sloth H. Q. to
find out more. Get a for
profit so H. Q. I'm Adam
and I'm Cheryl and where
the design team gross.
Microsoft latest project
that we're working five a
five game grows some of the
infantry is a beautiful
sandbox game about growing
new worlds. Building a town
and bring harmony back to
the land. Will be available
later this year PC
PlayStation Xbox and switch
thanks for watching. Once
upon a time. T. the P. and.
One there was little that
could be done.
Termination.
And our. Song of the at the
tree. What was gross song
of the apple tree which is
coming to PC PlayStation
Xbox and Nintendo switch in
twenty twenty one. Okay
Laura that was extremely
cute but have you
considered more dinosaurs.
You can't just hijack every
game revealing make about
dinosaurs Troy- life- finds
a way. This is a very
different world. Hi I'm
rich people can Direct to
at frontier developments so
you may have seen earlier
at the PC game show where
working on dress or do you
listen to we're really
excited about that and
we're looking forward to
creating the most authentic
drastic experience yet
we've got tons of new
features across four
different game modes
including our original
Jurassic campaign which is
a story set after the
events of dress or falling
kingdoms. You gonna be
leading efforts to contain
control and conserve all
these dinosaurs now running
out in the wild you'll be
working alongside
characters in the films
voiced by regional talent
such as Jeff Goldblum and
in the game we have over
seventy five prehistoric
species we've got new
dinosaurs we have returning
community favorites and
we've added flying and
marine reptiles to get. I'm
really thrilled to be
showing you a first look at
footage from the game
itself this is a from a
species field guide series
videos focusing on one of
the many prehistoric
species we have in the game
this is an iconic popular
dinosaur Triceratops but we
shown you it's in a new
environment never seen
before in dress or
deletion. I hope you enjoy
it and I'm looking. Forward
to that game releasing
later this year. Or the
Triceratops is one of the
most recognizable her
before's to ever have
existed. It is best known
for its trio of facial.
These adorned just for
display purposes the brown
horns in particular can
inflict considerable damage
to any dinosaur that dares.
To that was Jurassic world
evolution to which is
launching in twenty twenty
one on PC PS four PS five
Xbox one and Xbox series
packs and S. okay for this
next section we're bringing
the joys of E3 to your home
with the series of demos
you can play. Right now
that's right Tuesday this
is the future game show
virtual show floor and
remember if any of the
featured games grab your
interest you can try them
out now by heading to the
future game show steam
page. So let's head down to
the show floor where I
believe Laura is waiting.
Yes hello and welcome to
the future game shows
virtual E3 show floor. Just
look at it truly. I am
looking at it it is
incredible they'll Dale
did. You know minus the
queuing in the heat in the
you know. How do I say musk
that's in the air but man
the darkness perfection. I
read enough reminiscing.
Let's check out some games
I'd like to start by
showing you a tale of
paper. This is a striking
platformer from open house
games where you transform
to solve puzzles and an
oversize world dodging
creepy crawlies and
mischievous room as- and
now for another tale of
paper. As you shift packing
boxes in the house moving
sim get packed fully loaded
as you can see it's all
about moving couches. On a
couch with your friends in
couch co op. It's going to
be available on Xbox one
PlayStation four and PC and
is also backwards
compatible. On PS five and
Xbox series X. and S. are
you are you dancing couches
yes. Hey lord you entering.
Sure what do you have. Wait
what's that. L. O. W.
stored story about them.
There's early access codes
go go go go go so about
that drink. Right yes sure-
yeah. Here's a genre
cocktail full of co op
action RPG combat and
finished with a survival
twist has that sentiment. I
said how I heard what you
said. We have about the
gamer this is gate walkers
which sees you and up to
three other players banding
together to tackle
procedurally generated
worlds full of monsters but
you also have to get the
resources to fight hunger
thirst and the dreaded cold.
You like the element cold
got it wow. No one gets
there's enough for another
one year jokes anyway come
over here and check out the
many imaginative worlds of
game thank. This is an
isometric RPG that has you
solving crimes across
multiple virtual realities
were your choices will
shape the world around you
in and outside of the
simulations. Speaking of
detectives check this out.
Backbone is a gorgeous
adventure game from egg not
set in a dystopian
Vancouver where US crack
cases to clean house in
this corrupt post more city.
Plus. If you like raccoons
allow me to offer you more
critter based adventures
with beacon heights set
inside of a magical
storybook beacon pine sends
players to a sleepy
mountain town where you
collect powerful words they
can completely alter the
narrative in this charming
but mysterious tale you
know I'm detecting a theme
with the anthropomorphic
animals. You know Laura
I've always. Her another
set of moods interesting
try to focus I've got a
triple threat of fighting
boxes to show you this is
try fox a charming cartoon
brawler where you fight
waves of enemies as one of
three adaptable combat
classes great. Yes totally
but now it's time to get
serious. Mankind is gone
but the beavers remai
welcome. To timber board.
It's a unique city builder
where players set out to
create the ultimate beaver
society this involves
everything from
constructing dams to
crafting carousels I guess
even book tours critters
need a solid work life
balance that they do that
they do. What's next. The
rest breakers here what.
What was that. Is what I
would say if I was playing
our next game which is a
base building survival game
where you can slash your
way through hordes of alien
creatures look at it- no no
no no. I want to hear more
from voting roots really
cool. Maybe after this
showcase were meant to be
hosting and with that we
reach the end of our little
tour but remember you can
go hands on with all of
these games right now by
visiting the future game
show page on steam. Now how
do we with this is that-
nope well that's not that's
update after that I needed
a bit dismayed lord can you
help me out just a just a
little bit. Agatha we're
back quick note from here
on in when you see this pop
up onscreen during a
trailer it means you can
visit the future game show
page on steam to play a
demo and go hands on with
the game immediately. Then
there are a- I was doing
rocket sides was wanted to
do that is because our next
game is all about float
like a butterfly sting like
a bee check out this
exclusive presentation from
steel city interactive
about EA sports boxing club.
Coming later in twenty
twenty one EA sports boxing
club brings you the
greatest quite roster in
video game history. With
over two hundred fighters
already signed we got some
of the biggest and most
anticipated. Well the
absolute legends of the
sport. The most exciting
names in boxing today. The
first women's division ever
represented video games and.
But what about the game
let's take a closer look at
the next visuals and
gameplay that are set to
make yes we see the
greatest of all time as
good as the for the win for
the grandkids and stuff to
see. Zero condos in a
Gaming posted people up so
I'd say it's going be
quicker. And the mobile
system any SPC is all about
fluidity being able to
create uncles. Recreating
potteries boxes. The
physics system. Doesn't
just rely on automation.
This allows us to recreate.
Realistic knockdowns even
one of by instead you'll
be. It's not. Now we
thought professional boxes
professional coaches come
into the studio by temple.
Through motion capture and
I reviewed the game. During
its development and now we
really feel like we created
a true representation of
the school. Presentation is
important to us just
because we are in the
studio we're still going to
aim high when it comes to
production values. What's
possible coming to PC all
major consoles early access.
Twenty twenty one. He
sports boxing club is
coming to PC PlayStation
four PlayStation five Xbox
one X. Xbox Series X X. and
C. recess. Next up we've
got a deeply immersive
World War two shooter with
over one hundred players
taking part in epic battles
recreated using aerial
photography and satellite
imagery. Let's take a
closer look at hell let
loose. Product not yet
rated. My name's Max ria I
am the founder of black
matter and the lead
developer of hell let loose
hello at loose began as the
idea of a couple of
hobbyist game developers
all the way back in twenty
fifteen. Following a
successful Kickstarter we
launched into early access
in the middle of twenty
nineteen. And since then
we've delivered nine
enormous updates including.
Anti systems over holes six
new maps tons of new
weapons gadgets and
vehicles. As well as
expanding our unique real
time strategy inspired
metagame. As a result we've
been fortunate to sell more
than a million copies
during our first year
valley access twenty twenty
one is only going to be
big. I'm excited to
announce that we launching
out of early access on July
the twenty seven with the
introduction of the Soviet
forces on the eastern front
including famous battles
like custom Stalingrad.
Before we close out the
year by bringing hell let
loose to next generation
consoles hello at loose has
only grown G. to the
vibrant community that
surrounds it. From our
earliest Kickstarter
backers to our newest
recruits. We're excited to
introduce you to this ever
evolving and expanding what
what's your experience we
hope you enjoy this first
look at what's to come.
Hell let loose is launching
on steam on July twenty
seventh and coming to Xbox
series acts and S. and
PlayStation five and twenty
twenty one. So Laura have
you ever wanted to play ex
cons but in real time with
up to seven of your
friends. Of course yep
that's what I thought then
you need to keep your eye
on this next game. Hello my
name is. Zero again this is
amazing creation and for
the past few years we have
been working resources to
game it is a real time sign
documents. Gene park eight
players. Will play I'm
going. We are ready to show
me. Get ready for. When the
need. And have fun blasting
suggestions. You the
executive EIC class
commanding officer with
advanced cybernetic
capabilities you were
awakened to lead a secret
task force to counter the
threat of strong means.
Welcome back executor. The
strolling now inspected all
colonies on Mars build your
squad six classes the
soldiers utilizing their
skills. Each mission type
customize their weapons
intact as well as their
upgrades and abilities.
Using the. Enjoy.
Eight
purge earth of a mutant
invasion in red solstice
two survivors which is
coming to steam on June
seventeenth. Our next game
is about delivering mail in
a sleepy American lakeside
town let's join Dylan from
Gaming us to learn more. Hi
I'm Dylan from Gaming and
it's great to be here at
the future game show we're
currently getting very
close to finishing lake a
game that set in the
eighties. You play as
Meredith Weiss who takes a
break from our life in the
big city to deliver mail in
our hometown. It's a job
you can do at your own
leisure. You will get to
know the people in
Providence jokes along the
way. Today we're excited to
share an example of an
activity after your work
day is done. Movie night
with engine from the video
store. This is fun. It's
been ages since I've been
to the movies. Well they
call it the movies plural
but of course we can only
see one movie at a time. So
which one will it be. My
pick. All right let's see.
Big trouble in little China
blue velvet or the great
mouse detective. All right
I'm ready to pick. The
great mouse detective I
wouldn't have picked you
for a Disney fan- well
let's get in touch with
their inner child. We won't
spoil more and we also can
say what Meredith will do
after spending two weeks in
Providence oaks because
it's all up to you. Blake
is coming first to Xbox and
PC this September first.
Thanks for watching and
enjoy the rest of the show.
We're excited to announce
that lake is coming to
steam epic games store and
Xbox series X. and S. on
September first. What kind
of a showcase would this be
without a new souls like
our next game is a
pixelated take on the genre
following a protagonist
with a giant obsidian's
sword. In the beginning
there was dust and from
that das the move was born.
He opens at idleness parks
before suddenly shifted
right Celestino's chunks
cascaded from the heavens
until. Access from one
prodigious shod owned
humanity and from another.
The cost a great many years
balancing here and
telephone and malevolent
intervene. Vaccines spread
greed and distrust among
his can. Compelling these
calamitous beans to conquer
mac. Centuries of servitude
cost center finally aided
by a failed. Humanity the
great crusade he calls in
prison. The expense of on.
The piece was it was not
meant. For them. Returned
from his. Conducting
atrocious experiments upon
his cage to keep. A top.
With stephanie ijoma. Well
big and- the great moon
witnessing. The final. The
purest obsidian. It has
been a. Customize your
combat style and boss rush
ancient gods when elders
souls drops on the PC and
all current console formats
July twenty ninth twenty
twenty one and now we've
got a closer look at the
next game from the folks
behind war thunder here's
Tom from dark flow software
to guide you through.
Enlisted.
By the thanks
shooting in hopefully a
little trailer has got you
interested. My name's Tom
and I'm part of the team of
doctors software behind a
new game in listed. A
historical World War two
shooter with some unique
gameplay quirks one of the
listed the most unique
features is the squad's
mode. Where you head into
battle with a score of A.
I. soldiers under your
control. You can instruct
them on how to react
enemies and most
importantly you can switch
between any of them
seamlessly with the press
of a button. You'll only
need to respond when you're
in high school it is wiped
out. This way you always
kept right in the middle of
the action. Although if you
prefer more traditional
shooter experience we have
a fleshed out solo movie to
well you only fights
against other players. At
its core eliciting the
former gold middle ground
between the more hard core
an arcade style shoes is
currently available. Times
Achilles cap shorts a bolt
action rifle to the chest
will down a soldier in a
single shot with sub
machine guns and pistols
taken a few hits. Vehicles
as well kind of course be
devastating what have their
limitations. Across
district it's the corporate
view and crew inside tanks
can only use view ports to
spot targets so you'll need
to keep your wits about you
to really get the most out
of these machines.
Progression unless that is
spread over various
campaigns currently you can
fight in Moscow Normandy
and Berlin with Tunisia and
many more coming soon. Each
campaign features new
weapons and equipment
firearms can be improved to
increase several
performance and soldiers
can be leveled up to Roman
specialized products.
Different classes of
soldiers are able to equip
different gear with
specialist classes such as
engineers able to build
structures anywhere on the
map including Forbes
sandbags and barbed wire
fences. And even anti. Tank
cannons on their guns. In
the- aims to keep just act.
In the fall for of
developer. Firearms locate
and uniforms are all true
to history no neon pink
stun guns on Mohawk's here.
Each army will be decked
out with the equipment they
actually used during their
respective conflicts.
Because of the schools
feature you'll never be
short on targets twitch
reflexes and foster actions
will of course have a place
in listed. But even if you
haven't had the time to
fine tune your skills.
You'll easily be able to
come away with a kill count
double digits. The I.
however are very sensitive
and react to sound. And not
to be underestimated. But
not so we've got time for
make sure to give it a try
yourself by heading over to
enlisted dot net slash
joined. A list that is
cross platform and
available now on PC PS five
and Xbox series exodus. I'm
currently in open beta. New
content is added regularly
and no progress will be
white. On the full release.
Once you signed up. Use the
code in list now for free
bonus on us. I've read some
and I hope to see war. On
the battlefield. She is.
That was enlisted which is
available now on PC PS five
and Xbox series acts and S.
next up we've got a full
time student shooter with
fully destructible
environments- and the
protagonist only has one
arm let's check out severed
steel.
Seven field coming
soon on PC Xbox and
PlayStation. Okay no pads
of the reading because for
this next section we're
going to race through eight
exciting upcoming games
that deserve your full
attention here's our future
hits montage.
For twenty
twenty one. Okay I might
regret asking this but- you
want to help me with this
next little Misha. Hopeful
K. exactly recently
announced sonic colors all
we got some PICS. Please
yes. It does okay with me I
did not regret did not
regret it. Hi everyone I'm
Katie golden senior
producer at Sega of America
I'm excited to share with
you an exclusive clip of
tropical resort from our
upcoming release sonic
colors ultimate. Please
enjoy.
Get ready for sonic
colors ultimate which is
racing on the PlayStation
four Xbox one Nintendo
switch and PC on September
seventh moving swiftly on
we've got a new management
came from chuckle fish
where you play as a
powerful artificial
intelligence in control of
the space station. Do you
wanna roll the trailer
truck. I'm sorry Laura I'm
afraid I can't do that. I
know that you were planning
to disconnect me. No it.
Might okay. Here is your
Manser.
We're excited to
announce today that star
Manser is coming August
fifth twenty twenty one and
it's available to wishlist
on steam now Florida ever
since that lake trailer and
thinking have you ever
wondered about the postal
service like that there's
just. So much mail in Hong
I'm not that not really no.
You're saying you don't
know about Jeff and Debra
persia what are you talking
about I was gonna presses
button again hope explains
everything- it will trust
me. He really is a game
about to pee wee birds who
work at the post office.
Their names are Jeff and
Debra. I'm Joe I'm one of
the developers on TV and
I'm gonna show you how I.
Q. we level changes over
the course of the game. So
in this room you're
transcribing urgent
messages and assembling
them ransom note style by
stamping them onto the page
with your- to come back to
this room every so often
throughout the game but
there always be a new twist
to change the. So as summer
turns to autumn now your
word fragments are moving
around on conveyor belts.
No need to charge certain
words and half with the D.
scrambling to get. Jeff
endeavor are gonna have to
deal with all kinds of
hazardous work conditions
got sand storms during the
summer. Male fly swarms
these guys have no respect
for personal property.
Paranormal activity this is
genuine footage of an
actual contact. In winter
the post office gets huge
blizzard now this level
becomes about sharing the
more than a single tiny
lantern to break through
blocks of ice and keep each
other from coming. A little
heroes are going to face
new challenges every level
in every room the post
office whether they're
typing telegrams. Or
packages shipping rates for
helping an octopus or the
mail. It's all in a day's
work for Jeff. Also you can
dress up your calories so
don't say we never did
nothing for you. Leasing
kiwi on August thirty first
for PC and all major
consoles and we hope to see
you at the post office.
Thanks for watching. All
right you got me Troy I'm a
believer coop postal
puzzler see we is coming to
PC and all current console
platforms on August thirty
first twenty twenty one.
Next up we've got a
roguelike with an attitude
a game show shooter where
you earn likes for Duncan-
competitors. And causing a
little wanton destruction
will the circle be unbroken.
Get it find out in this
world premiere.
That was
death row and T. V. you
complete the pilot right
now by heading down to the
future game show page on
steam. Okay hazmat suits at
the ready because this next
game tasks players with
building a team of stockers
to survive a three D.
scanned recreation of the
Chernobyl exclusion zone
here's more on what to
expect internal delights.
Movie shows that both of
these I never submitted
Michelle Yeoh because the
Saudis to me with
michael highgam. Because
the cannibals are. Piece
how easy was the root of
all which is the second gig
this by now apple to put up
a commendable tasting what
is with my BFF- if you
thought it. That's not a
question ought to give it.
Yet okay we should not to
the- minutes about. Top
seven. About on of system
with our share. With that
if double that Isaac. Are
you personal that. You got
to go to the FISA sergeant
and mental. Because of our
gas on. Deal with technical
Chicana. Apple affect. My
with. To the gasoline model
call by I booked Ubisoft
tonight vegan give it a
fellowship of bungie sent
and give it to. Eight
seven. Five presidential
election position you got
without checking- by. The
football is obviously when
you look if you don't
absolute not my is. Not his
computer name used false
teaching. Right to survive
winter no like come to P.
on two eighth as well as X.
and in the summer if were
looking to catch of the-
access codes the verge show.
You can play Chernobyl
light right now but if you
miss them we've also got
more codes to giveaway on
GamesRadar .com. Next up
here are our friends at
team seventeen to show us
what they've been cooking
up with their upcoming PC
and console games. Let's
take a look. Product not
yet rated.
Be sure to wish
list any games that sparked
your interest on our steam
page it really does help
the developer out or you
could also head over to
GamesRadar .com for more
info. This next game has an
engrossing art style
reminiscent of everything
from Wes Anderson movies to
Wallace and Gromit. Let's
throw it over to the slow
growth to talk you through
some exclusive gameplay
from their stop motion
handmade adventure Harold
halibut. Hi my name's so
not and I'm the director
and composer. And I'm older
the games are director.
Hello this is the
handmaid's narrative game
about friendship and live
in the city size spaceship
stock indices. It's been
two hundred fifty years
since your home an arctic
space ship flat on earth on
the verge of Cold War to
find habitable planet on
which to preserve the human
race. Your Harold. A young
lab assistant to the ship's
lead scientist as general.
Well most of the other
inhabitants have reconciled
themselves to a life lived
a box and ship Mario still
works tirelessly to find a
way to leave the planet and
find a new. Dr of course we
don't want to spoil too
much of the story so. Let's
dive into some key plays.
You're able to explore huge
part of the space ship
right from the beginning of
the game. Well the
professor will always have
tasks waiting for you. The
wonderfully with rest of
the veterans will keep you
just as busy. It was very
important for us to not
only focus on exciting
storyline. But to create a
world full of interesting
events and meaningful
encounters. The dialogue
stone only help you
progress in the main story.
But also help people get to
know more about. This
happened over reading
through the narrative
you'll run into playful
interactions like. Three D.
printing your PDA is always
available to you for both
of your current tasks as
well as message from other
characters. This is also
where health personal
drawings are kept as well
as a few more shenanigans.
At this point you might be
wondering how we choose to
stop motion like look of
the game. We are in fact
building every single thing
you see in the game in the
real world. Sets and
puppets and then three D.
scanned everything. Within
able to use motion
capturing to create
lifelike animations for
huge cast of characters.
When the game begins with
harassment in day to day.
Duties 1 counter will soon
clans. Nobody could have
guessed existed in 1
technical. We're really
excited to find out how you
like being immersed in this
unique world the feeling of
puppeteering Herald there's
still quite a bit of work
to do so all we can say
right now is that
Intellivision will come
soonest on PC PlayStation
and Xbox. You can already
wishlist the game on steam
thanks for watching and
enjoy the rest of the show.
Harold halibut is coming
soon is the PC PlayStation
and Xbox. Okay yes there
but if you blew me game so
far so. We came up with a
wholesome chaser I'm told
that the developers came up
with something so sweet.
And so positive that they
just had to call it happy
Gaming. Seriously if what
I'm reading is correct this
one is going to melt your
hearts.
K. Laura hope
you're still there tell me
just. Watch the same
trailer that I did try I.
Yeah know something what
was who the hell is writing
the script yeah I don't I
don't know but- they're out
and- they're telling me
that- happy game- is coming
to PC and Nintendo switch
and. Twenty twenty one-
and- demo is available now
if you want to run. Have a
cheerful joined into a land
of wonder. Our next game is
a gorgeous hand drawn
puzzle platformer following
a young mechanic in a
broken world pay attention
at the end of this trailer
for some exciting
information about the
minute of silence for the
state. Tunnel the old broke
at the same time. Antico
named. She knows what must
be done. In the blind first
came. People began to panic
now the schools are taking
home and remain. Most
families still here however
she is being tossed to
protect. She is the.
Minister of finance. Yes we
are excited to announce
that minute of islands is
out now for PC mac
PlayStation and Nintendo
switch I will be arriving
on Xbox later this week.
Next up we've got an update
from the folks at tech land
who are fine tuning the
zombie parkour of dying
light to let's throw it
over to the developers who
are here to answer some of
your questions about the
game. With more about the
video we just saw in the PC
game show. The video
presented in the PC gaming
show brings you closer to a
ten story. What is looking
for a what motivates him.
How he ends up in the city
of course what happened in
the old franchise between
both good. This is a bunch
of important information
about deal to start. Okay
so we know more about. Look
outside the court complaint
cites quests are important
part of well building in
nightlife to through these
quests you can decide how
the city will look like
thanks to the city I'm
insistent or bring new
opportunities for the
citizens. A great example
is an opera singer that
dimension developers AMA.
Some citizens will support
your decisions some of them
will. But it's up to you to
decide how the city should
look like we have. A lot of
game activities provide for
our players but then this
stage we wanted to be a
surprise. How seamless is
the called experience we
just say that the best way
to experience than type two
is with a friend it could
be. What is cool about the
call is that it gives you
an opportunity to see how
the world changes when your
friends made different
decisions than you. In
coffee can walk in their
shoes to experience all
those differences that's
really there is no just one
way to playing the dying
light to. It's up to. How
are you improving the story
for ninety two. I know we
all have great fun getting
infected. But we also want
to give you a deep. Thought
provoking experience that
will let you be medicine to
deal to world for long
hours. On top of that
thanks to the choices and
consequences mechanics the
store will be shaped
differently. Depending on
the way you play. You've
promised a great open world
that feels a light. How's
it going. Yeah well as you
can imagine dying light two
is full of infected but is
also full of humans with
their everyday life
activities and purposes. We
are building nine like to
around the simple rule
grounds that. Reflects a
life. What is cool is that
and PC's I differently on
each of those levels. Also
their behavior depends on
the choices you make and
the way you play.
Dying
light two is coming to
PlayStation four
PlayStation five Xbox
series acts and S. and PC
on December seventh.
Revealed during the
Nintendo in the world
showcase earlier this year
this next game is a
skateboarding action
platformer here's Simon
Bennett from roll seven to
give you an exclusive look
at all the only world. What
global global. Hi this I'm
sorry but it and I'm the co
CEO of BAFTA award winning
studio roll. Seven right
now we're working on only
only. It's all starting.
You gonna meet quirky
characters of the magical
road trip through Atlanta
and of course had a ton of
new skate. Into your trip
back. But the studio we've
spent over a decade
PlayStation games they
transport you into a state
of total focus and emotion
and it's something that we
very much continue to build
on. With all the only world.
If you played previous
games in the series you
probably pretty aware that
you're going to slam a
bunch before you succeed.
So the place you want to
that challenge is very much
still a new place we'll be
happy to hear that the game
will welcome you with open
arms and ensure that we can
get you off from writing in
no time. Ultimately we
managed to make 5 all the
fun yeah you gonna get
knocked down but we finally
know what mine. It tastes
just that much sweeter.
There's just so much more
flow to the game we've even
added Grimes. Will rights
firecrackers split routes
right to left skating and a
host of insane tricks to
keep your fingers busy.
There's a range of visually
mechanically distinct areas
to explore. Hi to the brim
with a fantastic- cost of
quirky characters.
Beautiful landscapes cities
of course walking trees.
Only only world is coming
to PS four PS 5 Xbox one X.
Xbox Series X X. and S.
Nintendo switch and PC this
winter. Make sure you wish
list it now. That was all
in all the world which is
coming to PC and all
current console platforms
this winter. Next up we've
got a new game from the
team at Augsburg studio
creators of PS VR's the
lost bear. This animated
story trailer will
introduce you to the world
of tales of iron. And
something tells me you
might be familiar with an
area. For centuries and
longer rats have fought
tirelessly to repel the
incessant from. He's only
ever short lived. Until
finally a young. Rattus
first name unified kingdoms
under one. Attendees can.
Swarms from whence they
came. At least. And the
magnificent crimson keep
climbed ever higher toward
the sky. King read is the
senior criminals. In the
kingdom. Apple wants more
his people grew anxious
some claiming to perceive a
faint odor in the air. Your
tass returned with a
ferocious engines amassing
an army of unfathomable
scale. He turned everything.
For the Crimson. King
ranch's skis down upon his
with their claws barely
able to hold the crown. He
had little hope. So it was
decided the crown is to
risk. Your friends with the
kingdom. So. Question the
rating of the iron frog.
Doug anyway entails wired
which is coming to PC and
all current console
platforms. Our next segment
is from pole studio movie
games and hosted by god of
war and twisted metal
director David Jaffe who
recently joined their
supervisory board. Well
hello fellas it's me David
Jaffe great to see you
gotta work with developers
PlayStation stuff these
days and doing some new
stuff with movie games
these guys by you know
they've hooked up with this
great company you have to
fork from Playstation March
one of the best VFX houses.
In the business they worked
on the witcher they worked
on love death and robots
will make it a brand new
game the biggest thing
we've ever done by the way.
It's all about crime and
mobbing mafia in different
time periods going to be
great but for today settle
in babies he's the brand
new games coming very soon.
For movie games. Less from
beyond man this is one of
the- most games I played
last year. That's what
turned me on to move the
games in the first place
which- is the- console from
the version of the erotic
four click classic. First
person action adventure
game that blends
Lovecraftian or with your
freaking around a system I
love this game loss from
beyond. Gamer number two is
called fire commander step
into the shoes the only
real life. God the first
response this game. Is my
childhood fantasy come to
life. This game took me
totally by surprise you're
trapped in the wilderness
freezing hungry and now you
start to go a little bit
insane Maistre seeing all
kinds of crazy stuff out
there winter survival
simulator coming soon have
a great E3 have a great
future games I miss you
guys will see you soon. Oh
my god. Thanks to David
Jaffe and check out
GamesRadar .com for more
about movie games upcoming
titles. This next
presentation comes from the
folks at exceed games the
makers of story of seasons
and room factory here's a
look at their most exciting
current and upcoming
projects.
Tomorrow.
Find
out more about exceeds
lineup on GamesRadar .com.
This next game is a hack
and slash RPG with twin
stick shooter elements set
in a retro sci fi world
here's a new gameplay
trailer for but Torre Las
table.
Victoria last haven
is coming soon to PC and
all current console
platforms and you can sign
up to play the closed alpha
when it launches on July
twenty first now. What's so
things down a bit with a
look at the next game from
the creators of two point
hospital. I think I saw
something about this a few
weeks ago. No no no you
didn't. Here's developers
mark Webley been Hoskins
and Gary card to tell you
all about it and give you a
first look at gameplay.
Introducing two boys. When
we think about what we're
gonna do next campus and
the idea of running a
university or college or
something we just kept
coming back to is a really
rich topics of people often
probably heard of two point
studios may think all
schools absolutely still.
Hospitals if you seen a
previous game isn't about.
It's a Rapala you know we
call it one hospital but
that's about as close as it
gets to be a little bit
medical. Health campuses
taking everything we
learned from two point
hospital I'm taking it to
the next level the
important thing was for us
to give. Hi- canvas that
they could completely
correct themselves in
campus you start with a
blank. We got some called
the- small brush for
example which allows you
to. Drag interesting shape
pathways if you want to.
Try to. Keep things. It's
just really easy to paint
the world should 1 so it's
really simple to drag our
cornfields and lay down
some paths at different
angles and it's fun isn't
it I mean it's having this
kind of city builder
element said. The between
two hostile and campuses
that we spending. A much
longer period with the
students. What we what to
do with campuses. Making
Carabott university in the
idea of these interesting
and different courses are
gonna try interesting and
different students so.
There's a night school
horrible pun but night
school you got it. You
gonna try knights of the
realm- so it won't be.
Stuffy boring stuff that
make you go to sleep at
school is gonna be really
cool interesting stuff.
That was two point campus
which is coming soon to PC
and all current console
platforms. Our next game is
in early development but it
already has a very cool
codename which is always a
good sign here's Leo to
tell you all about project
ferocious. Hello my name is
Neil and I'm the developer
of project ferocious action
adventure games on a
mysterious. Island some of
you might know me from this
with us online the post
office Gaming development.
Tech stuff. And if not I've
been doing BAndai for about
twelve years of a big
passion and after working
on this project for about
two this. Is the first
project of mine I decide to
show to the public. And
even though announces a
very long way to go. I'm
very proud to present it
today to you on the show.
Recently the trailer.
Projects courageous is
targeting a twenty twenty
three release date and
coming to PC PlayStation
and Xbox. Our next world
premiere asks what if doom
guy had a drunk one night
stand with super meat boy.
Mmhm does this next game
wants to answer that
question. For some reason.
Watch out for war cry
challenges when it stops
about gravity and lowland
shoes. Drops on PC this
summer. UP next we've got
another world premiere
Conway disappearance at
Dahlia view is a story
driven detective thriller
set in nineteen fifties
England. Let's find out
more shall we. Robert
Conway twenty second of
June. Nineteen fifty four.
So many cases. This ticket.
Nothing so. Close to home
as the objection of shock.
There are some things that
take us refuse to let. For
me it's. Catherine this
case. She's looking. It'll
be no stopping. I wish I
could say. Service I wish I
could say. I have the
faintest clue. We should.
Sometimes it takes a minute
to record please. If you. I
and in that was Conway
disappearance Dolly a view
from white paper games and
you can dig into the
mystery yourself when it
lands on PC and all current
console platforms autumn
twenty twenty one and with
that we're at the end of
this year's future game
show whoa whoa whoa whoa
hold on surely this this
can be the enemy isn't E3
showcase nope sorry Troy
that's it. Canning I knew
it all right let's see it.
I'm seventeen years old and
it's my dream to be an
actor. And that really is
all we have time for these
are the head GamesRadar dot
com for more coverage and
updates on all the games
you see today and more.
Just sorry really excited
about that said Barlow
revealed- yes and thanks to
our headquarters deputy
black and of course all of
our many talented
developers. And industry
partners that have made all
this possible and of course
for everyone tuning in at
home well we hope you've
enjoyed today's line up end
mark your diaries because
the future game show will
be returning. In August I'm
Laura Bailey and I'm
terrific and this has been
the future.
Twenty one
twenty one. Hello you
beautiful budget gamer
dudes welcome. The clothes
out. Of he three days do.
You want a spectacular
there has been there's
certainly lots of things to
talk about and joining us
is the close the close out
crew crew from yesterday's
close our crew. Jordan at
the end of Phil they once
again I'm Lucy in Tampa
bind it to one of those
Chris combined you get me I
did not tell Taman Lucy
earlier today that you had
run with that joke so I'm
very curious if anyone like
weeded out- anything there
like what what this. Mean
that whether one person. I
highly doubt that if they
were combined anybody would
want this is a result so.
So goes anyways- invokes
Watson thanks for being
here for another day before
we get all mushy goushi and
say the goodbyes until see
you tomorrow- wonderful
things happen today- that's
available but a lot of
wonderful things happen
yesterday but man Xbox you
can say that Kurt. You can
say that. Yeah yesterday
was a week. What it's to be
expected like it with all
the- you know the
awkwardness that we all
like. Love you tend to hate
or hate to love the cringe
factor that so many of us
just like are so excited
for we got it yesterday and
all sorts of different ways
that we're not used to so
we're going E3 for keeping
it up- but- there was with
a different case. Because
we got some J. I didn't I
did like winds one moment
expressly during. I think
the winner of today
personal I'm I did want I
did 1 tell you didn't want
that one okay do you. Where
you all awake this morning-
when Lucy tam and I were on
the show and then. The star
field trailer accidentally
leaks like an entire hour
or- EIC yeah. Yeah all I
can tell you though you
know it's even though this
was not planned for the
leak obviously but as far
as we know we know there's
probably some conspiracies
out there good doesn't Xbox
but doesn't really just
coming out of the gate
having that be the first
thing they did I highly
doubt that was planned- to
try and- get in front of
whatever happened with them
that leak but- good on them
what does this like you
know I worked on their
favorite so- fill any
winced any moment sequence
today before we get into
the- today. So hi I'm I've
been struggling with
strangers in paradise final
fantasy origin. Which is
supposed to have a demo
which I tried to spend my
lunch time planes. And
it's- since nowhere to be
seen it's corrupted it's
broken. They the developers
of tweet about it they're
trying to fix it you know
it's very much like a-
sorry we're trying to
delete it kind of situation.
Not working unfortunate
because like I wanted to
check that out- you know I
really wanted to see the
game in action and like
divorced of this trailer
because I had a rough time
with a trailer like it was
a little. I mean tam and
are Square Enix- follow up
show was just like John
Hanna for being like we
gotta kill Katherine- Killa
chaos Hey have you heard
about cancer gonna go kill.
Him I was hoping that like
we could see it see what
the games like. And
actually play a little bit
and see if it's a little
less in tax. You know in
that way- unfortunately
doesn't work so notice but-
that was a bummer but
hopefully you know we'll
get that under control and-
can actually play that
thing and- see how it. See
how it goes because- I
don't know warriors of
light going after. K. by
the way it happens is that
after- the soldier I have
from back when I was young
you know maybe go to the
moon and we can just have
all. It's only appropriate
that the demo doesn't work
today because it's just
really feeding into chaos.
In the area yeah. You want
a little more chaos and
elaborate so you're gonna
have a demo. And you're not
gonna be able to play it. I
was after some chaotic
energy thank Square Enix.
So we went over some
wincing moments even though
I thought today was wins
free but I guess. You know
a little bit more wholesome
and forgetting these.
Trailer starring corrupted
on the inside. I'm I'm the
spooky kids you'd I'm the
one that's supposed to be
dark and mysterious
anyways- but I do want to
talk about some big wins.
And for me. Xbox just
killed it today- expected
this thing where they
showed stuff they don't
have to really explain how
much they just show up one
thing after the other they
give a starfield they give
us read full he gave me a
release date for
Psychonauts two. Yeah
that's it was like. Wasn't
like twenty six games or
something coming GamePass
like. Everything a total
yeah twenty seven of which
are going to be on GamePass
alright the colleges for
instead I didn't know. The
professional- so feel you
were in on the microsoft
post show but I want to
get- tell me tell me a
thing or two but you like
to see what was what was
your your favor wins free
moment. For Xbox. Meant a
lot of good stuff came out
of that show I really enjoy
that showcase- the halo
stuff. You know I was
saying this- to losing him
I I'm really really excited
for a faster paced halo and
that's what that looks like
it feels like reach. With
that grapple hook you know
which I really enjoy.
Because I get I'm the kind
of guy who gets
michael highgam up from way
down lane. Esther chief
moves really really slowly
and can't jump and like you
can jump but like you know
like he's on the moon. And
why does it. Undeniably all
the time so anything that's
gonna make me move faster
and Dodge more. That's what
I want that's what it looks
like I'm into it- I've
during the Xbox. Man in
this room although I've
come a long way in my old
age- Anna cleared itself
isn't Xbox bro- which has
problems of itself but you
know what. Language just
because someone- what was
let's let's pivot over to
square since Jordan wasn't
on the square response of
things were something you
join we have we have so
much talk about
construction between like
PC gaming. Let's start with
let's start with square
tell me some stuff during.
The year into. Or maybe. I
mean like but why would you
put such a why would you
put me on the spot like
that- you don't have
anything set up you know
you know I like tam I am a
bit of a Marvel guy and-
I'm not. Totally totally
sold on this new guardians
of the galaxy game. But it
kind of invokes a little
bit of those kind of mass
effect the visor your have
one person you have this
party that you can kind of
tell them. What to do what
at powers to use and which
should. Enemy to attack and
so that seems kind of cool
the whole choices seems
kind of cool at the same
time I'm looking at it I'm
like. This really any
different than almost any
other traditional like
western. E. G. that I play
before other than the fact
that there. Marvel
characters and maybe that's
enough maybe that's enough
that I jump into like yeah
this is fantastic but- I.
All the things I think that
we're showing off at.
Square today would Robert
Lee B. that game it's
pretty ball they just like
came out of the park and
showed like that was like
half their entire
conference I thought that
was actually pretty
impressive that they just
like came in was just like
Hey Marvel superheroes.
Yeah yeah yeah they 1 a
little known and you know
yeah I mean like the thing
that has me excited is
that's the writing team the
day day sex- mankind
revolution. Right now I'm
the title. There there's ax
man world. In revolution
and I'm excited yes- snake
instead writing team like
led by a merry tomorrow I
really like their work I
really like that Thursday
at their sex game so like
I'm really excited for. I a
guardians game that seems
like. It seems like a
really nailing that humor
and I know that writing
team does cool stuff and
I'm into it like hi I'm I
think there's a good reason
to. Be hopeful about that
K. you know I think I. Did
it could be the whole
Marvel BAndai thing I can
do. That and that's- that's
what I was about to say you
know I think come it's like
this this is Taurus thing
that- we haven't had a lot
of wins in Mario games- and
of course- with the
exception of spider man and-
it was a vendors you know
people play that game. Even
if for a moment in for a
second. You know he's a
campaign. Yeah exactly I
did it. Okay was there. But
you know I I'm a I'm not
gonna say anything too much
personally the guardians
because I'm fairly- almost
to a fault kind of
skeptical and like I want
to play the game I actually
want to get my hands on
with it and see you for
what it's worth but you
know this is kind of just
like I think a lot of you
two of them really kind of
get the points it looks
like an action game with
some interesting elements
kind of taken from mass
effect maybe even something
as textile stuff. Some
clear choice things that's
cool- I don't care I am.
We're just we're just. Like
I mean I don't want to be a
jerk about I'm just like
I'm those all those things
I hope those warm the
hearts of the people who
want that in the game
either and- the world can
make you know have comments
I mean wanting game like
cigarettes or summer bill
whatever that is. A lot
more of that- yes yes
Somerville. Yes we have you
know play the games- going
off of that thing and you
know because this was
exhausted earlier but why
not exhausted more limbo
and inside are both
absolutely fantastic Jordan
kind of so they have this
Kentucky route zero sort of
wake feeling sprinkled
about and you know- say
what you will about
americana style games but
this one seems to be taking
elements from a lot of
different things that
studio does exceptionally
well in fact if you just
look look at limbo and it
looks inside was just like.
A much better rest a plate
at studio I think it's so
it is a major problem
messing us up no I think
it's Jeff Ronald that airs
radio which is why it.
Looks so much like- let.
Our everyone can't. Cancel
me as- as a- fictional
GameSpot person nonetheless.
Usual successor it looks a
good I'm excited for it- we
do have a lot of time in
this beautiful- seconded E3
but you know the future in
the future game show in PC
gaming vampire masquerade-
swansong we've seen a lot
of Mascarita feeling
recently and not you know
still ever so we have that
sequels announced- last
year or something like
that- thank you guys you
folks took away from that
film. Europe on Denver's
masquerade. Right now I
mean anything from anything
from either way you it's
the I'm just 5 related
epic games. I don't. Really
get a list. It was a lie
both of those back to back
so much that's the thing
like I'm really struggling
to remember all the stuff
we went through today like
so many things are replaced
I think it was called- yeah
replaces the one that don't
really. That really. Made
things go off in my brain I
love. That Pixley art style
like that sort of loan.
Samurai loan going ask- the
story is static okay so I
looked up that's trailer
didn't tell you anything
right so I looked up a
little bit about what that
game is apparently your
like- an artificial
intelligence. Accidentally
or otherwise download it
into a human body. And then
also in the eighties retro
future dystopia. Trying to
survive I don't know I was
like yep yep yep checklist
all the things I enjoyed
some bumps all the words
thank you. Yeah I was like
oh these are all my
favorite words. So.
Jordan Voght anything that
like you said that there
was a game we came out
today. That you were really
looking forward to the
stresses you out looking at
that. My god and I've
already forgotten what it
was called on. Welcome to
the close up through right
through. Hard question to
hit you on the world every
time. The game both come
out in March they had the-
the lady at for whatever
reason in the just
announced during the
future- it game shows like-
by the way is out today I'm
like cool. I actually don't
have time to play it right
now but I'll be sure to
market quite game list I
can get but when. E3 and
play for all is finally
done. It's because E3
announcements hate.
Journalists they hate us.
They don't want us to be
able to have time to enjoy
things I just wanna and
that's great you know what
because there's tons of
people watching this we're
gonna be able to go and
play games. Not that not
the demo for strangers in
paradise. Jokes on you
thank you and again it is
coming on strong- but it is
definitely tough when like
there's a lot of things I'm
excited about a lot of
things are coming out
there's- there's another
team they can on Friday at
Jordan mentioned that. Like
it's just so stressful that
we have the- we still. This
sugary. Yes to agree thank.
There's yeah. There's a
lot. There's a lot. And
that's a good. It feels you
know like- the stars are
aligning things are
happening with. As for.
Other than the games are
coming out like right now
I'm stressing us out like
there's we still you know
twenty twenty to be a big
year- between red fall
starfield- other things. I
cannot DLC mess what is
your yes michael highgam
here- this fall got twelve
minutes this year.
Absolutely really awesome
twelve months from starting
yet right now. And then
supposedly holiday for Hilo
infinite- that's so weird
right that's so that
they're just like holiday
so like any time between
October and December I
assume even like give them
room if they want to
release the single player
first in the multiplayer
later vice versa like. It's
weird he said I was really
hoping they give us an
actual deadline right. Yeah
but I mean multiplayer. I
write a really good who
knows what the change right
so- yeah I know but I mean.
Well we have a moment- we
still have several world
we're we're halfway through
E3 so we still have we have
Capcom tomorrow we have
Razer- we also have a rise
in the morning with right
right EA sports- and then
on Tuesday we have
Nintendo. Nintendo day the
play for all play for all
starts tomorrow because-
know about plea for all
it's our- big old
celebration of. E3 games
also. Good old fashioned
wholesomeness into the
world because repairable
able gamers we're gonna be
doing streams we're gonna
be raising money we're also
have exclusive interviews
with debts- cool cats. We
all got to talk to you be
seeing that all throughout
the week so there's a ton
of stuff to look forward
to- but I guess while I
have you cool cats here.
Tomorrow we're gonna see
just just put put it on to
the universe events
calendar to take the own
Capcom- yes stick to yes-
and I would be down from
any and all resident evil
things please I. Was in
there was my answer what's
that yeah I know I heard
that there's one one first-
yeah like hi there's just a
lot we're we have an
abundance of amazing
resident evil stuff going
on right now with village
we've got reasonable for-
coming to oculus which I
really want to try that I
think it's gonna be a great
time I bought an oculus for
it I was just I was like
alright discussing the
importance of purchase I
ever made was like well
this is that- I guess is
that I'm doing this thing.
And I've also been enjoying
my oculus a huge deal to so
like it's been it's been
present before I think you
can Florence Munich
purchases that have not
regretted yes combine your
games in the long. I like
that thing and now. Yeah
and then you recently
singer. I'm hoping that
we'll start hearing about
village DLC that be great.
Well I want to know what's
going on in that ending
hello I weird stuff still
hanging who's the dude
what's his deal. We hear
about that subject DLC
please everywhere you place
okay and all you do is sit
there just look you cook
them food and have to put
the guns together they give
the youth in winters-
GamePass that'd be
fantastic at two. You have
to get to the merchant
spots before even does so
that your rights.
Everything up because
otherwise- don't exist so.
Thank you- your maps
tributaries going to be
great. I will be an awesome
VR experience to be able to
start to get into the eyes
of the Duke and take out as
many hands and I with the
guns together isn't just
his dexterity Zanzibar
despair distancing. Right I
1 his- his cooking
simulator for sure yes
those meals on again easing.
Cookbook actually Capcom we
get that like out on the on
the internet store please I
would buy that. Jordan your
upbringing a by the book.
Capcom could also yeah yeah.
Mail it there is like no
possible way it happens but-
after the remakes of one
and two and three of
resident evil I got a lot
of people alike remake for
next I'm like remake code
Veronica next. Exactly I
was I was. Out of my chair
and like scream of the
michael highgam the- code
Veronica give me a code
Veronica remake like you
know what village is
basically the spiritual
successor to for like it so
much of or is there it's
hard to see like.
Personally it's a smaller
things like you kind of
give us the four remake and
in some ways release the
reimagining of four. Just
do what does the real
sequel in the series and
you know. That's the- guy
in that game what is his
name Steve or something I
can't all right I don't
like him but do you. Have
what you did for Carlos and
our E3 remake where it's
like oh I kind of really
like. All the seed up there
Sherman union Steve started
shooting here all. With his
two guns blast I mean that
there was a dramatic you
know make your kid and
scored happened to about
like there is some room
there the fix due to for
the better I think for
sure- yeah so that's- just
pull bonkers villains like
yes No. Yes it do a Capcom
but now the tomorrow and
you should get a luxury but
because we saw Kurt fill in
Jordan Voght the close out
crew of GameSpot we're
giving this to you-
anything else Jordan Voght
you we also got- take two
stuff. I don't. It would to
announce Rubio. Take hello
how are you okay do we have
bioshock in the offing
maybe. Well that's right
making a new. I'm
interested drinking that
would be installation I
don't really have to manage
it but I would be
interesting. Yeah I mean
none of us have no idea
what's going. So I mean-
either way like it today
was kind of a- inspiring
take after yesterday while
I was perfectly excited
about yesterday for all
this weirdness as well. I
walked away from today
feeling I was like holy
crap like Xbox. Still there
if they're doing it they're
still I just I don't think
Xbox at about conference in
like a few years to be
honest I've like. As
someone who was. Strain I
so this is me okay like
this is. Someone who
really. Does not care or
has not. However has had a
long. And difficult
relationship Xbox- I grew
like increasingly impressed
with their ability to just
like show up. And say
things and not you know at
least you walk away
feeling. Like he like just
under the sink you know if
you're after year he's
managed to say something in
like we're seeing the
fruits of those things come
true years later. So like
why would have rolled off a
lot of love for just
loading you know video game
nonsense like it's actually
kind of all come to
fruition and I think. That
makes for meeting year over
year this past through-
these past few Xbox
conferences. B. like. So it
was exciting and I mean
maybe square should've went
gone before. Microsoft
exports we would have had
different reactions to that
but nonetheless you know
even if I'm not excited
regarding that storm like-
yes where you just came out
swinging. If you- in yeah
but- in yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Okay odych this is this the
closest to belittle. Well
yeah and then we got. Yeah
right- Phil you know to
talk about that earlier so
Jordan Voght your take on
mac. I am so stoked for
back for but it's one of
those weird things that
were kind of. Like video
game development always
like this weird cycle where
everything kind of happens
over and over and over
again in our in the-
everyone wants to release a
new left for dead style
game we have back for blood
we have aliens fire team we
have. Whatever our team is
working on until maybe like
three years from now I'm
going to be like. We have
another one of these but
back for blood is like the
first one we've gotten in a
very long time and I'm like
yes. Left for dead again
this is awesome this is
cool. I cannot wait. Yeah I
just have so many good
memories of that game-
that. Letter that was one
of those games that like
really defined my college
years when I had nothing to
do except hang out with
friends and play a lot of
video games and like.
Always so good and- I
played a little bit of
this- what. Several months
ago. And it was a lot of
fun I really I really dug
it I really think it's full
of a lot of. Read new ideas
that have kind of come out
of the multiplayer space in
the time between now and-
the first letter delivered
it to. And it's informing.
What's going on in this
game in a really
interesting way it's not
breaking the mold by any
stretch is like very much
feels like. The next
spirituals doesn't next
step on what left for dead
should be. What it's full
of a bunch of little tweaks
that thing that I really
think you're going to like.
Elevate the Gaming in a lot
of ways that you you might
not necessarily. Fully
expect right away that
makes sense right like all
these little tweaks since
like. All these all these
customisations and all this.
Chinese like senator with
your T. and good strategies
stuff. It's all kind of
thing that I really enjoy
like you can sit in a
discordant like talk about
our- our strats for next
time. Kind of thing. And
filter text together and
stuff like I'm I'm- I think
it'll be. Left for dead but
better. In all the best
ways super into that. Left
for dead by better boy
those are some strong
words. Also now seeing.
Yeah well I mean. That's a
man or a boy can dream- I
think it's also they were
able to see the roof. You
know we seems like this
since the protests. Clones
things attempt to try to do
the same even seen rainbow
six. Kind of doing their
own- interesting take just
around the corner with
extraction- but I agree
with you feel that it's
exciting to be able to see
this re visited. Now all
those moons Pat later
because I fully black-
actually left does not to.
I played fairly recently
because I love that game- I
still think it holds up- in
its you know that kind of.
Classic way that valve
games can somehow standards
test of time sometimes- but
I. Am extremely excited to
see how- they're able to
adapt like new styles of
game play that involves
from. All those moves. To
now into black for. Back
for blood end. It's going
to be GamePass game which
is. Laurie a shocker today
in the midst of many many
many many other GamePass
games announce there's also
the other- there's also
another four player style-
co op shooter. For dead is
give those numbers a lot
your **** there's just a
lot well it was like- just
announced like the few days
ago the culvert the pirate
missiles it was like it was
a kind of Funkadelic slick
sixties vibe do you guys
know. And I missed that one.
In Chatham. We've only seen
like one hundred and twenty
games in the last two days
I don't remember every
single one. I guess bird
you don't know the
developer of every single
one of them. Okay well.
Close to a close thank you
both for joining us on this
very hi- chaotic moments
because you know what this
is E3 E3 is mixes all
unhinged we're not putting
a little sleep I'm a red
ball deep I'm headed that
had two cups of calling 1 a
bag a bag of a bag of
cashews- but I think I need
some other food that I
can't remember because I
was just too busy trying to
type things things are a
little bit hectic so bear
with us in this moment but
nonetheless this is how we
close it out. Close enough.
Dreamy and tired cool
because in a chaotic and
hectic and intense. Because
I'm kurt indovina this
jordan ramee this is
phil hornshaw where the
clothes are groovy. But
make sure you stick around-
till tomorrow the day after
and the day after that
because there's so much
happening Tim Lucey and
dave jewitt is going to be
joining you folks tomorrow
morning- needing often to
I'm gonna be coming around
the mountain. For a Capcom
for something other. I'll
be here tomorrow. Thank
you- but of course we got
Nintendo date coming up on
Tuesday I'll be around for
that only between April
stuff what happened you
should be excited- not
because I said you said so
because the universe-
compels you to be excited
anyway so well that's sad
Jordan. Hello join me
thanks for being here today
this revenue. It's been a
pleasure. Thank you for all
right. I'm gonna go take a
nap apparently but 1 just
spent a long day. Yeah go
see the devil works go see
if she's this change of.
That works that means I'm
just thank you folks so
much for joining us
specifically just for a
moment it means a lot he
took the time iter data at
least see what GameSpot was
talking about. Even if you
just have the tune in this
moment- have a wonderful
day drink some water do
some high kicks in high 5
somebody like. The last
time. Gearbox.